what a mindblowing finish to an
incredible game tonight with Charlie
Sanders winning the game in literally
the last second an unbelievable truly
spectacular Charlie Sanders how does it
feel hey y' I want to say something to
everybody watching yo you can do
anything anything's possible The World
is Yours Charlie did you think that that
game was going to end that way tonight
yo there are no limits huh you can swim
across the Atlantic you can jump real
high and touch the moon fantastic
Charlie Sanders fresh off of his uh
Victory it just feel like he's ready to
touch the moon I can fly anybody can fly
if you believe in yourself the way I
believed in myself tonight you will fly
and what's next for Charlie Sanders and
the or kids you can actually fly no no
not well not literally yes literally
kids young kids I want you go up on your
roofs right now wait what fly into the
night sky okay people will see you
flying and you can do anything you can
do do anything okay well we we we uh we
just want to remind the kids that of
course you cannot actually fly kids come
on Yo screw that negativity man hey boys
and girls ages 8- 12 yo don't let nobody
ever tell you what you can and cannot do
all them pre-teen children out there
listen to my voice you are
Immortal okay well obviously we
understand that Charlie is super excited
right now and that no one is actually
Immortal no at all kids you can turn
yourself into a car and have a friend
drive you onto the freeway okay no well
that's just a metaphor kids it's not you
still have the power of childish
innocence get a friend on your back and
make a be line for the next ramp to the
freeway y'all okay don't do it the
freeway he's speaking figur once you get
there ain't nothing figurative about
this you will turn into a robot first
and foremost I just want to say to the
12 families who lost
children I'm sorry my statements were
irresponsible I have subsequently looked
up the terms literally and
metaphorically and found that whereas I
was not incorrect they did not mean what
I thought they had
[Music]
meant economy Plus M for the Discerning
passenger we're not in Kansas
anymore
T good morning ladies and gentlemen we
are about to begin boarding South
Northern Airlines flight 34 to Grand
Rapids okay excuse me boarding group one
I'm going to boarding group one excuse
me I'm in boarding group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first first class passengers
first class passengers only
please next our business class
passengers may now
board okay now we would like to welcome
our Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite
members okay now all passengers with
children anyone with small children you
may Bor
now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why get this is thank you for your
service thank you so much for your
service God bless you thank you for your
service thank you for your service all
right people in
wheelchairs any priests nuns rabbis
imams what why do they get special
treatment Asam I've
never that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with with
[Music]
babies any old religious people with
military babies what's a
military thank you for your
service Jason
schwarzman anyone with a blue suitcase
you may now board finally no not you sir
not me this is a blue suitcase that's a
blue computer bag so you're not you're
not going to let me on
then damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it God damn it anyone who
doesn't seem
cranky drunk people you will now be
boarding any
drunk
people drunk
people all right it's no it's my bag
sir
just
o hello oh hey
Christian
yeah totally well you have your
favorites and I have my
favorites okay call you later cow
Chow boarding group
[Music]
one
anybody Jason schwarzman Jason
schwarzman up your hand F me Jason
Jason I got him I got Schwarz here
everyone Jason schwarzes
by we got Jason Sportsman let's wrap it
up peoples boarding group one over here
get a boarding group
one Berard he's disgusting he's not even
flight he's an airpl technician I mean
come on that's and he talks too much
that's why I like you you don't talk you
just listen it's
good and the captain has turned on The
Fast and seat belt sign got a little
turbulence coming up should be no
problem just remain in your seat until
the sign is turned off thank you for
your
cooperation
okay excuse me I'm going go the bathroom
hi excuse me yeah yeah going need you to
take your seat the fast and seat belt
sign is on I'm just going to go to the
bathroom for a second I'll be right back
okay I understand what you want to do
unfortunately I'm going to need you to
observe the fast and seat belt sign
that'd be much appreciated right just I
I read on the internet that it's not
against the law for me to go to the
bathroom while the fast and seat belt
sign is on so see if sign but is it
against the law though the light is on
is it against the law you see that
there's a picture of a seat belt on that
sign I know but is it against the law
though the fast seat Bel sign is on but
is it against the law though Bel but is
it against the law Bel sign is on but is
it against the law but is it against the
law it's on Bel sign is on
sign sign is so you're being difficult
you're being very
difficult not illegal notal not illegal
legal passal passing your
seat legal sir I have to piss and I have
to Sir can you lower in the toilet can
you lower your voice I have to piss and
I have to okay lower your intensity
you're louder than me you're yelling in
my face sir you're the one who I think
needs to tone it down right now you are
screaming at me you're
hurting my ear
drops that wasn't a word you're not
saying a word there this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue
trick okay sir sir sir if you would like
I would not like to I would not like to
sit down what I'd like to do is go take
in the
bathroom
because it's not
against the
law so I'm going to go to the
bathroom
Okay mark
with a
k
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
I
a
[Music]
and your captain has turned off the
fastened seat belt sign feel free to
move around the cabin thank you for your
cooperation
excuse me oh excuse me sir are you
sitting in
26g yes have I done something wrong no
no no no we just wanted to ask if you
would mind switching seats so that a
mother and a child could sit together
but I'm back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting
here which is an economy plus um It's
actually an upgrade upgrade you say
mhm economy Plus
yes sir
oh don't mind if we do great great uh
carry on carry on yourself Alex thank
[Music]
you economy
Plus for the Discerning
[Music]
passenger we're not in Kansas
anymore to ladies and gentlemen this is
your captain speaking we should be
leaving Topeka in the next 10 minutes ni
stand corrected looks like we're going
to have a smooth flight trust me I know
the captain and he's one smooth
[Music]
[Laughter]
guy of course he knows the
captain he is the captain
Oh Oh move over Colin mockery there's a
new face in the biz his name is
Captain have to be in E comy plus to get
it I
[Music]
guess extra foot
room one in at
least
M Sky shop magos
[Music]
oh dog ears from my
convenience Lord of the Rings
cups Lord of the Rings
[Music]
tables holy shaku
massage economy plus it hurts a little
but but I like
it
Rose
[Music]
butt
and I thought I had an
upgrade
y' hey
y'all h
y' y y Excuse excuse me oh man oh man oh
man I tell you one thing if 911s were to
happen up on this here
plane don't worry we got
this okay I have no idea what you're
talking
about he's saying that if them terries
is going to try something up in here
today like the bounce Boogie and
bump that we
got
on ter do you mean terrorist oh yeah
help yeah baby he ain't talking about
Terry G and I certainly ain't talking
about no terry cloth I mean if a Terry
up on this plane even thinking about
trying to do something we going to Dr
him up you're going to you're going to
what we're going to
dra
SC I think what my partner is trying to
say if any terries come up in here we
going to get our burer on yeah did
something happen or did I miss something
is hypothetical or oh we going to
definitely drop some hypotheticals on
that Terry's clavical cuz I'm talking
about sque sque sque sque
SK SK SK SK don't you just wish so don't
you just wish in Your Heart of Heart
some Terry would come up in here trying
some grab ass and the touchy feing
that's the opposite of what I want to
have happen on a plane okay that's
unfortunate
conference this was unexpected certainly
was I'm thrown right now as to who's
going to be our con
you doesn't have the heart nor the
gumption literally right next to me on
three break
three
youo I got an idea feel free to say no
but can we switch seats I will not take
no for an
answer why that's the combat seat
Jonathan Livingston
seago if you going to be in the combat
seat then you got to be be willing to
blast up on some
carries because with great power come
great respons of
tril okay I just I just wanted some leg
room um okay Max leg room you get yours
meanwhile I'm going to go Hayden Panton
theary on some terries especially when
they get
froggy ribbit
ribbit um you going to have to be ready
to kill kidnap a Terry I don't you going
to have to be ready to torture a Terry I
don't think that's necessary absolutely
you have to fireboard those mother jamas
I don't even understand what that means
do you trust me no I'll take that as a
yes okay
trust these teres come up in here trying
to act
froggy then we going to give them the
Rainbow
Connection and and fr a phone is that a
box cutter oh you best believe it baby
we going to be eating like Diane
K 2.35 in Baby Shi wax perfectly leg
well mhm and if those don't work you
know I'm working up that plan B
brother you a G oh yeah prin of baby
100% polyurethane they can't detect
these mamod
they they have a they they have a weapon
they have a weapon guys weap where you
at Tam about to relax we taking control
of this
place
right
[Music]
my
dra
[Music]
Scout hi everybody I'm Dave stassen
alongside Jeff worthy and welcome to the
annual East West pool as we get ready to
watch some of the best college players
in the nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there Jeff
that's right Dave it does seem like the
most flam buoyant personalities came to
the Forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the
[Music]
East Demarcus Williams University of
Georgia TJ Json Wayne State University
tar is nth King Mary M College to Royal
smoochi Wallace University of Miami Des
squarus green Jr University of Notre
Dame ibraim muus un University of
Tennessee at Chattanooga Jack marus T
theat tricks Michigan State University
the AA T Billings CL K Carolina
University The Jasper proen krux II
South Carolina State University Lear
Maxwell jillions East Carolina
University jabarus Jamar jabarus and
Lamar University of Middle Tennessee
Theo shower handle University of
Southern Mississippi Hingle
mccringleberry Pence state university
lar Petron Duke
Marriot Florida atlanic University the
Dinklage [__] University of South
Florida X Miss Jackson flax and waxon
California University of
Pennsylvania we're going to be looking
for big plays all game long from tyru
smoochi Wallace and let's not forget the
tight ends Ibraham muus and H Le
mccringleberry they've both had amazing
season that's right Jeff now let's meet
the players from the
West vegetarian Jeffers spin Texas A&M
the gler dunach University of Wisconsin
Swan El Gooding Splat saskachewan
University quo quo San Jose State
University osz Buck
Shank Stanford University these a 12
washing beard Jones college Shakira Quan
TGF Carter University of Northern
Arizona X Wayne at alicious Missouri
Western State University sequester
grundle MD Adam State sko philos Raptor
malloys South Dakota State University TJ
AJ RJ back slashing forth the 5ifth
albian
college
San Diego State University donkey teeth
Boise State University
torque lewith Nevada
State Penitentiary the player formerly
known as Mouse
cop University of Missouri Columbia Dan
Smith
[Music]
BYU
I'm Dave Sasson alongside Jeff Worthing
and welcome to the 2013 East West Pole
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right Dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year's Stars a
run for their money let's check out the
team starting with the players from the
[Music]
East cos Nester Smith Rus University
ellipses quarter University of Alabama
nil dewi
LSU bismo funion Florida State
University mang Georgia Tech University
Mar tro scle University of Louisville
Chris busness University of Tennessee
the poop oh miss quack blip Auburn
University gulus
boozler the you mistine Tris University
of Michigan far Trail cluggins
University of Arkansas blon
blasing C cartoons plural Virginia Tech
Jammy Jammy Jammy the Ohio State
University
fudge
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of depz Poopsy and let's
not forget about Heisman winner Jammy
Jammy Jammy and remember you can't talk
about 2013 without bringing up fudge
everybody's talking about fudge at 350
lbs this running back is almost
Unstoppable the whole year you're right
I could talk about fudge all day but
first let's meet the players from the
[Music]
West
Ean
ducklings Indiana University Purdue
University Indianapolis D historious
lorious Utah State University ew conad
sorth Junior steam Oklahoma State
University Exquisite team bé schwisow
University of Nebraska hooka laka Haka
hookah hakaka University of Hawaii King
Prince chamber May Baylor University the
Jennifer
Janis University of
Colorado University of Arizona Harvard
University D
University
Army Navy Surplus Store Wing Days online
classes first name last name College
University God home school
squee Santa Monica College Benedict
Cumberbatch Oxford University a Aon bake
Morehouse
College hey J dinked yeah L
Carron check out
Leah I wonder what he's dreaming about
he is probably dreaming about what we
going to do to the team from the
West I
[Music]
Wonder to variousness T King for short
I'm a bad man and an awful sport
smoochie wace you could call me Ty Royal
wrapping up rushers like aluminum foil
mcing go B I'm very scary if I got the
ball you best be wared lar Patron Duke
Mar I love the ball so much I want to
marry it the E school going to the from
the West oh
yeah where foot conc we going to show
you that we are the best we are the
best I'm ibraim Mo and my Rhymes are
clean like my name was Dr Seuss public
the Third they call me the proe I can
inter balls with my ear shower handle
that's my name power candle sounds the
same with Jack marar Lamar black and
waxon play sax Demarcus plays
guitar E SCH going to beat from the
West okay don't you
know football CU we going to show you
that we are the best indeed we are the
best it must have been all a
dream or was
[Music]
it oh it's
on what's up y'all it's Jeffers I'm the
big left tackle going to help us win
xwing at Aliss I'll use my Force to give
the East distress goodness is where
attack running through the feathers and
patting my stats y'all know me I'm
washing beard catch so many balls it's a
little weird cuz you know we're going to
win against the E what we we going to
get the points and they going to get the
least it's trying to call the voices
running through my head back it up is
hot dck get CH I hit the should be and
make a noise like th can't block me and
all of that jazz cuz y'all don't want
none of this
osati the player TJ AJ Formerly
Known le as Mouse cop and donke I'm the
touchdown man that's grundle but y'all
ain't ready for my man damn
Smith yo yo Smith comma Daniel other
kickers in the leag don't hold a candle
Che your leaders up I'm a chocolate
crotches goddamn baby [__] be y why man
cuz the [__] want to get with me got
swi sweets and dutchies rolling num some
te touchies hitting field goals blunted
been drunk when I ped been like aund
times that I already done it oh see
these haters thought I was playing
staying away from my faces with all the
bull they saying but just remember you
talking when you tossing those gauntlets
I'm Dan Smith and the West is getting
rowdy like
[Applause]
monsters please no no
[Music]
no what what what's what's the joke what
I don't get it man you shot that damn
fool
oh yeah no I still don't get it hey man
ain't nothing to
get is just funny man dude can't snitch
now man don't fake laugh huh that's not
real I could tell no I think it's really
funny no you
don't look at him sitting there all
day
he was 20 and now he's
dead ain't never going to have a wife or
kids now what you doing wife and kids
that ain't
funny his mom and dad ain't never going
to see him
again no no you're ruining it for me
okay well I guess I just don't get it
then it's just that you shot him that's
all that's the whole thing oh okay so
oh the hell is wrong with you you don't
shoot a dude that's already dead that's
not funny oh
oh yeah yeah I guess I just don't get
[Music]
it happy Sunday Esther happy Sunday
Georgina how was your week oh the Lord
is with me but the devil he got his
hands on my grand niece Grace oh no M
they're smoking the reer and doing the
Hanky Panky with boys oh J oh Esther you
know that I love all things that are
good and holy but if he doesn't let go
of my grand niece Grace I'm going to cut
the devil's off and shove it in his ass
mhm with my prayers I know you will
geina I know you
will how was your weak girl oh you know
me I'm blessed and thankful for
everything mhm all right but you know my
grandson Jason got his wrapped up in the
leathery claw of sat not Jason he got
himself arrested for the spray painting
and the vandalism oh Lord and I tell you
I never raise my hand in anger but if he
don't let Jason go I'm gonna punch that
Satan in the nuts so hard it wiped the
licking smirk off his horned ass face MH
with my pray amen I know you will Esther
I know you will but Esther I got to tell
you something else now let it out you
know Esther that I have found Serenity
in the glory of Heaven yes but my
daughters husband Bernard has got
himself wedged between the cleft hoves
of Lucifer herself she opened up his
laptop computer and found the
pornography of women not the pornography
of women absolutely the pornography of
women not on the laptop computer on the
laptop I am a pacifist under God's
request but if he don't let go of
Bernard I'm going to sneak up on that
[__] ass Lucifer right in the midst of
his sleep time and then I'm gonna sit on
that mother head and I'm G spread my
booty cheeks on that Pig's face and I'm
gonna just pucker up my stank hole and
just TS TS TS Scoops scops Scoops SCS
until that got a brown dot on his nose
that I can use for target
practice shoot that that with my prayers
with your prayers of course of course oh
Georgina Georgina Georgina y y y oh I
got nothing but faith in God in heaven
above but I tell you my son's wife
Crystal she got herself wrapped up in a
fiery wings of Mephisto herself here we
go you know she got caught using
profanity with her own children what at
the dinner table oh
Lord Martin oh I have nothing but love
for every creature on this Planet but if
he don't let my darling Crystal go I'm
going to flirt with the devil oh oh show
him a little bit of shoulder how you
doing he going to start looking away I'm
going to start twerking start twerking
he going to be like oh he going to be
going to be drawn in seduce that little
mother him one of these batting my
eyelashes at him then when he least
expects it and I got his trust that's
when I'm going to ride that I'm going to
give him a night of his life a night he
ain't never going to forget I'm going to
give him this way I'm going to give him
that way and then right when he about to
climax that's when I'm going to clinch
up my on that mother red and I'm going
to snap that off with a Divine kle well
you got to snap that off it off with my
PR with your prayers with your prayers
of course with the prayers yeah but
that's right girl you go get them out
Satan him in
[Music]
the what what's happening
Georgina Georgina isn't here
anymore it is
I
[Music]
Satan I'm kicking this
ass oh help me somebody help me I got k
get this [__] get him get him I stuck a
safety pin in this
r that hurts right now I got his in my
hands like a Old Rag
I'm give me some of that I want a piece
of him yet me
[Music]
in is this crazy [__] now it's me
mother your wife's
Nightmare On
Top what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me oh you'll see it
in a second mother wa I'm waiting you're
here you
go I got him good I'll do anything you
say I'll do anything you say too late
dcing come we should probably go oh yeah
start service I got to him I we going to
go me evil on his ass no no I I can't
take it I can't take it off of him
please please get these crazy [__]
off of
me Jesus Christ my personal Lord and
Savior I swear not too late for that
now excuse me I think we're ready to
order well um I'm sorry that's not how
things work in this establishment
someone will come to you yes we're sorry
no no
problem what was that what well where
was black Jeff black Jeff what yeah
black Jeff I read somewhere that when
you dated by racial guy you're supposed
to get the best of both worlds so there
are white Jeff situations and there are
black Jeff situations and that was
definitely a black Jeff situation oh
okay hi folks I'm so sorry for the
weight can I get you bottled or tap
water for the table this evening how
about I'll bottle your ass and kick it
down the stairs man we've been waiting
half an hour for one of you
[__] to show up God I I'm so
I'm so sorry I'll get you a bottle of
our finest Premium Water on the house
that's what I said [__] sorry what are
you doing black Jeff that was black Jeff
but he was just trying to help us oh so
white white Jeff
yes good evening I'm sorry to bother you
two I am the Mater D here at sh HRI oh
yes uh what is it well I am so sorry to
disturb you both but our establishment
has a certain dress code and mad mom's
um deage is inappropriate oh my God
we're we we're very sorry we we didn't
know there was a dress code well
certainly remember for the next time but
there ain't going to be no next time for
you looking at my woman and her her de
CH choc or whatever you said man a
problem here okay see it was really a
simple misunderstanding it all started
with that mother right there who was
disrespected myself and my girl but we
really love this guy and he gave us
exceptional Asser we're going to have to
ask you to leave you have to ask me to
leave oh you going have to ask the black
man to leave huh actually you don't have
to ask us to leave cuz we're want to see
ourselves out and we ain't never coming
back again though we really appreciate
your help that's it Oho mucho watch your
ass man let us reimburse you for that
breakage okay right after I'll burn this
whole place with a mother round with
everybody inside of it by which I mean
you're going to get a very negative
review on
yel this is not just another streaming
app what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you joking me this is
daily late and late late this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great standup great movies and the
great corn Holio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps hi hi this is live sports breaking
news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
[Music]
a all units from status check front of
house is
clear huh did you hear
[Music]
that must have been
nothing
back p is
[Music]
clear
nice
[Music]
now it's my turn to play
a
[Music]
Carol
TIG I thought I killed you the first
time Mr
teue I promise I will not make the same
must take
[Music]
Twi you are a good cat Mr
T but a lousy
fighter
[Music]
no oh snap
Mr snap
indeed
[Music]
te you saved my life no
Carol you saved
[Music]
mine
oh
oh it's
[Music]
just woo great great hike today buddy I
was come up that last Hill and I turned
around you were nowhere to be found MH
thought I was going to have to go back
and get you at least we made
it oh yeah I forgot to tell you I uh I I
talk in my sleep oh yeah quite a bit
actually so um if it bothers you just uh
wake me up okay buddy
oh night
night
[__] you stupid dick
head hey Jordan oh let's go camping come
on Jordan keep hiking we're almost there
oh
buddy so muching energy shove that Cliff
bar up your ass you bald
sucker J
Jordan
you Keegan hyphen Michael Key Jordan
wake up you're talking in your sleep not
asleep
yet oh Nature's going to be so great
once we get shove nature up your ass you
bald sucker and by bald sucker I mean
you suck bald still
awake so what do you want to do tonight
like I was thinking maybe we could meet
up with Amy and Brad and like before
that we could go to Angelo's and before
that we could like just go
bu I have something to
say I had to say it in person because
it's it's like super
important
okay
um I know this is
sudden but like I've been thinking about
this for a
while and I know this is something that
needs to
happen I'm braking up with you cool love
it totally fine with
that really yeah cuz I
thought I was was really worried that
you were going to be like mad mad oh my
God are you kidding me no of course I'm
not mad people grow apart it happens
it's like part of life no I'm totally
fine like love it love it love
it
um
so uh um you know we we had a good
run don't be a
stranger can I
just can I ask
why why yeah like whatever like I'm
doing some work on myself and like
trying to grow as a person so I really
like appreciate to know why yeah um okay
yeah that's like you know I think that
you're kind of like a a controlling
person you thank you for that that's
nice thank you for
that cool no problem yeah so you know
what your problem is Andre what you keep
tabs on
people every little thing somebody does
you have to keep it tab of
it wait I I I can't tell if you're angry
or not I'm not I'm totally not angry oh
no I'm excited it's good it's just like
you said your peace and I just think
that I deserve the human decency to say
my piece right right is that is that not
okay or no no no it's no of course of
course you're a controlling manipulative
person everyone says it I I I I don't
think that I I am yes you are Andre yes
you mother
are okay now now like you sound pretty
angry I'm not
angry I'm not angry I'm fine I love it I
love that you Cav my house and you broke
up with me in my space and I'm going to
think about that every time I'm here
that's great that is so perfect for me
it's the best thing that around me where
else was I supposed to do it because you
won't come to my house here he is the
Puppet Master is back but I'm not I'm
not no I'm not the puppet why are you
doing this to me it's true you won't
come to my house so my apartment looks
like two rats just in it every day oh
right like thank you for that I'm a
[__] thank you I didn't no I didn't say
[__] I didn't all I said say it am I
evil or am I a [__] no no you're not
evil Megan you're not why are you
punishing me I'm not I'm not punishing
you I'm not you broke up with me and I'm
not supposed to feel punished who thinks
like
that I don't know I can't I'm I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay Megan I I guess I didn't
think it through well it's like too late
now I mean we're done no it's not too
late Megan Megan seriously I just I I I
I was I had a feeling that I thought was
true and clearly clearly it wasn't true
I'm so confused like like are you
breaking up with me or are you not
breaking up with me Megan I'm not
breaking up with you okay cool so what
do you want to do tonight like I want to
hang out with Amy and Brad but maybe
before that we can go to Angelo's and
before that we can go buy
some what just happened
let's get this party started ladies and
gentlemen this is Paramount plus this is
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers picked
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and younger this
is everything you've been looking for
that's going to leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
all right partner take the scumbag down
town before the Mexicans find him and
blow his ass away I'm going keep you
alive
Chico
comend
[Music]
l
[Applause]
[Music]
no
w
[Music]
[Applause]
no is that a bird
hey do you know what happened
no
[Music]
oh oh I get it when I say no stuff blows
up
cool I'm good you
hungry I can eat yeah man um what you
want uh Pizza
Chinese kill that noise
man I got a rat
aoui oh [__] that's a rap dude nah it
ain't that's a Ratatouille
yo hey Ratatouille go make my man a
sandwich yeah show them what you
[Music]
got
what the [__] son you let a rat up in
your
house what this
mean I don't know what to say man I got
a r a toi man he a chef just like you
know them movies man no no hey there's
only there's only one movie Levi all
right and he's not a Ratatouille he's a
rat and his name is Remy potato potato
potato I got that's my so ratou that's
all I
know order up damn come on
Levi
voila Levi look at this thing man you
see it got bite marks all over it any
good Chef has to taste his creation
that's rat [__] on the
sandwich he did make a sandwich though
oh hell no I'm out my dude you need
[Music]
help oh well Ratatouille another
negative
review maybe you want it Charlotte
Web to the end of the first quarter with
the Rhinos in the red zone for the first
time got to say Bill I like watching
these rhinos Ransom takes the snap drops
back with good protection and that's a
completed pass to a very wide open
Hingle mccringleberry The Rook out of
Penn State nice grab by mccringleberry
you think he's happy oh boy he is loving
it down there oh we got something of a
shooting gallery going on oh yeah look
at that boy that is something and oh oh
wait we got a flag there is that for
excessive celebration well see and I'm
not sure about that call I don't know
Bill that was three pumps and the rule
book says you cannot have more than two
oh my gosh but look at the kid he's
pleading his case with ref pleading his
case yeah clearly three pumps Coast
Johnson definitely not happy about this
call 5 minutes into the fourth quarter
third and 10 the Rhinos again
threatening to score can the Cougars
hold them big play coming here Bill
Ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and
mccringleberry pulls it down oh he's got
it oh my gosh for his second touchdown
of the day for this rookie he has got to
be feeling great about himself conf I'll
tell you man he's Oh see now there's two
pumps yeah he's really testing the
boundaries and he's clearly gotten the
ref's attention here a third pump will
draw a flag no matter what see oh he
just did it again what now what is that
the second time now you have to flag him
on that yeah he had to you know Bill
it's just frustrating seeing young
players without the ability to restrain
themselves oh it really is it it's hard
I mean the ref's going to get you every
time yeah yeah absolutely uh see now the
ref agrees that's three pumps right
there and the quarterback Ransom under
Center last 5 minutes of the game rhinos
are Marching here again hard to stop
this team from score and build they have
so many weapons Ransom takes the snap
and it's a shovel pass the
mccringleberry oh he's at the 10 he's at
the five and touchdown Rino oh my great
block by hard dunach and that's going to
be tough for the Cougars to come back
from boy what a career day from hangle
MC crinkle bberry the rookie out of Penn
State oh he was just amazingly fired up
here today Jeff you got to love the way
this guy plays and he oh oh see now
there's one pump oh well I cannot
believe this kid you got to put your
team first in situations like this and
mccringleberry's just not doing that now
there's two Jeff now if pumps a third
time he will draw his third penalty for
today everybody here waiting with bed
breath he did it oh did he yes he did it
oh that's just he couldn't help himself
amazing I mean come on in professional
football it's really a shame that's what
it is you can argue all you want but the
flag well it's been thrown that's right
if it's three pumps the ref's not going
to take it away now no he's not duration
and intensity doesn't make any
difference Jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps all right no question
there is the first one right agreed and
then coming
up is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
right here oh yeah you're right there's
absolutely three pumps there oh uh
apologies to all those watching with
young children uh clearly you will be in
room
237 and you have free Wi-Fi there also
from 6:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. every
morning there's a free continental
breakfast m
M continental breakfast yes from 6:00
a.m. to 10:
a.m. so it's Continental then
mhm very
good he
garon a one admission for the
continental breakfast you can just help
yourself sir M interesting European
style
[Music]
When in
Rome the forbidden
[Music]
fruit well aren't you a tiny
Plum well la d da
paper and everything and who are you my
little friend not a spoon not a fork but
something in between a
fon but will you think of next
[Music]
Germany all the European countries lay
before
me where should I fly to
First the pit of the donut M thank you
turkey buckle up let's see where we
shall go next ah the
Danish clearly from
Brussels hello grease where the yogurt
flows like
water M yes like go good but to
stay so good pulling into
[Music]
Spain bakes to Perfection and you
believe this it all comes with the
[Music]
room I love being in continent I love
being in continent I Delight to the
sensus isn't it my friend isn't it
yes I'll have what I'm
having I'll
have what I'm
[Music]
having so good it's so
good dude I got to tell you
something last night on show
times I saw some
some Lethal Weapon to Lethal Weapon to
starring the racist ass Mellie Gibson I
know I know but I got to tell you right
up front and
truthfully racist ass Melly Gibson is
still kind of
[Music]
my he still my I don't know dog racist
ass mly gies I know I know but think
about him man think about it remember
when he jacked up all them mutants and
the Road Warriors talking about like
nothing in here but sand yeah and then
remember when he had taken that hatchet
and chopped up all them England remember
in The Patriot and did it in front of
all his kids you know what
though racist as Mell Gibsons is still
my too remember when racist ass Mell
Gibsons was Blue Man Group and
bravehearts oh my God they was chopping
off my man's head my man was still
talking about
fre or what about conspiracy theories
though oh come on what the about
conspiracy theories though what the
about conspiracy theories though it's
going
on come on you know racist ass Melly
Gibson be directing too hell yeah what
about Apocalypto yo racist ass Melly
Gibson be telling the story of a bunch
of crazy ass oldfashioned Mexican who
had been in the jungle getting chased by
a
pan and what about that passions of the
Christ though passions of the Christ
though passions of passion of price with
racist as Melly Gibson made that movie
about Jesus in a kind of racist ass way
that was on my jam and you know what I
just realized though what's that you
know what would be my what would be your
if racist as mie Gibson's co-starred in
a movie with Jesus you talking about the
the savior of all the king of all Kings
the Alpha and the Omega and
Jesus that would
[Music]
be
now first let me just say that I'm
encouraged that so many of you from the
Republican Party have agreed to meet me
in this way now as you know I've tried
very hard to reach across the aisle and
govern this country from the middle well
all due respect Mr
President we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here if you would I'd just appreciate
some feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country feel free to
agree or disagree whatever you
want we're going to
disagree disagree
disagree
disree first I think the government is
too big I think we need to shrink the
size of the federal government so that
all decisions can be made at the state
level we disagree Mr
President you drive a hard bargain you
win there we
go big government it
is next up this has been a hot button
issue but I think we can settle it right
here no taxes for rich people we
completely disagree round two goes to
you
guys okay more taxes for the rich what
the what is happening to us man I am
taking a beating here guys all right
last issue
immigration now we need to secure our
borders and anybody who's here illegally
should be hunted down and
deported
we
[Music]
disagree we are a country of immigrants
no we need a clear path to citizenship
for all of those who are already
here help
[Applause]
[Music]
me great I love your ideas lastly we
cannot regulate Firearms yeah we can
yeah we can yes we can
we all right all right if you guys say
so now nobody better throw me a
cigarette ain't I a
stinker
W this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you joking me bro this is
daily late and late late this is real
roasted and raw it this is great standup
great movies and the great corn Holio
are you threatening me no this is one
pump two pumps and three pumps hi hi
this is live sports breaking news and a
mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now
streaming Rick nicholby reporting live
from a gruesome scene a cult known as
qet or quest for Eternal truth has
apparently taken their own lives in a
mass suicide police confirmed that
cyanide laced Cherry Kool-Aid was also
on the premises excuse me hi Rick
nicholby Channel 6 hi are you two from
the neighborhood oh
yes
no yeah okay were you two members of The
Cult that lived here the cult what cult
was this a cult right I had no idea this
was a cult say the term cult it's a
little judgmental I would say the same
thing not knowing the full Doctrine well
apparently they believed that there was
a spaceship waiting for them behind the
moon okay well you know that that still
is really possible and it's possible
right I mean who who knows what is out
there in the universe be behind the moon
okay well it appears they killed
themselves in order to board the ship
right and that's where we disagreed with
them right there or would have we would
have disagreed with them had we been
there on on our departure day their
departure day their departure day which
is the day that they did this I mean
that's what you could call it if you
wanted to but I ain't in no cult no I
mean what what I always wondered is how
or am starting to wonder since you
brought this to our attention why if
there was a spaceship in the sky why
wouldn't it just Beam us up beam them up
right say just beam them just beam them
up why can't you just beam them up alive
why you got to be dead to get beamed up
you know what I'm saying I've been
saying that for weeks seconds for
seconds because because you Rick Nichols
B you told us that uh you know and
that's how I knew because seconds 15
seconds ago you said it I I didn't know
anything about it until you have said it
cuz I ain't in no cult okay well then
why would someone join a cult charistic
leaders you know like a
compelling Tac Taco Tu I mean
hypothetically they could have had tacos
on Tuesday which would have been a draw
I mean that would have been a plus okay
so this is a tragic day for this
community and for the members of the
Quest for Earthly truth I'm Rick
nicholby
reporting who you see yep you see uh-huh
everybody jump the gun we're
ready oh my
goodness my goodness how are you doing
girl you know I was on my way home and
was in the area I just wanted to come
say hello that's it that is all have a
nice night so where you going girl you
can't leave without coming inside oh no
I wouldn't want to be an
intrusion I just wanted to say hello
goodbye there is a seat in this house
with your name on it girl no no no no no
no no no no I can't I didn't have money
for the bus I'm a miss from the 50 mile
walk why must you be so difficult girl
you're right I am being difficult aren't
I your life is better without me coming
in trust me so there I go okay girl
listen everything is I man we're good
friends it's all right and you know you
can smell it girl you know you smell it
girl you know you're smelling the fried
dumplings the A and the saltfish girl
was come over you I should have called I
should have called that's situ I'm
formally inviting you into my home now
come
inside
[Music]
hey hey come on good
game
hey get out out of here you get
[Music]
out good hit got
he oh no no hey hey hey hey knock it off
you can't do that guys guys guys listen
know Rafi just got out of treatment
remember we don't want to trigger him
with any
slapass hey what the is going on here
why are we all acting at the funeral in
here no nothing uh Ry you just caught us
in the Lull in the conversation man
we're
happy okay
I was going to say for a second cuz I
mean that was a good game huh good
game hey good
game good game
man good
game
okay there's an elephante in the
room you know I want to talk about
see I had a
problem it was
bad and my lost p i will sneak into a
horse's
stable when you find yourself at 1:00
a.m. in the morning with your hand in
the air and a horse's ass in front of
your face that's when you know it's
man but I'm okay now I'm all better guys
honestly just treat me like I'm normal
okay okay ra have some fun okay it's a
[Music]
game a good
game
feel you can pick up your
glove come on Pi up
[Music]
the hey what I told you huh it's just
normal guys come on I'm fine I'm all
better now you guys can do the normal
stuff be yourselves B things over pick
things up
you know do your stretches touch your
toes you
stupid
excuse hola
amigos my name is ruin I just came over
from the the Braves farm team I'm from
the Dominican
Republic I'm really excited to be
working and playing with you all go
rhinos
welcome to the squad it's good to see
another all right we're going to need a
bigger
boat really put your locker right next
to my locker huh I I guess
so you got this B so spending an awful
lot of time down there there you hey I
have a lot of stuff yeah a lot I see
that you can do this oh my
goodness you okay there buddy not
looking too
good I am feeling a bit flushed you know
I got a good feeling about you maybe we
could be good friends maybe even the
best of
friends maybe another
time another
place but not here
not now well either way we're teammates
and so anything I can do for
you ask away got it okay go rhin
yeah oh
no
no I want you yes I you can't have this
SL you can give me the this
SL you cannot have this SL
SL that's what I'm so
excited I'm so
excited I'm so I know so scared I
know it was just too hard to
resiste
okay are you
okay I'm okay
okay
okay hey guys you know maybe after a
game Victory we could all go dancing
right
[Music]
huh
slers so I'm doing this like airline
food diet it's like all I eat and I've
lost like 16 pounds oh my God Amy I
almost forgot to tell you we got a new
receptionist at work e no way yeah so
I'm in the common area alone minding my
own business yeah oh she said something
to you she came up to me and no joke
she's like hi I'm Sandy I don't believe
we've met yet she said that to you like
no Amy I'm not even kidding you she's
crazy um yeah no like I'm scared like
crazy like get this [__] away from me
she's sociopathically bat [__] crazy oh
my God that totally reminds me I have a
new neighbor ew yeah she comes over my
house she knocks in the door with like a
a package under her arm um stalker much
um yeah and she looks me in the eye and
she says to me um excuse me I think the
postman dropped this package off at my
house by accident she said that to you
yeah crazy [__] I mean like I'm going
to have to move because this [__] is
nut Burgers mcloney Tunes stand at the
foot of my bed with a knife crazy oh my
God that totally reminds me you remember
that girl at Starbucks the crazy one no
a different one she's new I haven't met
her yet well she's crazy uhhuh she gives
me my change and then she's like thanks
thanks
bye she smiled at you like that how
crazy is that that's like that's like
insane in the membrane crazy like like
this is the membrane she's inside of it
cuz that's insane no like I'm not even
kidding you Amy that's crazy like it
puts the lotion in the basket or else it
gets the hose again cray to the mother
cray yeah like if Jay-Z had a sister her
name would be cray hey you ladies want
to meet Channing
Tatum is he really in there are you
serious oh Channing oh my go Channing
what are you doing in a van eing crazy I
don't see you Channing where are you
hiding you in here Channing are you like
in a little
ball smell like mil do in here ow sharp
Jagged Rusty Edge is that a meat
Hut I'm the leader of the Free
[Music]
World but I
all right everybody Focus up look this
party tonight could be a model for the
way that the world should work and I
just want to
say I'm totally stoked to the max about
it all right you guys feeling good yeah
good Dennis what are you shooting video
yeah man all right well be careful with
that I might run for office
someday now trust me I think that this
party can be the most inspirational
party this campus has ever seen is that
coming to me and just grab that
and some righteous Bud some righteous
Bud we got going on there we need some
Bodacious jock babes coming in we need
some hot ass punk rock
babes I don't care where they come from
the most important thing it's imperative
that we have a diversity in the uh uh
[__] Department intercepted don't sleep
on bario a don't ever sleep I'll bury
up that is some major
[Applause]
doobage a parde is totally gnarly it's a
gnarly institution where is he Dennis he
come on here get this get this okay we
we got to have a system in place to get
everybody weed all right so just watch
this is how you're going to do it all
right this this is I'm really Frosty
right now by the way this is your
Constitution all right it's just a piece
of paper we got to keep its Integrity
cuz it's going to hold everything
together this right here this is us this
is the American people we're special
we're magic hello yay we all live in
here all right the most important thing
is that we don't get too far apart me
and you we we got to be close that's
that's the magic of America's love
otherwise we're going to get air bubbles
in there it's going to start canoeing
and everything we don't want that all
right you get that all right look my way
ahead you but I'm already done boom
fireworks 4th of July that's for you we
want like 10 of
these oh my God I'm so
waste I'm
so oh what was I
saying when I roll down the street
Brothers all taking eat Honey's dropping
their G wanting pieces of me cuz I run
this whole block with these Rhymes and
this Glock make this whole damn hood
tick this my time I'm the talk [__] of
the Walk I'm the boss and the King
[__] kissing my ass and [__]
kissing my ring what's up yeah oh [__]
you know it's true
yeah I'm the leader of the Free
[Music]
World
[Applause]
president
how thank you and may God bless
America all right couple introductions
we get CH here this is John oor nice to
meet you John Mr Ian Roberts nice to
meet you petero all right nice to meet
you Jerome Smith come on brother what's
up
fam you know this Heath Williamson nice
to meet you Mary Woodberry nice to meet
you J Martell nice to meet you sir Tasha
Robinson come on come on come
on feel that Emily George all right nice
to meet you Daryl Stokes come on what's
up fam how you doing all right never
forget about that cuz that's all we got
meet you nice to me you all right oh
bring it in bring it
in start from the bottom now we're here
yeah nice to meet you all right nice to
meet you all right nice to
meet one black afternoon my Octon come
on bring it in there tuck that I'm in
here dog I'm in I'm in here do you tuck
in
there you you I'm in there I'm in there
I'm in there all right nice to meet you
man uh nice to meet you oh my goodness
look at this oh she is so beautiful
M I want another one there you go
precious beautiful beautiful what's her
name oh this is Livia rui okay nice to
meet you miss ruie all right come on
there he is
Boom all right B good to meet you here
we go right this way
sir come come on my man's been up 10
minutes okay the number pressing now no
just hold on a second Malia all right
just hold on a
second sorry everyone it's uh taking so
long Obama Obama how you doing
sir it's me just showing my daughter how
to use the ATM having a little trouble
with the machine oh you're having
trouble with the machine oh man we
tripping we're tripping right now man so
you can be on your way no no no no no no
I'm trying to show Malia what life is
like in the real world here all right so
just do me a fav favor treat me like you
would anyone else in this situation okay
yes sir yes sir all
right hurry up man it's your time stuck
in a damn machine
[__] not exactly what I have in
mind go
on didn't get
your
D damn come on girl hurry up man you got
seven oh okay take your time take your
time take your
time all right you're doing fine sweetie
now uh Malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop hey
okay so in the future you want to try
not to go through stop
signs okay just remain calm now and uh
what you're going to want to do is pull
up right here uh next to the
curb this is this is why we want to stay
in the lines and we want to follow
rules remember
this
license and
registration
holy Mr President yeah yeah just uh
teaching Malia to drive here well you
guys ran a stop sign back there but
that's okay you can go no no no no no
Malia's got to learn what it's like to
drive in the real world here now this is
called consequences Malia now I want you
to go ahead and treat us like you would
if I weren't the
president not exactly what I had in mind
[Music]
oh honey I am tired I am going to bed
good night
uh
well is everything
okay well it's uh it's just that I was
uh hoping that uh well that we could and
uh I want to make this clear uh I want
to be uh straightforward I want to uh
have a okay uh Luther are you available
to translate yes ma'am
I really was hoping we could spend some
time together when is the last time we
had sexwoman reelection night what does
a brother not named Bill Clinton have to
do to get some in this house well you
have been very busy lately mhm mhm you
know what if I could just can we get
your translator oh yes certainly uh
Kendra yeah honey could you please
translate while you have been very busy
lately
sure my Ain one of your limousines that
you can jump in and out of whenever you
feel like I don't see you all day then
you want a booty car I need an emotional
connection thought this was uh romantic
I'm try [__] can't you see I'm playing
a romantic music I got the Peno and the
glasses what more do you want from me an
engraved invitation from my nuts
maybe we should make a date what am I
supposed to do jump out of my clothes
every time Little Bear stands at
attention you ain't my commander and
chief mother and my vagina ain't some
cave in the Middle East you can fly your
heat seeking missile into whenever you
feel like it well I didn't mean to call
you but I I had meetings all day long
I'm dealing with these mothering
Republicans hearing no no no all day
long then I come home and you not going
to let me get my jam on up in here well
you know I have had a busy day too you
act like I ain't got nothing else to do
I got these obese mother on my ass
247 what's more important you getting
your wig de or some 8-year-old fat ass
collaps in his buunk bed okay you seem
to be forgetting job number one you are
my secretary of [__] get to
work you
Luther Kendra yes sir yeah we'll uh
we'll take it from here absolutely yes
sir ma' good night thank good night
man oh this feels good um Mom Dad I know
you already said that I can't go but can
I please go to the party tonight Malia
use your
translator if you don't let me go to
this party I will get a tattoo on my
face have
[Music]
fun now first let me just say that I'm
encouraged that so many of you from the
Republican Party have agreed to meet me
in this way now as you know I've tried
very hard to reach across the aisle and
govern this country from the middle well
all due respect Mr
President we disagree with you we think
you should run the country from not the
middle well that's why we're here if you
would I'd just appreciate some feedback
on some new ideas and directions for
this country feel free to agree or
disagree whatever you
want we're going to
disagree disagree disagree
first I think the government is too big
I think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree Mr
President you drive a hard bargain you
win there we
go big government it
is next up
this has been a hot button issue but I
think we can settle it right here no
taxes for rich people we completely
disagree round two goes to you
guys okay more taxes for the rich what
the what is happening to us man I am
taking a beating here guys all right
last issue
immigration now we need to secure our
borders and anybody who's here at
illegally should be hunted down and
[Music]
deported we
disagree we are a country of immigrants
no we need a clear path to citizenship
for all of those who are already
here help
[Applause]
me
great I love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate Firearms yes we can yes we can
yes we can we
can all right all right if you guys say
so now nobody better throw me a
cigarette ain't I a stinker
[Music]
welcome back we're here talking with
All-Star shooting guard Charlie Sanders
about his amazing career now Charlie you
grew up in a tough neighborhood didn't
you that's right drugs violence my whole
life I had to deal with adversity and
that continued when you went on to the
pros that's right you know fines
injuries everything no matter how big a
star I am I'm always going to be dealing
with with adversity adversity Johnson
what's your take on this I don't know
girl I just like with it ah come on
adversity deal with me
dog I deal
with always wherever we go
it's come on no don't don't drink my
water don't drink my water and first you
leave me some leave me a sip leave me a
sip damn come on man oh deal with me
this he doesn't I'm sorry no he doesn't
pick up social
cues what here
[Applause]
we ttty twister titty
twister come on are you okay no a
mindblowing finish to an incredible game
tonight with Charlie Sanders winning the
game in literally the last second
unbelievable truly spectacular Charlie
Sanders how does it feel hey y' I want
to say something to everybody watching
yo you can do anything anything's
possible The World is Yours Charlie did
you think that that game was going to
end that way tonight yo there are no
limits all you can swim across the
Atlantic you can jump real high and
touch the moon fantastic Charlie Sanders
fresh off of his uh Victory it just feel
like he's ready to touch the moon I can
fly anybody can fly if you believe in
yourself the way I believed in myself
tonight you will fly and what's next for
Charlie Sanders and the orang kids you
can actually fly no no not well not
literally yes literally kids young kids
I want you go up on your roofs right now
wait what fly into the night sky okay
people will see you flying and you can
do anything you can do anything okay
well we we we uh we just want to remind
the kids that of course you cannot
actually fly kids come on Yo screw that
negativity man hey boys and girls ages 8
through 12
yo don't let nobody ever tell you what
you can and cannot do all them pre-teen
children out there listen to my voice
you are
Immortal okay well obviously we
understand that Charlie is super excited
right now and that no one is actually
Immortal no at all kids you could turn
yourself into a car and have a friend
drive you onto the freeway okay no well
that's just a metaphor kids that's not
you still have the power of childish
innocence get a friend on your back back
and make a be line for the next ramp to
the freeway y'all okay don't do it the
freeway he's speaking figuratively FKS
once you get there ain't nothing
figurative about this you will turn into
a robot first and foremost I just want
to say to the 12 families who lost
children I'm sorry my statements were
irresponsible I have subsequently looked
up the terms literally and
metaphorically and found that
whereas I was not incorrect they did not
mean what I thought they
meant I've ever seen in my life you know
what I
mean why you reading
[__] because I like to read and this is
a really good book you're a really good
[__] [__] why you got to bother me man
because I'm not doing very well at
school I'm reading at a third great
level I really don't want to get left
back so when I see somebody reading for
fun it makes me feel that much more
stupid and then I get
mad um I didn't know that thanks so much
for opening up to me shut up
queer I don't understand why I mean why
you got to go
there I've been having sexual fantasies
about some of the other guys at school
what give me
that I'm afraid of these feelings and
what they might mean it's like because I
I hate myself so much I got to point
that hate outward towards
[Music]
you you understand this on such a deep
level that I don't understand now I'm
going to punish you physically for
acknowledging my emotional problem wait
wait I was going to say if you
understand yourself so well then maybe
you should try working on changing it of
course I want to change it but it's the
only defense mechanism I have against
deeper more terrifying problems buried
inside of
me
you lucky my Dad's here get the damn
Chuck son I need to take you home and
beat on you cuz I hate myself and you
look like your mother who left me and
I'm going block out the guilt I feel
over mistreating you with the river of
vaka I'm going to internalize that and
unknowingly transfer it on to you
[Music]
tomorrow coming
reluctantly let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
plus this is Strokes of Genius beautiful
games and One Shining Moments this is
Defenders investigators and seven
strangers pick to live in a house this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and
younger this is everything you've been
looking for that's going to leave a mark
live sports breaking news and a mountain
of entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now
streaming
[Music]
hey what what what what can I get you
hello sir I would like a Raman
Coke ran Coke coming
up
[Music]
where you
from oh all right baby I'm going see you
on the dance floor girl
oh raming Coke be $8 $8 all right my
good man let
me let me I'mma got it I got it
just you all right
okay I tell you what third times the
charm
brother there it is there it is yeah
just just take the card out keep that
open for me can you hang on to the for
me we'll do in fact let me get a tequila
shot brother actually make it two man
one for me and one for you my good man
shut
two tequila shots coming right up how
you doing G all right nectar of the guys
up in here all right all right let's get
that going there all right cheers we
going
cheers
H not no hold on bring you there more
than one way to skin a cat you want some
help with that hold up let me just try
to get up in
here
a that's burning my tongue you know what
what I'm going to get you one of these
yeah try that there we all right hey you
a genius let me get this going on
here just want to there you
go buy your conal my darling all right
all right move Dr around here yep hey
yeah
so uh I'm worried about you oh I'm going
tell you what I'm worried about I'm
worried that this club ain't popping off
the way it should be what what cuz I
wait a second What uhoh DJ Turn It Up
that's my trap right there
uhhuh hey man a bar is not the place for
you to be right
[Music]
now let me get two more shouts to tequ
uhuh sorry pal you're 86 what how and
what
best be gentle
with oh it hurts all over how you doing
girl for first time I think it's like
87 two guys in a heavyweight bout yeah
no it was the first time in a
heavyweight bout that the uh two
fighters ended up getting
married hello my good sir I like to have
two shs
[Music]
te come on brother way omark oh man
are you kidding me no seriously you got
to come back in the bar right now you
come back in the bar I don't even know
Claire I'm sorry you left your jacket
yeah well why don't you give it to your
new fat ugly girlfriend all right I
didn't even matter yet whatever you left
your jacket Megan oh throw it in a river
why would I do that I don't care I'm
over it
fine God
M leave me alone your jacket though
seriously mean you start buying drinks
for everybody as soon as she comes over
I mean who does that you can come back
to the bar you're literally an [__]
how is that possible I can't be an
[__] I got arms and legs in a head
where's my jacket I have your jacket you
want it no you know what eat it why
would I do that you know what I'm not
following you anymore done F over it
fine Megan come back to the barn no
mean no Megan
uh-uh Megan do you want your jacket no
seriously come back to the bar you go
back to the bar I'm going to throw this
jacket in the water oh nice that's
really nice what do you want me to do
Megan damn kiss my butthole okay good
fine fine then I'm going I'm leaving
right
now God damn
it m no like seriously your jacket no
but it's your jacket though
what
[Music]
mean
no I have
your I have your
jacket I'm over
it seriously
[Music]
me
all right listen up Sheriff's
Department's close by we'll be safe
there okay stay close I'll get you out
of
here oh my god oh they got BR they got
BR they got bre they didn't get us they
didn't get us
okay we're still alive right keep it
together yeah okay we got to make it to
that sheriff
station oh my
[Music]
God we got to go through them stay
together keep moving and don't get bit
go
[Music]
are you getting this Y what is up all
right let's go let's
go this is
[Music]
crazy what
um
ain't that some these are some racist
mothering zombies why would you even
lock the door I mean the window's broken
in oh oh hell no no no
no oh come on what is that they
seriously wouldn't let her eat us that's
hey guys isn't this great these racist
zombies are leaving us alone come on we
having a
party
[Music]
the beer is
here and look who I
[Music]
[Applause]
Bo man you are so
man wow we need a crazy V like you in
our
game with this
bandana I welcome you to the game yo
hold up okay what's going on hey
Kito uh I was just welcoming Eduardo
into that
game why who he what he did he's he's
crazy man we we were thinking that the
gang Miss a crazy guy yeah Manan this
guy is lo show
[Music]
himo locco huh no no I'm the local one
in this game what okay okay check this
out quack quack quack quack I'm a duck
I'm a crazy duck no carito carito is not
that kind of locco okay that's more like
you know zany or or goofy yeah it's the
wrong kind of Loco you want to see Loco
Kito you're not crazy you're like uh The
Quiet One I'm not quiet I never be being
quiet in fact I'm always loud check it
a okay okay that was
weird were you yelling I saw you Lo up
right here right down in broad daylight
Yoo up your pants homes I got tiom on my
underwear that's the black fish I'm
naked and I don't even care you got to
pull them up okay there's like children
in this neighborhood okay okay but check
this out I got nine punch cars from froo
Universe each with a one stamp in it
every time I get a yo I get a new card
yeah carito that's just being Cavalier
with your finances instead of collecting
your free dessert I mean that's not
local that's just like financially
irresponsible I might not be local but
you know who is local my friend Mr
basura
head just bumping the garbage hey I'm
the most local person in
here carito why would you do that okay
carito oh
carito you don't have to do this okay
it's not necessary you're not the local
one check this
Outfield yeah I'm crazy I'm the local
one gito please don't do it again Kito
stop I'm me to D this is like watching
the British version of the office like
it's funny but awkward and sad at the
same time
yes oh well I think I just proof this
bottle is
unbreakable Kito you're embarrassing
yourself look at this no no no no carito
what are you going to do with that I
don't know I'm too
crazy carito why would you do that man
that was local but not in an
entertaining way
okay
okay Down the Gun the
G Put the gun down
stop
Theo you just Shoto in the
head n the most local in the game yes
carito by process of elimination you are
the most local person in the gang
yes he
the he CAU the bullet in hise that's the
most loest thing I ever
[Music]
seen come now Mary
Magdalene stand and be forgiven for your
sins but
Jesus how can I be
forgiven I'm a prostitute no
child you were a
prostitute that life is behind you now
Mar magaline where you at [__] oh no
Jesus I think it's my pimp I think he
found
me there you are man it took me forever
to find your ass I've been looking all
love for you you know how many [__]
named Mary there are been here now get
your ass in that Caravan no no I'm not
going with you Gala Leroy I'm going to
stay here with Jesus what the flip is
this you washing this feet maybe what I
taught you that I rescued you from the
fishing Village I cleaned you up and got
you out to work and now this all you
repair me you go get yourself another
pimp hell no brother She's mine I don't
think you understand she's not going
with you well I can't afford to lose her
I already lost three [__] to leprosy
all right all I got left is Mary a
[__] and two blind chicks who
actually you know they get requested a
lot don't ask me how that works get out
of here I'm not going with you galile
Roy I'm staying here with Jesus and I'm
warning you Jesus has like 12 followers
tell them oh
12 okay all right so this mother a
serious pimp no my friend you're
confused it's 12 men uh are you a gay
pimp I'm not a pimp I'm a
carpenter
carpenter then why does your house look
like I've been busy with non-c carpentry
work okay that's it [__] pack your get
in the Caravan and make me some money no
and I don't have any stuff to pack Jesus
says we don't need things what the is
this all about money hell yeah it's all
about money
brother I have a saying oh it goes like
this you're going to love this shut up
it's easier for a camel to pass through
the eye of needle than for a rich man to
enter the kingdom of God oh yeah well I
got a saying too it's easy you know why
don't you pass your own pass your ass
through the needle man you man come on
girl STS
what what the I slap you and you want me
to hit you on the other cheek that ain't
gangster this it's crazy you can have
them I'm
done wait
friend so you know that there are no
hard feelings would you care to join us
for
dinner what y'all
[Music]
have
I am your
substitute Mr
nostrom but that might as well say No
Nonsense because I do not
play now today will not be a day
off in fact today you will work harder
than somebody call a cold Brown up in
here see you later Mr Po
all right fellas coming to the stage
next the beautiful
galaxy hey
baby hey
[Music]
baby it's going to be for
you keep it there more where that came
from too trust
me that's my girl oh damn I'm straight
up talking about some Daryl daers right
here here because this some chocolate
thunder what girl Make It
Rain yeah oh yeah I TR to make it
[Music]
last all right girl a I'm going to get
it right in the booty right there uh and
booty SW that's that's what you call a
booty investment CH brother you really
don't need to uh uh give them that much
I I don't think they're expecting all
that woo it's kind of like feeding a
squirrel you know I mean they they will
come come back to you so oh oh oh my God
some of this is getting lost let's get
it right where it need to be right in
there baby oh yeah keep it
classy keep it classy oh somebody better
get an umbrella cuz I can't stop making
it rain it's like it's like no one flood
up me here woo two by two baby two by
two baby you don't know that om the
general cuz it's storm and Norman that's
what they be calling
[Music]
me
damn anyway like I said when you finish
training we get Scotty muo up in here
that you can train a
boxing oh Lord have mercy you don't know
nothing about this Make It
Rain are you an idiot Leon get this guy
out of here all right nobody
move there he is there who is you on
your feet on your feet what I do you're
under arrest for photocopying money oh
God damn it you know how long it took me
to cut all that out got carpel tunnel
syndrome up in this [__] callus is on
the inside of my thumbs that's
definitely real
though this is not just another
streaming app this is so much comedy
it's not even funny are you joking me
bro this is daily late and late late
this is real roasted and raw give it to
now this is great standup great movies
and the great corn Holio are you
threatening me no this is one pump two
pumps and three pumps hi hi this is live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
Comedy entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming the right triangle's longest
side is called the hypotenuse and it's
this side here
hey I wish I were high on pot new three
sides I wish I was high on partt
[Applause]
news okay okay oh Mr Morris it's very
funny it's very funny but let's get back
to the
lesson if you can see the longest one
where it goes from this point that was
my joke this is I know man that was
hilarious triangle I've labeled them
here A B and C no but I mean I said that
laed anything I said it say that they're
a and so I said that please please Mr
Jackson keep your comments to yourself
thank
you now the hypotenuse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it thison you really got me on that one
oh so great oh oh principal Martell
principal Martell come here come here
come here tell principal Martell what
you said Troy oh uh um she she was
talking about the hypotenuse and I said
I wish I was high on pot
news I'm
sorry he likes
it principal Martell's
cool that's very funny principal Mortel
principal Mortel I I said that Mr
Jackson that is enough what I said it
first oh uh Mr glacius Mr glacias yes
come in come in yeah yes what up
peoples comedian Gabriel glacius is
touring the local schools today for a
charity he's working on tell him what
you said tell him what you said oh I
wish I was high on pot
[Laughter]
news oh my God that is clever that is
very funny very funny right no thanks Mr
glaus Mr GLA
I'm your biggest fan that was my joke uh
you know it's not really cool buddy to
take credit for other people's jokes Hey
listen funny stuff I'm doing this big
tour right now you want to see about
maybe we could talk about you opening I
need an opener uh um sure what do you
think is that okay of course of
course
what talent man nice for me to than so
much like a Richard PRI get over here
man come on Richard
PR
he deserved it all right so across from
the longest side is a 90°
angle good thing I've got a 90° dangle
Joel stop it you will never be Troy why
are you trying to be like Troy
dick at two nerdy
girl so the
hypoten is's going on I would miss my
Fant I would to miss my fants right here
oh my
God good evening my fellow Americans
every day our citizens improve the lives
of those around them today we honor Troy
Morrison now Troy was in geometry class
when his teacher mentioned the
hypotenuse of a triangle Troy said I
wish I was high on POTUS that really
cracked me up and it cracked up the rest
of America too so today I'm pleased to
present Troy with the Congressional
comedy Medal of Honor Troy on behalf of
the entire country I just want to uh
thank you for your fantastic
off-the-cuff line you are a true comedy
hero thank you sir thank you and also Mr
President I have uh something for you
what's
that oh got one yes these are sold out I
I haven't been able to get my hands on
one of these thanks Troy oh my good I
man Tyrell about to come out here right
now watch ladies watch this watch this
yo Ty real yo what up Lawrence hey man
you want to play front hand backand I
don't know that game man it's easy dog
all you got to do is say front hand or
back hand all right front
hand bam I got you
sucker oh okay okay I see how it is man
come on man come on you know that was
funny
backand huh it's still my move right I
choose backand this time really back
hand God
damn look T I'm sorry but I ain't sorry
you know what I mean I mean you asked
for it I mean you literally asked for it
front hand what no why you
I got it I figured it out front hand no
back hand back hand look look dude hey
if you want me to slap you across the
face back hand I'll do it okay don't
think I won't do it but but you know
that I'm with you right I mean there
ain't no game called front hand
backand
oh oh D yeah I get it I get it all right
all right all right as soon as I get
good at front hand back hand you want to
stop playing play what man I made it up
so I can smack you you in the face I'm
about to smack you in the face as soon
as it's my turn back hand there ain't no
turns cuz it ain't no game you ain't got
no game back hands
[__] Bri
hand look I don't know if you with me at
this point or
what but I don't want to
smacking no
more where you going then okay forfeit
forfeit I win I win front hand backand
okay me and you me and you me and you H
backand damn she was fly she all right
yo man can I ask you a question yeah
what why everybody messing with the
Batman's see that's exactly what I've
been asking myself it don't make no
sense why would you do it why would you
do that why would you try and mess with
the Batman it's futile it is remember he
ledgers try to I mean mean the Batman's
got armor and you know some martial
movie work I got armor and then martial
arts come on all you got is a purple
suit and some pancake makeup come on man
I mean come on man why would you mess
with the Batman that's what I'm saying
man remember when Danny devitos tried it
walking around talking
[Music]
about come on man I mean the Batman is a
multibillionaire with a grudge you just
a little fat [__] in a tuxedo
with an umbrella exactly it's like a
pretend bird can't mess with the Batman
no way no way out of the question man
Jim car cares though Jim carries though
Jim car riddle me this riddle me that
man's how's Ace vur going to mess with
Batman well play how's Ace V well played
hey Batman I've come to get you yeah now
see how are you supposed to block a bat
rang from going in your butt with a
carefully crafted query you cannot
that's how it's impossible hey hey AP AP
Michelle puers Michelle P Michelle puers
tried to mess with the Batman Michelle
perers triy to mess with the Batman
Michelle perers Michelle guess what
Michelle fers you ain't a real cat come
on I'll tell you one thing ain't no way
you going to meow with the Batman but
what about Arnold Schwarz Niger what's
arold Schwarz [__] trying to do what is
AR huh feel the burn feel the burn feel
the burn it should be in your trips come
you can't turn up the AC and think
that's going to mess with the Batman
what are you supposed to be doing to
Batman giving the Batman a cold giv the
Batman a sniffle talk about bat loss and
you're Defeated come on come you know
there is one person though oh no no no
here it come now there is one person who
could here it comes right now no here it
comes could did and Sh again the
Batman here it comes he trained the
Batman he gave the Batman's his skills
he's a mirror image of the Batman's in
fighting Power I'm talking about Roz Al
that's right right there talking about
straight up Raz Alou played by the
incomparable
Liam so even when we are talking about
the
Batman Liam is
[Music]
[Applause]
my hello my fellow Americans with me as
always is is my anger translator Luther
hi now the first year of my second term
has been a challenge
cluster tonight I'd like to address the
concerns of the American people over
what they perceive as the US government
spying on their digital and electronic
activities man you're all some deluded
self-important mother if you think we
interested in your deviant porn watching
asses I can assure you the American
people we are not reading every
individual email rather we're searching
for key words that would indicate a
threat and don't worry everybody those
key words are not girl on girl anal
squirting
plopping
plopping what the is plopping you dirty
mother these key words are being used
amongst other things to prevent
terrorists from using weapons of mass
destruction not prevent you from
watching videos of ass destruction now
these policies have already foiled
numerous terrorist plots these are not
the kind of plots that y'all are used to
like when a guy comes in the door with
his penis in a pizza box and a lady
sucks on it and I assure you that the
country's gotten safer since the end of
the Bush era and I ain't talking about
the
president these policies have allowed us
to probe and
penetrate Luther just what I'm trying to
say is that there have been numerous
terrorist cells fingered you got Luther
okay Luther why are you trying to
undermine the president with your
juvenile sexual window the average
American has nothing to fear from these
policies now if we was drone striking
perverts our country would look like Mad
Max Beyond Thunderdome right about now
I'm talking about a post-apocalyptic
nightmare thank you and good night go to
sleep
y'all plopping oh yes sir when you
oh y'all are some sick
mother the Second Amendment of the
Constitution states that a
well-regulated militia being necessary
for the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed here here
yes please gentlemen we need all of your
signatures
gentlemen a point of
order what if someone made a gun that
could shoot say 50 people in 30
seconds Congressman Peele we have many
orders of business today one of which is
not judging your sense of humor
prodigious as it may
be then one
man would be able to walk into a crowded
area and kill scores upon scores of
people before anyone would have a chance
to stop
him Congressman P where are you getting
these hairbrained ideas how could you
possibly know
what the future
holds because I am from the future I
know what this amendment will bring and
I cannot let any of you sign
[Music]
it
I did it did you see the the muskets he
had magnificent and me the quill so I
can draw them before I
forget
damn
it I've been trying to reach out to you
all
day are we on for
tonight jeez what you can't catch me you
can't catch me I'm Lance Moore touchdown
[__] what
pause
oh shoot Keegan's been texting
me sorry dude missed your
texts I assumed we'd meet at the
bar whatever I don't
care sorry dude missed your texts I
assumed we'd meet at the bar whatever I
don't care
whatever I don't
care the is his
problem do you even want to hang out do
you even want to hang out oh that's
consider
it like I said whatever like I said
whatever this guy Jesus you are
Priceless
a you're the one who's
this this mother right
here oh he wants to mhm MH
okay you want to go right now
huh guess I could do
that okay okay let's go he said okay
okay let's go all right you know what
you know what you want to really do this
now Keegan h nut you're not putting me
out yeah let's do it oh you [__]
first round's mine oh no oh no they
going to beat no rounds [__] it's
going to be a street fight this son of a
cuz tonight we going a
party no buddy like I said first round's
mine a beer and a gimlet for my partner
right what's
that uh I got I I got you a baseball bat
with Nails in
it for my post-apocalyptic Jackie
Robinson
costume okay all right everybody just uh
let's settle down settle in and like
just totally let's get our math on okay
all right guys so
um all right J somebody's got a little
extra energy from fiz head
right Jimmy buddy hey buddy let's okay
it's just let's knock it off
okay
okay you got me he got me right guys
Jimmy did all right let's take our
[Music]
seat that's great that's great that's
great very good Bravo JY I'm just
kidding you guys can
clap that was awesome oh and I thank you
I I thank you for the entertainment
[Music]
man let's go man hey buddy I don't want
to harsh your Vibe man
but I'm going to be honest with you
really pushing my buttons now
Jimmy driving me
[Music]
crazy you want me to write your name on
the
board
hold hold okay Jimmy do you want me to
call principal
Martell that would not be bitching would
it okay you know what tiimmy you know
what why don't you come up and teach the
class man H wouldn't that be
awesome yeah come on
up no and then you know what I'm going
to do Jimmy I'll just here how about
that Jimmy and then we can all watch how
you're being
disrupted oh I see that's supposed to be
me right all right Jimmy okay I see that
I get it supposed to be me it's time to
be done Jimmy don't you dare Jimmy
what oh yeah oh
yeah
well this is you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
jimy about that jimy oh I'm going to
slap five give me five give me f huh how
about that huh that's you Jimmy I'm
Jimmy
I'm Jimmy and I need attention yeah I'm
Jimmy I'm Jimmy oh look at I'm baby
movie that's the funniest thing that
ever happened in the whole world I'm
Jimmy I want attention
wyy I'm Jimmy I'm
Jimmy Mr fire principal Martel no what
no no no no no no it was Jimmy it was
Jimmy principal Martel no Jimmy it was
Jimmy
it was Jimmy it was
[Applause]
Jimmy j j j j j j j
j
[Applause]
thank you for meeting me here yeah of
course you know just glad we could set
aside our differences and you know avoid
a war here you know salute all right
[Music]
salute whoo whoa whoa whoo whoo
and no don't do that we we're trying to
avoid a war here oh a
no that's too much what are you doing
we're just having a nice little dinner
here all right well that's just
disrespectful oh no not his hair Anthony
he had good hair yeah you're done you
already messed what is what's going what
are you doing now this phone no no no
don't go deleting his contacts he's not
going to know what to answer it or not
you're finished now that's that's good
look what you did now we were in the
middle of something and now what what's
going on here what are you doing oh
that's permanent that's a permanent
silly mustache a now he looks like a a
sleeping musketeer that's adorable but
it's it's ridiculous he can't he can
hardly wash that off that's whatever
what you go what is that n what the what
are you doing yeah you putting in his
hand that doesn't even make sense here
that doesn't even make sense oh oh
Anthony oh that's hilarious but save
that for a slumber party all right what
do you no you're rearranging the
silverware that's just so mean that's
it's confusing it's confusing enough
what with the anony anony don't do oh
well you know the salad you get a little
pepper so that's good that's that's
that's not so bad you finally did
something constructive what are you
looking for what are you you're putting
the silverware back that's good well
that that's good now he knows he can go
from outside to inside and that's oh you
put a little Z in his ha that's good
yeah Z it oh now what it actually looks
better than when he came in if he wasn't
unconscious he could go out on the town
so that's good that's good oh look yeah
all right wipe off wipe off his face
yeah yeah get the mustache while you at
it cuz that's that's the most
embarrassing part oh he doesn't look
ridiculous anymore oh okay now that's
that's now you're helping everybody
that's good for everybody everybody
likes that nobody wants lettuce on the
floor all right we done all right you
really turn this around anony there we
go all right and in your garment all
right all right he won't even know what
hit him he won't even know that any
oh no no no no no Anthony anony I can
see it in your eyes I can see it in your
eyes you're going the other way now
anony anony it was going so well well
that's that's that's perverse anony I
don't even know what what's that what's
that what are you going to do with that
finger what you oh yeah no not W wiie no
Noy oh we're going to war and we're
going to war we're going to
war
good evening my fellow Americans you
remember my anger translator Luther why
hello now I've told Luther that he can
join me for this last address but that
his being on his very best behavior is
crucial to Healing The Divide in this
country keep it chill Luther go against
every Natural Instinct in your
body since we last spoke the country has
voted for a new president
Trump here we go come on man come on
come on really it's talk about the Trump
how did this happen man get the [__]
y'all going to B the dude that's going
to make America hate again don't you
understand this is how the hunger game
starts no it's true we all have to
accept that we going to have someone
else call in the shop
Vladimir Putin y'all we got a naked rusi
on Horseback going to be running the
show bbo russing [__] it was a
close election but the people have
spoken yeah they voted for Hillary
Clinton but then this outdated Electoral
College mumbo jumbo Voodoo [__] I
can't even it's more imperative than
ever that we move on as a country united
united in the fact that we can't [__]
stand each other even as the country
adopts new policy
uh on
trade immigration new policy the only
good immigrant is a smoking hot white
one plagiar eyes of
speeches I said
[__] now I have greatly enjoyed my time
as your president except when um you
know um let me think about let me think
when the Republicans wouldn't let me do
[__] and then that one dude said I
wasn't born here and then y'all elected
him so you know what didn't love that
part so much so pretty much the
beginning middle and the end
suck I have met with President elect
Trump and have pledged my support in his
transition he doesn't even want the job
y'all I saw it in his eyes the dude was
shook the only reason he ran is because
his Factory in China made too many Red
Hats it's the
only
reason I assure you that if he succeeds
we all succeed unless he succeeds with
all the [__] he promised to succeed with
in that case we're [__] and now a Time
cherish tradition is that the outgoing
don't say outgoing don't say
outgoing that's me damn it leaves the
incoming president a little note in the
desk of the Oval Office of course it's
completely confidential go [__] yourself
until now oh that's my
bad
to all of you out there who are afraid
that your way of life is under attack
remember that progress isn't always a
straight line no cuz sometimes it's a
line that goes like this
goes and then just goes straight down
for four [__] years stay strong and
never stop standing up for what you
believe in uh yes I would like to book a
fouryear stay for five at the Ice Hotel
in Sweden please sorry five for B I mean
yall going to take B make it six in some
thanks America it's been real it's been
good but it ain't been real good
apparently Orange is the New Black good
luck with your health care [__] I'm
out
peace I got my eye on you [__] Grabber
[Music]
yeah
can you totally chillax I'm so annoyed
right now can you like not talk to me
for like a second like that'd be great
that'd be fine that'd be fine by me what
oh my God are you serious this is bull
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in check your
girl bro excuse me what did you say
check your girl uh-uh it doesn't work
like that no one checks me because I'm
not luggage okay so you can
go yourself Megan serious l two more
people are going to come out in a couple
of seconds and then we can go in no let
me ask you a question what was it like
being in The Green Mile he wasn't in The
Green Mile it clearly wasn't in that
movie what does Tom hanks's penis feel
like Megan moreover how does it feel
when swarms of bees are coming out of
your face seriously I'm sorry it's like
our favorite movie don't apologize for
me yeah this is nice this is nice you
look like common meets The Incredible
Hulk when you brought the frankincense
to baby Jesus did they like make you
stand outside the barn because you were
too big or did they invite you in with
all the other animals don't flare your
nostrils at me okay do you have any idea
how impolite that is he hasn't moved his
nostrils once since we got here I saw
them move they did not move Megan they
flared Megan they did not move your
nostrils flared more than a Survivor
from a boat accident what he's not even
looking me in the eyes okay you know
what if you're just going to continue to
be a little prick you're going to get
your ass kicked don't touch him
Megan crazy
[__] totally love my nails right
now go over everything right now over
the floor I'm over the sky I'm over you
over that [__] back there you're a
[__] mean seriously
burn
um excuse me oh God hey what did you say
what the did you just say you guys come
back here with your little itty bitty
dicks you best control your lady yep
excuse control your lady no he doesn't
control me cuz let me tell you something
I'm not a remote maybe can we just let
this go no I'm talking to the [__] of
Anarchy right now yeah you why don't you
all gather yourselves and why don't you
just go and figure out a way to on each
other's leathery PE ey hey you
[__] it's not even the plural of
penis yeah I'm the queen of the
world yes I feel Invincible like I have
superpowers or
something you hear that all you ass of
the world I can do anything I want and
no one can stop me guess you don't have
to fight your own fights you crazy [__]
oh
boy oh
no oh
nothing can stop
me hey man this is your first time no
man I've been doing zombie extra work on
this show since day one first season man
my first time oh was your first time on
this show my first time being extra at
all ever kind of nervous oh wow okay man
hey man sorry about you you'll be all
right man it's okay man it's not that
hard man you'll be all right me
personally dude I'm looking for that
lunge bump though what's what's what's a
lunge bump oh that's uh like if you um
you get featured if you lunge at
somebody and then you get a bump in your
pay and if you really lucky man they
blow your head off that's straight bank
right there extras the assistant
director gather around Jerry hey Jerry I
had a thought man about the first scene
that y'all not now St oh Steve it's
Steve okay I'm going to need somebody to
Lunge at the
fence you think you can handle it yeah
uh yeah it's his first day though he
kind of nervous man he kind of nervous
it's his first day okay so the
director's going to yell action Max's
going to come by and then you're just
going to Lunge into the fence
like you you want me to say gr oh this
is say whatever crazy okay all right
cool man hey you know hey that's cool
hey you know I got a lot more experience
man you can just use me I've been here
day one first season so okay cool all
right that's fine you're going to go
with him all right good for you man good
for you gr no don't you you don't have
to say gr do whatever you hell you want
to do man that's the lunge bump that is
the lunge bump man you got it you got it
on your first day
ever being an extra ever you got it man
good for you and
[Music]
action what's baby what the hell was
that cut oh man I would be more than
happy to fill in man I'd be more than
happy to step in Mac just remember when
you're coming through the factory that
like your mind is still in the carent I
mean you got to pick People based on
qualifications man you just be picking
random the good note but maybe what I
was doing sort of superseded that agreed
yeah we were just discussing that
absolutely it suedes it yeah but uh
let's do one that just seeds it okay
just same level we're going again
straight away okay right away reset okay
he's not doing a good job at it you're
doing great though man opportunity
knocks you got to answer the door man
and
[Applause]
action
cut I'll be more than happy to step in
at any time you want me to I'd be more
than happy to do it just a certain sense
of urgency is all we're looking for
clock's ticking you got survivors to
find right can't I tell youall something
real second this dude right here is not
doing what a zombie does this dude was
literally on our last take waving his
hand up in the air like this Jer making
Beaker sounds he sound like Beaker from
The Muppets y'all thank you that's great
just a ticking clock on this is all
we're looking for because there are
survivors is what we're after okay I
found the ambivalence in there the
ambivalence is Art it's gorgeous and we
love it but there are zombies so if we
could just pick up the pace just a hair
that'd be great straight away please
right away Jerry Jerry but Jerry we're
not doing a night of to live in Muppet
are we we are not cuz the beaker is not
a zombie you have any notes yeah don't
be Beaker quiet please
action I'm going to eat your brains
zombie cut no
he actually just said the word zombie
come on man you ever hear a zombie say
the word zombie before no you haven't I
don't think so you know get rid of this
kame thank you that's what I'm talking
about I'm sorry but you terrible at this
man do your thing hey man no he talking
about him no he's talking about him cuz
he said zomie thank you Steve no you
want me to leave hey man I've been up
here staggering around here for three
and a half years and I've been startling
extras left and right when do I get to
startle the lead huh one more for safety
straight away here we still roll
action
hey what do we do if we have to go to
the
bathroom we like it I love it genius
moving on thank
[Music]
God
inter
oh is my
sh
mother
[Applause]
you dead white person oh this place does
seem dope to me Mart barely barely yo
and is about time Shakespeare do scriven
the play that places a brother amongst
the firmament that's my sight oh who's
your favorite character mine's a fellow
oh T mine as well T mine as well because
they got a as a
general I'm saying Hell if yes a did the
Beast with two backs with that comely
white maiden and did not anyone speak us
against him he's straight pimp he thinks
things are looking up for people of the
darker Hue damn
straight hey hey n come on oh um Marion
what's that I could borrow a couple of
duckets to purchases a kpon from y
concession more please you know I got a
concealed cornish game hand up in my
dublet oh allow with me to partaketh up
in this bit okay okay get in
there the second act is about to begin
come on y'all y'all heard the urer if I
know Shakespeare I thought I was about
to kill everybody up in this
[__] no no NOP I hate at this place how
they going to kill a man that trifling
ass Iago I knew he was up to something
they should have killed him in the First
Act how they going to kill a and how a
going to do himself in with a dagger how
does that happen let me tell you
something if a brother killed himself
every time he broke up with a white
[__] this world would be barest of
brother you'll be talking to a skull
right now okay mm where Shakespeare's at
Shakespeare oh he's right
there Make Way pry make way be gone
s you killed a th a black man got it
going on and you Shuffle off his mortal
coil I say unto thee that's a tragedy M
oh is that not the trador Kanye of the
West what oh no
wait truth be told my lords it is not I
who pen this Dreadful play to
Christopher
Marlo yes that thou already tried to use
that line of argument when the Jews
wanted to kick your ass after The
Merchant of Venice we do not purchase it
slick willly we do not purchase it be
calm my good Lords it will not be long
before another black hero Grace the
stage and now if you let me take my
leave of you not so fast you going to
write that
hero
now verily that
mother
you know that John shaft is one bad
mother shut that mouth I just speak
about
[Music]
sha let's get this party started ladies
and gentlemen this is Paramount plus
this is Strokes of Genius beautiful
games and One Shining Moment this is
Defenders investigators and seven
strangers to live in a house this is
Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and
younger this is everything you've been
looking for that's going to leave a mark
life Sports breaking news and a mountain
of entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now
streaming I'm going to go wash my hands
oh okay okay see you
second
buddy um I'm sorry uh that seat is
actually taken uh my girlfriend is in
the bathroom and she should be back any
second so you cannot sit there you don't
even recognize me do you no no I I I
don't I don't I don't know you we were
in that Human Centipede together I said
I do not know you 3 years ago we were
kidnapped by the crazy German scientists
surgically connected us into a single
human digestive chain there were three
of us I was in the middle you were at
the end the other guy was up front your
mouth was sewn to my butthole okay yes I
remember and after years of therapy I
finally put that behind me probably
should have said you put it behind me if
you catch my drift I'm sorry I'm sorry
you already caught my drift I'm sorry
that's it it was right there in front of
me I'm sorry I guess it was right there
in front of you that's
it how are you doing how are you is
there something else I can help you with
hey frontman this is a nightmare hey
backman backman no don't call me that
cup of squat no ooh chilly old habits
die heart
nice one no I can't eat it word why are
you happy to see him come on man you
know we all shared the same experience
no we didn't he was in the front nobody
in his mouth that is true do you ever
stop eating ever only when I'm okay well
but me and you right me and you what I
mean we were in the same boat nope you
two were in the same boat you both in
someone's mouth I didn't get to in
anyone's mouth get to when do I get to
some's mouth huh when do I get to in
somebody's mouth Steen h i no the these
guys I can explain this I can explain
this
you oh you're disgusted you know now
you're going to leave oh yeah that's
great oh yeah once again I'm the
[__]
[Music]
okay man you know what it it wasn't my
fault all right I I I I I had the money
like you said in a trash bag in the back
of my car and I was going to go straight
to the drop spot
all
right no no oh okay okay okay no no hey
hey hey hey man ain't no need for you to
get comfortable okay because because I'm
telling you man what happened wasn't my
fault all right I I I drove to the greed
upon location man oh
man come
on okay okay okay okay be be okay
because there's no need to have anything
crazy in a paper bag I'm telling you
there's an explanation for what went
down whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm
down now let's calm down man they ain't
no
need oh not a juice box there ain't no
need to eat a meal and then do some
crazy with a sandwich container and a
juice box oh man come on come on man
just chill out a little bit just you
need to relax man you need to take it
easy and relax
oh oh God damn now come on man don't do
it don't do it don't don't man come on
oh eating a sandwich you eating a
sandwich man how you going to sandwich
me dog how you going to sandwich me oh
okay look it's getting crazy now it's
got to stop it's got to stop right now
okay you cleaning yourself up before you
do some ill come on man what you doing
what you want to know what I'll tell you
whatever you want to know man just
please stop this cold ass man I'm
telling you dog please oh no no okay
look okay maybe it was my fault a little
bit maybe it's my fault a little bit but
don't just what you want to do with that
juice box man what you going to do with
that what are you going to do with the
straw what are you going to do with the
straw come on man listen listen no no no
I did it I did it I did it okay I did it
I did it I left the car I left for 3
minutes so please don't do anything with
the straw what you stop the
F okay man I beat you to it okay I got
your point all right man H oh man that's
a
[Music]
[__] will we be having any more
problems out of him sir
no yeah that's what I'm talking
about hey y'all for real though this
right here yeah this goes out to all our
fallen homies yo come on hey yo real
talk all
right I
mean seems like a waste
right does that make me a
dick okay I'm a dick okay I'm a dick I'm
sorry I'm a big old dick I'm okay
here for our
homies come on man Dam okay okay fine
fine
glug glug glug glug gugug come on man
hey man you got your thumb in there okay
you need to respect our
homies okay for the homies who trash
beard what come on hey beer is
beer jeez I cannot win on this what fine
I'm not on board with this but I'll do
it
hey what you doing what you really that
don't count oh hey put that that's not a
man it's more of a symbol than a gesture
somebody back me up on this hey man
that's disrespectful right there you
just do it fine fine I pour it out I'll
waste the damn beard
in you know I'm just not a waster you
know I save everything Jamal knows if he
eat a piece of pizza and don't eat the
crust I eat the crust if we do a driveby
shooting I will go back for the shell
cases not to hide the evidence but
because you can recycle those they have
value man just like this beer I can't
waste nothing y'all it's physically
impossible for me to waste this I can't
do
it Jamal
can you pour it out for
me f d come on man I mean it's not going
to bring him back stupid it's not going
to bring him
back call my
agent Jaden picket Smith my man what up
Clyde hey look man I'm going to be real
with you okay this Al million boy script
I'm not feeling it I mean it's hard
being Will Smith's son I just want to
make sure my next project reflects that
I'm a down toe normal kid am I making
any sense yeah yeah I'm I'm reading you
loud and clear I've got a script right
here very real called street ball talk
to me okay so you play Tony he's a kid
from the streets lives in the Hood in a
house with his mom
stop house oh it's like a tiny Mansion
got it go on so his mom and he uh they
live in this house and she works at a
supermarket oh uh a supermarket's like a
mansion uh but it's full of food and
anyone can go there so like where the
Butlers go yeah basically so so he uh
and wait you said his mom was doing
something at the supermarket working
so working is kind of like acting on a
set every day in a film that no one's
ever going to see and it lasts for the
rest of your life oh like a maid yeah
yeah she's like the maid of the super
awesome continue so anyway Tony doesn't
make the basketball team right so he
decides to start playing pickup games of
street ball outside so he plays
basketball in his plane no on the ground
in his limo no uh outside is that stuff
that goes by when you're inside the limo
oh snap he plays basketball outside the
limo door yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
then he gets really good at basketball
and then blah blah blah blah blah fast
forward at the heart of the story Tony
has to choose between his mom
choose yeah choose is when you have to
make a decision between two things you
want but you can have only one but
there's
two yeah but I mean he he can't have
both what I say about science fiction
Clyde it's a
no okay we'll
pass dad bless you thanks hello and
welcome to the fifth annual meeting of
the tallah haxi black Republicans now
I'm pissed royally pissed last November
Barack Obama was reelected
president and the black vote went almost
entirely to
him we're not getting our message out
obviously the Republican party is and
should be the only home for black voters
yes sir now people think that black
voters are a
monolith we're not a monolith what no
we're not in fact black Republicans
alone are an extremely diverse group of
people now to speak more on diversity I
present tonight's
speaker Mr Douglas
Jackson
now I'm not going to sugarcoat it I'm
pissed I am royally
pissed the liberal media thinks that
republicanism is not for black people
now you tell me what about fiscal
responsibility a strong National Defense
and limited government is unappealing to
black people we're not a mod lith we
come in all different shapes and sizes
yes we do now who here like to come up
to this Podium and speak about the
diversity amongst black
Republicans gentlemen we have a real
treat today a gentleman who is a little
bit eccentric a little bit outside of
the box if you
will but I can't think of a better
person to speak on diversity amongst
black Republicans than this gentleman
right here all the way from Orlando my
good friend Arthur
Washington
thank you for the introduction brother
doulas thank you for being here brother
Arthur however I am
pissed royally pissed indeed indeed all
right Democrats think they have a right
to all the black people but that is not
the case we are not a
monolith Democrats may be cool but they
ain't practical there you go Republicans
are practical
black people are
practical come to think of it get those
pants I think black Republicans are
pretty
cool not to mention very
diverse excuse me gentlemen uh sorry to
interrupt someone's white wife is here
to pick them
up was her name Emily uh she was white
okay God the moment I saw you last night
at the club totally had to ask you out
yeah are you kidding me like the moment
that's so sweet I was actually afraid
that you were going to be like one of
those high maintenance chicks you
know what yeah I don't know I control
freak or I don't even know I don't even
know God that's so funny is is it is it
funny is it funny no I'm like I totally
just like to be just like easygoing I'm
wi I'll it's been 5 minutes and we're
just now getting our
menus
I'm sorry don't be sorry be
better right okay I'll be better that's
your
job thank
you so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill right yeah yeah you
know what I like about you no what it's
like you're not afraid to be like brainy
and respectful right thanks I really
like your
boobs I think think we really compliment
Each Other Well you just did it right
there and uh I pretty much go with the
flow and what the is wrong with
you excuse me do I look like Mad Max to
you I'm sorry do I look like Mel Gibson
with a
mullet no not not at all does he look
like a feral child with a boomerang in
his hand no then why the is water a rare
commodity here it's not it's not I'm
just uh I
I'm sorry I'm just really slammed no
you'll know when you're slammed because
your nuts will be on the table and my
fist will be covered in your
[Music]
blood
um you were uh like kind of harsh to
that guy oh him yeah no I was a hostess
at a restaurant in the industry that's
how we talk to each other I'll show you
you hey God
hey what do you see there what your
water
down down boy on your knees okay I have
other tables that I have what does that
look like to you yes there's a little
Lipstick on Your Glass but it Mak it's
your this is what I want you to do I
want you to take this glass in the back
I want you to break it take the biggest
Shard you can find and bring it to
me I'm going to Slit your
color all right I'm just I'll get you
another water I'm going to Slit your
throat and watch you bleed out and I'm
going to shower in your blood all right
I'll get another water well that would
be great thank
you but as I was saying like I just feel
like it's like do unto
others it was your lipstick on the
glass what the hell is that what are you
doing wait wait no no no no no oh my
God I just tell you no one's ever talk
to me like that in my life saying that
you you have his back who does that it
was your lipstick on the glass he's just
a
waiter you know what take his I hope you
have a very happy life
together Meg what's going on right now
what are you
[Music]
do seriously Megan no no Megan you left
the jacket hey you left your jack
hey don't do
it I just heard her feelings and then
she left her jacket least I could do
back Jack don't do it need to Che she
does not need it it's 87° out you know
she doesn't need it and your heart of
hearts you know she doesn't need that
jacket don't do
it she's going to need her jacket she's
not going Megan you you're jacket
though seem like a nice
guy all right so that's just working EAS
then okay good good good good good me
that's awesome man okay we got to hurry
uping out the we just I want to get out
there hey oh sorry
sorry y'all want to do some of that God
drop no what the who's this guy y'all
never heard of a
godra wh what I've I've never heard of
that AKA
Slayer Cy Cy double cutting
Elmo cat vage okay Long Island brain
slice fontt font font font I've heard of
that it takes all your greatest fears
and
insecurities and it gives them teeth and
arms and then it locks you in the room
with them from which you cannot
Escape well that sounds terrible yeah I
don't want that none of those words are
good you realize the it's a God is
somewhere inside your
body but you can't find it and it hates
you um okay none of us are interested in
this drug thank you sir um nice meeting
you let's hear him out let's hear him
out it's a razor sharp Crystal you tuck
under your
eyelid and then when your ocular cavity
starts bleeding it goes directly into
your brain feel like there's got to be a
good part yeah you've just described a
life wrecking physical addiction if
you'd let him finish if You' let him
finish she's going to get to the
Euphoria I'm sure just what you can't
take
anymore you poop your mouth I'm sorry
what you poop in your mouth
no you poop out of your mouth I'm in
dude Jeb come on man no don't guys if
people are willing to go through this
the high must be amazing buddy remember
when you did mushrooms and you cried for
3 hours this is worse than that oh yes
oh oh
oh that
hurts that hurts when did it start
working how should I know I don't do
drugs drugs are for
[Music]
losers this weed is mad tight y yeah man
I'm super high
dog hey yo let me ask you a question on
the
real yeah yeah dog yeah go ahead
B hey man where my dookie
go
oh what my
dookie where do we go
they go down in the toilet you know that
no man I ain't
stupid where do we go after that come on
B quit playing I don't it goes there the
sewer you
know everybody go down there yeah
everybody's dookie goes down in the
sewer where my dookie go after that that
washes out to the
ocean
I guess hold up hold
up dolphins swim with my dookie I don't
know man I mean I don't I really don't
know we're in the ocean yep what happens
to the dookie I'm just taking a stab
like a wild guess all right that the
dookie like probably go up in the air
and like evaporates and then turns into
the cloud or something a dookie Cloud oh
this everybody's doy mix up go up into
the cloud and then the Rains Down that's
ganga I just can we stop talking about
doie right
now I just thought of something yes what
is it what is it Levi the pieces of my
dookie yep falls on the ground that's
true yep and becomes a plan okay okay
that's good now we're done with the
dookie talk right dookie
plan that reaches Towards the
Sky he
said yeah
Levi if my dookie can make it out of the
[Music]
hood maybe we can
too
huh
maybe maybe
Levi ladies and gentlemen Darius
Rucker
yeah don't go out with my friends no
more don't want to hold your hand no
more I don't want to be
[Music]
with oh no no no no no I'm not in hoodie
and the Blowfish anymore y'all doing my
own thing what do you mean in hoodie
because you you are hoodie man come on
everybody
[Applause]
hoodie no no no all right now now now
stop it stop it I'm not hoodie I'm
Darius Rucker all right I used to be the
front man for a band called hoodie and
the Blowfish all right but I was never
hoodie there was never a hoodie just if
I may if I may ask where are the
Blowfish at right guys come on everybody
blow fish blow blow fish
blow there are no people known as The
Blowfish y'all okay the whole band was
just called hoodie and the Blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name like
hoop stack or tow the West frocket
oh don't go out with my friends no more
don't want don't hold your hand no
more oh oh what oh stop for a second I I
see I get it now I understand hey we got
to pick y'all we got to choose between
hoodie or the Blowfish so who wants to
see the
Blowfish there's no
Blowfish who wants to see
hoodie
hey hey that that hurts my feelings
y'all but you said you weren't hoodie no
I'm not sir but in the question you just
asked the audience I I was clearly
hoodie so you are hoodie I'm not though
he is
[Applause]
[Music]
hoodie
[Applause]
I'm got a pocket full of funy with a
peppermint twist she's a cool shifted
mom blasting off on the
FL iridescent poor Galactic super
train sister playground with a strong
Daddy got to get it
up got to get it
on got to get it
down got to make
it got that quick crayon earthquake jet
pack on a
lotive Supernova Spanish
Harlem solar blast with AOS and
R's that mamaat
de got to shake it
up got to move it
in got to put it
down you got to make it
swim you com sanation do
Qui play Tornado withle beef Snee sh
Justice cannons caes and
trees off penguin Shillings railroads
and PE i g ma Brooks CR backs on my
knees ping trap laser curreny be he ping
tra laser Curren
hey what the hell are we saying man I
got no idea man I'm just hungry and
talking about the Galaxy and trains I
think they buying it
[Music]
[Applause]
though
[Music]
8 kilos 100% pure grade Afghan
heroin
100,000 US dollar
hold
up we should count it first
mhm my
guess you know we going to do a straight
count on this right now count it count
it yeah good idea yeah mhm should
probably do it fast so we don't make our
friends here wait M okay 20 40 60 80 100
20 40 60 80 200 you know what I'm fast
do it yeah I'll take care of that 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 89 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 89 why why you doing piles and nine
it's faster than 10 oh really I do my
nines 10 times and I do an extra extra
pil of 10 faster okay you know we we
should probably both be counting oh well
let's get to it that's double trouble
all
[Music]
right I'm sorry can you can you pleas
can you do something like over there
please it's a little distracting oh you
know what what's up I got it we can time
me okay we time me counting out a th000
we take that time and then we just count
money for that time times 100
p no I I got it this is it right here
I'm going to do a web search for a
picture of
$100,000 okay then you know we'll know
what it's supposed to look like and then
we can arrange our money to look exactly
like it and see here hey here we go
right here look I mean damn that looks
that looks just like a lot like our
money I I think we got $100,000 here
folks I think we made it you that is our
money I'm sorry I'm sorry the earlier
yeah when we were counting I took a
picture of our money so I could upload
it on Yahoo answer
oh damn that's right there I just wanted
to see if anyone could verify what
$100,000 look like oh you got it what
was I thinking I got it man I got it
what the hell you doing man I I thought
you know I was going to try to Rainman
it oh that's a plan right there that's
right okay yeah here we go here we go
okay yep yep I got that I got that
246 90
9,980 okay so okay but check this out
okay so this one time in college man I
was straight kicking game to this
beautiful chick Diana man and at the
house party and so anyway I go to the
kitchen to grab us a couple of beers man
I kid you not I slipped on a banana peel
a banana
pel like this I was like man I just fell
out my ass I just bust ban like I was
must yo dog you good yeah man uh what
are you
doing
me it was a funny
story I was laughing then let it out man
just just
laugh I
am so uh any anyway uh you know so I I
get up right and I go to grab a beer and
I forget they always was shooking up
when they fell right I kid you not this
beer exploded in my crotch and looked
like I peed myself and now I'm trying to
walk
over come on what are we
doing don't hit don't hit my couch Lon
keep come on y I'm just laughing with
y'all well we were laughing you weren't
and you know make any noise you just
open your mouth and
you jiggling you look like a worm on
crack mhm I guess everybody just has
their own unique laugh okay man you were
not laughing you were not admitting
sound up out your mouth man hey I'm good
tell you your
story thank you anyway I
went back to the kitchen to get two
fresh beers and she said I hate beer but
where did my banana
go and so then we call the
chaita
Diana there it goes Lon don't back up
hey come on man let it outon hey get
away from the
turtles Lon don't do this just don't
touch my turt get away from it why you
knocking down my CDs damn okay you put a
lampshade on your head why would you do
that hey come on come on those are
okay you know what now see like you do
it intentionally now all right see
that's not even it's almost like you
choreograph you going to clean all this
up okay look hey if you got to laugh
then just
laugh
damn
maybe sometimes you ain't as funny as
you
think all right I got something that'll
make them
laugh huh yeah just let it out huh there
you go huh that's funny that's it just
letny huh he went back just laugh
man you KN that's funny just let it out
why won't you laugh just laugh Brother
come on
[Laughter]
man
see that's why I didn't want to
[Music]
lie have a good
life
hello Sky magazine this is R speaking
hello RI I would like to report an item
which I ordered that arrived broken
Wendel Sanders smoking bed Lane that's
right I am showing the last item that
you've received is the Superman bed with
the mattress of solitude that's the one
ordered it from a son for his birthday
but I cannot give it to him like this
and I'm pretty darn too and pissed about
it very sorry sir I will start
processing your reorder right now with
you on the line okay I Ain't Mad At You
RI it's just the system I know okay
thank you for understanding sir kids e
huh oh K well yeah I just got the one
myself had sex with woman and everything
to get him how long is this going to
what is your son's
name uh
uh
Stimpy pretty much Stimpy I have boys
too I tell you sometimes they can be a
real couple of you know what [__]
[__] you're preaching to the chir
Stimpy don't you give me that look
you're going to get it when your mama
comes home oh man sounds like your wife
is [__] on Wheels you got that straight
RI hot little biscuit though name's
Claire body 10 face 10 so pretty much
hit that every
night
sexually anyway what's holding up the oh
one one minute and uh how old is your
son 15 15 and he still want a Superman
bed a l blomer enjoy it while you still
can he'll grow out of the toys any day
now they all do and the second he starts
hooking up with the girls he'll forget
all about that Superman and Spider-Man
stuff pretty much seems like how it
would happen maybe then he'll stop
bothering me with all those stupid
little facts about how those characters
you just named are clearly from two
distinct and separate universes sadly
some people never move on sad I got a
better word for you pathetic well I I I
wouldn't say but that gu hey I call them
locks I se them real and I don't
tolerate n nerds in fact let me nip this
in the bud real quick stimp it Stimpy
get back in here well I didn't mean to
there you are with your round body and
your creepy ass face no more sweets for
you cuz you're never going to get laid
if you keep eating sweets and another
thing all these figurines and toys you
got around the house we're throwing them
in the trash cuz they're not real people
Stimpy they're not real people so stop
being so lonely stop being
so
[Music]
lonely and this is not of my business of
course but I was wondering if your son
would like to talk to
someone oh [__] simp just jumped out the
window oh my god oh he killed himself
why I to do it it must have been my
fault no it wasn't yes it was I'm going
to call the cops don't you dare cancel
that reorder it's the only thing I'll
have to remember him by
[Music]
he
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
a
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
um hi uh are you Earl
Peele who the hell want to
know ah I think I'm your son Jordan
Peele oh okay I
see come on in here for a minute and
close the door on the way in all
right all right man go ahead have a seat
there I'm going to explain something to
you
okay I ain't your
dad all right I'm sorry to disappoint
you but that's the situation
brother are you you see what's
happening we're doing the same thing I I
always do this I always scratch the back
of my neck like this whenever I'm in an
uncomfortable
situation scratch my neck man everybody
scratched their neck I breathe in and
out too man and now everybody my kid
okay look at this that's a picture of me
when I was a baby that's my
father that ain't me look look look look
man look at that dude's afro look I got
this going on man my hair was gray he
got black hair I mean he handsome as
hell but I ain't nobody's
Daddy I'm
sorry just been looking for him
everywhere yeah yeah sure you have since
I got my own TV show
now
I don't know I just I know that wherever
he is he he would be
proud you got your own TV show huh yeah
yeah I'm producing and acting oh you oh
oh you producing and acting right okay
yeah that that's that's my
boy look at that man we doing the same
thing what is that Holy that's jeans
right there man because you can't do
that unless you sharing mad jeans with
somebody it's got to be in your
DN
oh you're my
son my baby boy thanks for your time you
come back home man I I miss you so much
stop get off get off get off get off oh
hey when I first came to your door you
wouldn't even
a
okay okay you know what when I first
came in here stop
that when I first came in here you
wouldn't even acknowledge that I could
possibly be your son but now only after
I tell you that I have my own show on
Comedy Central whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa Comedy
Central get the out of my house
W this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you joking me bro this is
daily late and late late this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great standup great movies and the
great cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps hi hi this is welcome to papet
mattress Liquidators how can I help you
today I need to buy a new bed okay yeah
good good you came to the right place
I'll be more than happy to help with
that uh what size you need a fool queen
king queen queen oh we got a big so you
know it needs to be sturdy all right get
kind of crazy in my room oh okay I got
you brother I got
you well this a postoptic mattress we
got right here that's extremely
comfortable and uh
durable do you mind if I try it no not
at all go
ahead I also mentioned there's a 100%
money back guarantee on this yeah yeah
yeah yeah who got that good de I got
that good de yeah
yeah no it's too
hard do you have anything
after
um of
course this uh this one of our um
natural latex
mattresses it's uh on sale too today at
$1,200 can I try
it
sure who got that good de I got that
good
de who got that good de I got that good
de it seems a little pricey okay no it's
a little pricey I ain't going to lie to
you but uh no problem we got other
choices um this this is a great memory
foam mattress right here a little
cheaper and can I try it out right right
yeah of course you want to try you know
how it goes yeah coming up on them late
nights he boom boom boom boom
yes c pumpy c pumpy c ppy
yeah yeah man um sex
happens yeah yeah yeah yeah who got that
good de I got that good de yeah yeah
yeah yeah who got that good D I got that
good de oh oh here it comes here it
comes here it
comes yep that's the one I'll take it
okay let me ring you
up got that good got that good got that
good got that good I got
[Music]
that Brothers Brothers Brothers see when
are we we going to think of ourselves as
more than
this what y'all doing y'all rolling huh
flipping stooping boxing maxing taxing I
used to stoop oh yeah I used to flip
roll you know whatever you want to call
it me and my crew we would get into
activities much like
yourself you see the problem was we were
only perpetuating The Stereotype the
system already assumes about without us
M you see we need to stop feeding into
the preconceived notions that we are oh
great job you guys you really work hard
today I wish I could pay you more but uh
you know how it
is hey who are you huh what do you want
I I don't
know as you were as you were what smart
guy
he
[Music]
Brothers Brothers brothers look at
yourself pants hanging off your ass
looking like a couple of clowns which
you are okay enjoy the birthday
celebration give me youring money [__]
I said give me your money [__] brother
brother brother
sir everybody in this self-defense class
has already paid to participate if
you're interested you can sign up
online I'm interested good that's why I
came over here I'm interested I'm going
to think about it I'm interested thank
you
sir Now ladies it's going to get really
intense today no matter what happens I
will be groping your breast assis as if
you were being attacked like a real
Attack brother brother my brother now I
was watching you now you old brothers
need to break the stereotype and stop
being so preachy you know what I'm
preachy come on you preachy man plus you
older than
me I'm 9 years old I got Benjamin Button
disease I'm done I'm
[Music]
done uh I actually pressed it already
huh the walk button I I pressed
it
couldn't hurt to press it again but it
won't help I mean I press it already
right already done you don't think I
didn't press it no I wasn't saying that
good so I most certainly did press it
just have to wait for it to
[Music]
[Applause]
change so I'm like late for work so I'm
just
press it what for why would you do
something that's already done I mean I
just think that that's crazy
right I don't know you wouldn't suit up
and try to kill Bin Laden again it's
done I have killed the bin Laden of
pressing this
button how long ago did you press it
what do you think I've been standing
here for days I just pressed it right as
you walked up are you sure you pressed
it am I I sure I pressed it it's how
could I miss rats know how to press
buttons do you think I'm dumber than a
rat no no nobody's saying anything like
that man it's going to change just just
wait it's because I pressed it
already Okay no offense I'm just going
to press it what would you do that for
this is precision equipment designed by
people with engineering degrees it will
work I pressed it sir I pressed the
button while we've been standing here
the light cycle has gone by twice okay
I'm not saying you didn't press it I'm
just saying maybe it didn't work if it
didn't work for me why in the world
would it work for you you think you
think that it would change faster if you
pressed it you think the light doesn't
like me or something or do you think
that that this particular button was
designed so that it only works up the
second time that it's been pressed cuz
that's lunacy okay do you understand do
not cut my balls off on this one
okay
please do not press the
button I okay fine we'll just stand here
thank
you what hey
no told you shouldn't have pressed the
button told him not to do it no actually
I already pressed the
[Music]
button b b
b hey what's wrong man I was having a
nightmare
a
again but you want to talk about it I
miss
mommy hey I know I know it's hey me too
me too
pal come here
man it's all right hey it's okay it's
going to be
okay I just don't want anything ever
happened to you happened to me hey come
on man ain't nothing ever going to
happen to me
really yeah that's what I said so yes
that I'm nothing never going to happen
to me you ain't never going to have to
worry about nothing happen to me but but
what if what if you got hit by a car or
something
that's impossible because I will never
die so I
can't die no matter what you can't die
but I thought all human beings
died that's true that's true that's
science so that's true but I am lucky
cuz I'm not a human you're
not I never told you about this
no you know I'll just let it out I'm
from a planet called
fonus the thing is it was being
destroyed all right that's what happened
my was I was sent down here in in in a
capsule to Earth by my parents oh like
Superman Superman yep that is what it is
exactly like except oh here's the thing
about my version only one superpower
immortality oh yeah so I'm tired daddy's
tired can you let's go to sleep okay but
I'm not going to live forever right
because because I'm only half alien oh
no so I'm going to
die
you you you write about yourself
ex
but here it is this one sliit my mind
you can build with me an immortality to
machine to give you what I I got from
the remnants of my spacecraft so yeah
wow you going to be immortal you going
to be immortal daddy when are we going
to get the remant tomorrow
tomorrow going to get them tomorrow
during
work hey you got anything that looks
like parts of a crash spaceship did Mom
mhm right this
way some folks wear their hats way off
to the side with their pants down low
and a gun tucked inside take their beer
by the 40 and their chicken deep fried I
think we all know who we're talking
[Applause]
about I once met a l so fine she was
drunk on barley wine I'd been to Sea for
months or three I knew I could could
make her mine and the last was past
consent so it was off with her we went
and we threw her in bed and rested her
head and we left cuz that's what
gentlemen
do to a drink or two with worrying about
what you will do we say oh ho but we
don't say ho cuz is
disrespectful y
yeah there once was a girl from Leeds
who I heard was good on her knees so I
docked my ship for an overnight trip to
take care of all my needs she was f as
Tales to tell and my mask began to swell
so I laid her down and raised her down
and performed conolingus for an hour or
[Applause]
so fair they Des as much attention out
there we say oh ho but we don't
say is
[Music]
disrespectful I once had a woman so fair
whose womb contained my air with a Sun
by my side the Seas we'd ride the child
she would bear but my girl she was no
fool she was working her way through
school so I did support when she chose
to abort because it's her body in there
for her
choice we don't say talking about gold
we don't look at chest the treasure
holds with the hand Anda and on our we
don't say she when we're talking about a
sh we don't say B we don't say [__]
that
langage there was a lady with a golden
eye and the doctor said she would die so
she emptied her purse to lift the curse
and prayed to stay alive she a walk the
very next day and in her grave she lay
but the scariest part of the story from
the start is I bet you assume the doctor
was a
[Applause]
man I am
so
[Music]
are
of we say oh ho but we don't say oh
that's always disrespectful
[Music]
there was a slot with TT to here and an
a
[Music]
St
cuz it's your ho but we don't say
[Music]
[Applause]
ho
[Music]
a
y y y y y
[Music]
[Applause]
la
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
y
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
a
I well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red W and
[Music]
true dreaming of the girl with a red
hair and freckles in her eyes like the
skies of
blue country music I grew up in Texas
you know so all right keep her safe from
the homies in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking The Reaper and
acting like CL
keep that pretty wide dress from getting
dirty and brown cuz that's the American
way
oh pretty racist
song racist against
who black people black people but I'm
black well keeping the redheaded girl
away from the homies on the wrong side
of town homies come on brother there's
all kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian
homies no homies are black no I think
you're making them black man I mean that
I think that's your stuff you hear the
Twang and then you assume that it's
racist but that's that's just what
country music is like here look you're
going to like this one you like this one
all
right some folks wear their hats way off
to the side with their pants down low
and a gun tucked inside take their beer
by the 40 and their chicken deep fried I
think we all know who we're talking
about the only dark I like is when I
turn off the lights the only Hood I love
is pointy and white t trust you if I
can't see your face at night I think we
all know who we're talking about wait
wait hey stop that that's racist what's
what what is racist about it the only
Hood I love is pointy and white yeah man
that's talking about the clan man the K
clux Clan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know what can I just say
something man I'm just gonna be
frank you're getting a little like Al
sharp and like fericon on me right now
man my God are you serious dude dude
please hey give me you know can I do one
more let me just do one more dog I
absolutely promise you that this song is
not racist and it's impossible for you
to Mis interpret it as
such okay it seems like you're about to
sing the most racist song so far I'm
not
hi get me R family tree okay I'm
out come on man
hey over here trying to sing about a
tire
swing WR off an entire genre of
music the joing and the drums are a
banging let's get the boys together and
have ourselves a hanging oh damn now I
see
it now I see
it one at a
time I put men like you behind bars
every
day one at a
time you may take my ears but cannot
lock my soul
away all the years I had to run I've
chased you through the years so long ago
it All Began now your journey is out of
In the Shadows on my for what you done
but was I ever be your only friend I'll
let this fight and now interrup to end
this life of let me finish what I need
to say will be welcome now I'll let you
finish first my journey don't let me get
in your way only stole a Lo of bra all I
needed to
survive end up in
your I have stayed alive get in a word
at least do I tell him that I love do I
tell him of his child now where did this
[__] come from from I have no idea one
at a time will he ever know L seriously
please hang on recognize her it's hard
enough to talk to him did you say my
daughter yours and mine one at a
time this all has to happen on the same
block now this is just a joke we can
solve all of these issues if everyone
just spoke one at a time taking what we
can cuz things are getting worse taking
what we can from every at a
[Music]
time one at a time the years destroy the
man she knew
we
[Applause]
Glory we will die I will years they pass
and we
speak here we go again Hing in and
out what this is about
why are we all facing the same
way is this city on fire what's with all
the
smoke oh now we're all ears
ready all y'all rappers out there you
think y'all hard cuz what y'all been
through hey yeah check it out it was
Friday night chilling on my front lawn
me and my crew I had my bath r on
everybody High just watch X-Men got
plenty Chicken Heads ready for sex man
musters roll up they trying to talk
smack don't these know they with the D
pish n i new homie seen us keep pull two
shots somehow my penis got between us I
got shot the shot shot in the I got
shoten but it's still standing shot shot
shot I got shot but it's still
standing went back to my Palace
fast now I'm the dude walking around
with a fallace cash like Wolverine I'm
trying to be a loner but they thinking
got an adamantium boner what can I I say
they still up on my totem pole [__] get
your tongue ring away from the scrotum
hole don't know why they love it but it
keeps the ladies moistening gave half
the Honeys in the hood Le poisoning shot
the shot shot the I got shot the but
it's still standing shot the shot shot
the I got shot the but it's still
standing
yo they shot that fool in
[Music]
the got man damn that hurts damn no
video over man video's over I'm serious
man damn so uh yeah I got like 30
something followers I up to like 15
tweets a day so if you wanted to uh
follow all right no no no no what they
hating on the halfways they hating on
the halfways they straight hating on
Annie halfways that's your girl dog
Annie halfways from devil where's PR
they Hain on her Nicholas Nic be
straight hating L Mr robas Mr Rob I
dream the dreams and dreams get
dreams why you be hating on the how do
you be hating on the halfway I do not
know cuz that's your girl that's my girl
with I've been rolling with the half
toway since Precious
diarrheas you was there since day one
you know I be loving me some princess
diar to the Royal Engagement you got the
Blu-ray I got DVD and Laser disc and VH
Yes Man Rachel getting married though
what
uhel getting married getting married y
do you love in half a ways I do come
on come on man and osar goes too and he
half the ways crackhead kill brother
that's why come on come on broken back
oh we Broken Backs brok broken back
that's right Broken Backs dog I'm
married to Jake [__] and Halls jigglin
THS thank you I stand corrected so wait
you know what like was not
myok she good she was good though play
that confident Texas business woman
talking about straight up you know what
I'm struggling with my husband's
sexuality she kept her integrity at the
same time as showing her breast and
that's a delicate balance delicate
balance why would you hate on the
halfway why would you be hating on the
ha Confident Woman in Hollywood whose
sole character flaw is that she cares
too much she cares too much that she
cares too much she can't too much come
on come on you know who they never be
hating on who's that dog Sandra bu SRA
Bullock my girl they never be hating
that's your girl right there straight up
there send bull say your girl right
there straight up do you know who should
do a movie together though who is that
what Bullock seies and halfway you
talking about some halfway and some
Bullock no I'm talking about some
bullocksies and some halfways let me
just explain what I'm talking about now
I'm talking about some halfways and some
Bullock sees
no you right bu have was that would be
my
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
oh you good yeah I'm I'm good I thought
something was going to me too happen for
a second we would transform in some way
shape or
form okay that would be
my that would be my sh
[Applause]
what up Vegas what up
Vegas yo three days me and you free
drinks make it be a this is going to be
our right here dog this is going to be
my let's get some jams going up in this
[__] right now got the number one track
in the country right now roll with
me that's my jam right there I love this
song man I love this song too man that's
everybody loves this song what
he what with me roll with me
let with
me you know that I got what you need see
don't get greedy give it up sweet let me
set that body free cuz what you got you
got to give it to me
what ever since I was rocking a onz I
know that you was second to n growing up
and learning ABCs and one two hoping you
learn we were meant to be even way back
then every little know a perfect but you
know I grow up and got a little bit
older a little bit Boulder busing off my
shoulders almost a man those playground
feelings who stronger couldn't wait much
longer now with me you
girl it
right no no what the hell don't turn it
off just cuz you don't know it what we
going to do when we get to Vegas no no
no no no no no don't change the subject
about what we're going to do in Vegas if
you don't know the words just admit you
don't know the words know the words I
told you why would I make makeup that I
know don't know that's ridiculous man no
I know the words it seems like you
didn't know the words I know the word
Hey listen Hey listen to me man what
what I know the worst of that song
everybody knows no no it's not okay cuz
you obviously don't believe me hey hey
dude on our
friendship I know the words to roll with
me
okay I'm
sorry sry let it go I'm sorry that's
stupid
turn it back
up yo I love that track so much I'm
sorry I got to play it again this is
roll with me
[Music]
1.3b yeah that really
hurt what flever you
got vanilla flavor you got Lemon Zinger
Lemon Zinger like that tea
oh what wrong oh no what's going on I
got that brain freeze oh man the you do
you ain't got no brain
freeze hey relax man that pass man calm
down and he
passing passing can't be intensifying
dog come on man you said you from the
hood dog you acting weak right now with
this brain
freeze come on ain't no brain freeze
going to make you yell like that man get
over don't be hit in your head with the
brain free come on in it y you going
silver balls on it silver balls on the
string kinetic
energy what's wrong with you come on
okay Exorcist what are you doing now
what you doing some Kung Fu get over it
man listen they can't be doing this much
to you listen man don't be a punk ass
[__] man get over the wait you afraid
now you see anything you just scared the
brain free is making you
scared what do you mean who am I you
ain't got no Alzheimer's what's wrong
with
you you a punk ass [__] what is this
you going to go three stoes on this
mother this is some craziness oh you did
the hand
block you know what man you're weak man
you a weak ass mother that's the problem
is your
P oh yo yo yo yo yo Yoo yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo hold up now hold up now hold up
now hold up now hold up man you going to
continue to eat the fro yo even on top
of the BL FR what are you doing hey now
I really start to respect you now man if
you're going to eat the thing that's
causing you the pain this is oh now it's
going FAS
he's speeding up he steering into the
brain freeze this is straight crazy
right here Bry real talk though real
talk though real talk though I mean it's
crazy in the time man I strangle Benny
with my bare hands cuz he didn't have my
money all right we got him got who what
what you 5 stand up slowly who I can't
believe this man I known you since sixth
grade you under arrest for the murder of
Benny Tac theatrix get him out of here
man you a punk ass brain freeze mother
you going to jail for a long
time been to
deep I got a brain freeze got caught
with the brain freeze yeah you got that
brain
[Music]
freeze hey hey what you
doing oh come
on come on what you doing come on man
stop it stop
it
f you're big you're big you're
[Music]
big I know you I know you I think I like
you no no no no
hey what are you eating what are you
eating get the away from me oh but
that's food go that's food though
damn I like that I like the way you look
looking good to
me you a dude sorry that's okay it
[Music]
happens
hey what's up there is there something
up there is it up there yes D hey come
here I want to eat you in my mouth you
going to eat you in my M no get on it
getat it to eat it I see you come here
let's get this party started ladies and
gentlemen this is Paramount plus this is
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers pick
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and younger this
is everything you've been looking for
that's going to leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now
streaming hello LESA hello Carousel oh
Sammy Carousel had another premonition
oh what was it this time she says an
ostrich is going to escape from the zoo
today no she heard that on the news last
night so that's a thing that actually
happened in real life already okay well
better late than never all right all
right well go make Daddy some camomile
let's go come on go around use the
fourth there you go Le
Sean I just got this letter from an
insurance company it looks like we are
officially on the same Insurance what
yes me we did it I can't believe this I
we're finally not going to be treated
like second class Citi oh my God I want
to see I want to see I want to see I
want to see no don't show me just tell
me what are we covered what are we
covered H it's good insurance it's we
got Dental dent and uh oh my God make me
an appointment right now I'm going get a
ruby filling and a Fang for apples a
Fang yes a single solitary Fang for
tricky fuits and bottle caps you
understand that that's kind of an
elective procedure which I'm going to
proceed to elect the Fang the president
of my mouth and then I'm going to get my
voice louding voice loud yes so I can
talk to birds all right so well I don't
know if we're going to find a dentist
who can do that also it's not covered
this insurance because it's the basic
dental and vision
and
my sem sem sem sem who sem whoop sem
that is my name I'm going to have one
contact that looks like a cat eye and
another contact that looks like a cat's
face that's missing an eye you don't
wear contact I'm going to have a third
eye that looks like the letter eye and
it's going to be in my eye I'm going to
be like I see
you lesan you don't wear contacts so
there's I'm going to need to wear
contacts when I have my eyebrows redid
cuz they say that kind of procedure will
scrumple the cornean you're not getting
your eyebrows redid redone UND
I'm going to have them switched on my
face so when I get mad I look delighted
you understand that insurance is only
for real medical problems and even then
we have a deductible I'm going to deduct
the fats from my ass and put them in my
fangles so when I wave I look like
Mickey Mouse okay all right listen to
what I'm telling you right now what
insurance is not for you to have the
bottom half of your body caught off and
you sewn to a horse so you can
experience what it's like to be a c oh
my God Sammy that's a good idea it's not
a good idea because you die almost
immediately oh it be worth it Samy it
would be so worth it Samy please tell me
I can I know that you want to do that
but you can't do it it's not covered by
the insurance oh Samy come on why you
got to be the 80s to my disco right now
why do you have to I'm not trying to I'm
just trying to be the reality to your
I'm going have stomachs I'm going to get
another stomach one for cherries and one
for corn my God that's right Sammy I'm
going to go to couples therapy alone and
just play both parts I'm want to go to
the gynecologist just ask questions till
I get it oh and I got another question a
few questions about how many different
parts of your body you can make blink
cuz I want to get my ear Lids done and
my foot Pockets foot pockets are this
invention I've been thinking of where
you can just put your keys up by your
ankles then I'm going to have a coaster
put on my shoulder so when I go to a bar
I can say you want to drink on me and
then I'm just going to be like a monster
and then for Halloween I'm going to
dress up like a normal human being so
glad we could bring this project to this
neighborhood oh it's so rich in history
yeah I grew up in a neighborhood like
this oh yeah I I grew up in a
neighborhood exactly like
this all right welcome to Mama sugar
bags y'all ready to order yeah can I
have a chicken fried steak with gravy
and a
cola I will have the baked beef short
ribs with collard greens and throw down
some of that cornbread all right babe
you know what hold up a second I'm also
going to have some of them collard
greens and cornbread as well but hook a
brother up with some of them hot links
all right all
right you know what uh why am I trying
to front scratch all that give me some
okra and some fried red snapper and girl
you know I want some chillins all right
now y'all got ham
Hawks of course well that's what I want
I want a plate of ham Hawks deep fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet I want some pig feet and
4 lbs of grits oh oh hey and you know
what else give me a little Dixie cup
full of lard all right I just remember
what I want a bowl of mosquitoes none of
them tiny ones either give me them big
motherfu you find down at the swamp
sister could you please hook a brother
up with a rusty bucket full of fish
heads wrapped in razor wire donkey teeth
donkey teeth straight out a donkey's
mouth you know what any animal tooth
will do I want you to stick it in some
honey glaze fry it with fatb and serve
it in an old tin coffee can forget
everything I said up to this point right
now bring me some dandel greens a cow
hip and a dog face wrap that whole mess
in an old Ebony magazine and serve it to
to me in a shoe box okay I want a
platter of stor ankles an old cellador a
possum spine and a human
foot you want a human
foot
mhm I got just one question for
y'all you want gravy on that cell though
oh definitely oh yeah yeah you got to
put gravy on it yeah supp to sell a door
without gravy it's not
food that's
[Music]
really okay let's get this thing
going everybody take a seat we got to
have more meeting homes cuz I'm telling
you man we got to get
organized ah
carito ain't got a seat man someone get
him a chair n I'm cool no dude get him a
chair homes n
man I'm going to see Gangster but carito
doesn't look like it's comfortable man
why don't you just sit in the
chair I never sit in no chair
essay M you never ever going to catch me
sitting in no
chairs like ESS you know that that's
local
right it's cool carito no one's going to
think you're soft if you sit in a chair
we're all sitting in chairs bunch of
[__] ass
keros okay I don't have no time to sit
in aing
chair huh okay now that we're all
here you know what about why though like
it it don't make no sense for you to set
yourself up with a rule like that no
it's like limiting yeah limiting I mean
sometimes people sit in chairs man all
of you guys with your [__] ass
chairs
there okay carito quit playing and sit
in the chair pendo no carito we have to
have this meeting now ESS say get up I'm
good right here man you're know
I'm chilling go ahead with your meaning
okay but you know it's going to be weird
you don't care it's going to be weird
weird for you maybe he doesn't care
okay okay homies so this is what we have
to do like we got to sell more drugs and
we got to make more crimes happen
Roberto where are we carito you're
bleeding
I who cares
man yo whoa you just got shanked man we
got to pull that out leave it I'm
chilling holes I don't care about that
stupid
shank
Kito Kito wake up
Manito it don't even bother
is you me you I don't need those
defibrillator I don't even want to
welome back to life holes
Kito go back into your body my body's
stupid
holes I'm fine right here on the spirit
plane life is for
[__] oh my
Kito Kito go to the light n I'm good man
Kito does heaven man I don't need to go
to heaven HS Heaven is for [__] oh
boy
hey you know what let me hit
that really I can handle it I am certain
that you cannot oh come on I smoked a
ton of weed in the '90s
right the '90s um you know weed has
gotten a lot stronger since then you
honestly think it's gotten so much
stronger that I just flat out can't
handle it you think I'm such a
lightweight that if I take one puff you
already took a puff an hour ago we've
had the same conversation 15 times in a
row
yeah hey you know what let me hit that
really thanks thank
you Mike yeah hey how are you man good
to see hey I'm glad I ran into you what
is that joke that you told recently at
the office everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time and I
haven't heard it yet oh gosh okay um all
right it goes like this so there's this
woman
okay good
audience I love it already I love it
already awesome okay well this should go
well um so there's this uh woman and she
goes to her doctor she go to the
doctor I haven't even gotten to the
setup
yet so she goes to her doctor and she um
she says to her doctor uh kiss me
no that's not it that's not it not not
not the not the
punchline you guys stop man you're
killing me over here y you I don't know
if you think the joke is over but it's
not it's actually just
starting okay so I'm going to I'm just
going to speed it up so she says to her
doctor kiss me he says I can't it would
be unprofessional no no not even close
she says says that would be
unprofessional and then she says she
keeps asking him and he says no no no
happens three times like
that finally at the end she
says kiss me and he says I shouldn't
even be having sex with you right
now then what
happens I I don't I don't know then I
guess she she probably sued him for
malpractice
superce so you know that wasn't that
wasn't the punch line that wasn't the
punch line no the punch there's
more there's not more there's
more no there's actually less what is it
turn it
around no there's you turn it around
said
the joke was it can't be the punchline
was the only part that you didn't laugh
at what
the you got got me you're doing a joke
the whole time you were doing a weird
character the whole time yes yes I love
the malpractice stuff the malpractice
Pune line is hilarious so you weren't
aren't doing a character what character
what character this is some
crazy
yo hi
y' hi
y' y y Excuse excuse me oh man oh man oh
man man I tell you one thing if 911s
were to happen up on this here
plane don't worry we got
this okay I have no idea what you're
talking
about he saying that if them terries is
going to try something up in here today
like the bounce Boogie and
bump that we got D
on ter do you mean terrorists oh yeah
help yeah baby he ain't talking about
Terry gar and I certainly ain't talking
about no terry cloth I mean if for Terry
up on this plane even thinking about
trying to do something we going to dra
him up you you're going to you're going
to what we're going to
dra
SC I think when my partner is trying to
say is if any terries come up in here we
going to get our burer on
yeah did something happen or did I miss
something is hypothetical or oh we going
to definitely drop some hypotheticals on
that Terry's clavical cuz I'm talking
about sque sque sque
sque don't you just wish so don't you
just wish in Your Heart of Heart some
Terry would come up in here trying some
grab ass and the touchy feely that's
it's the opposite of what I want to have
happen on a plane okay that's
unfortunate
conference this was unexpected certainly
was I'm thrown right now as to who's
going to be our comrade you doesn't have
the heart nor the gumption literally
right next to me oh three break
three
youo I got a an idea feel free to say no
but can we switch seats I will not take
no for an
answer why that's the combat seat
Jonathan Livingston
seago if you going to be in the combat
seat then you got to be willing to blast
up on some
carries because with great power come
great respon
tril okay I just I just wanted some leg
room um okay Max leg room you get yours
meanwhile I'm going to go Hayden Panton
theary on some terries especially when
they get
froggy ribbit
ribbit um you going to have to be ready
to kidnap a Terry I don't you going to
have to be ready to torture a Terry I
don't think that's necessary absolutely
you have to fireboard those mother jamas
I don't even understand what that means
do you trust me no I'll take that as a
yes okay trust these terries come up in
here trying to act
froggy then we going to give them the
Rainbow Connection yeah frog and frog is
that a box cutter oh you best believe it
baby we going to be eating like Diane
keep 2.35 in baby sh wax perfectly
League well mhm and if those don't work
you know I'm working up that plan B
brother you a G oh yeah 3D prin of baby
100% polyurethane they can't detect
these Mama
Jam have a they have a weapon they have
a weapon weap where you at Terry
everybody relax we taking control of
this
[Applause]
place my got on the right is the
ring
[Music]
my
dra
[Music]
Scout
oh there you are
Cedric sup dude T well Cedric T well
yeah can I ask you a question man um why
the hell are you dressed like this and
what the hell did you do to your bike
you ain't heard I'm steampunked now yeah
I don't know what that is
man jwes
Veron I seriously think that you have
cracked man all right like like in your
mind nah I ain't cracked up I live in
the clock
now umbrellas and blimps
you're wearing a top hat with a door on
it I'm just an ill ass Lemony Snicket up
in this [__] but you what's with you
what's with me I'll tell you what I'm
I'm a ill ass normal mother who' been
waiting for his friend for an hour and
10 minutes underneath a goddamn Bridge
with two homeless put chance good sir
could you point me in the direction of
the nearest
apothecary if you're talking about the
drugstore it's right there in the corner
what time does it close it closes at
10:00 man you've been there a million
times I'll check just to be sure make
sure it's still open I'm telling you
Levi if you put that piece of pipe up to
your eye and use it as a telescope I
cannot be your friend anymore this yep
still open all right I have to go Dan so
you try it no no I'm not going to try it
because it's a piece of pipe and it
doesn't have any lenses in it therefore
it's not a telescope yes but how could
you be
sure
science I'm going to look through this
piece of pipe and if it doesn't work
like a telescope then we finally done
man like not homies anymore we're
[Music]
done oh s
why would you
think in a million
years did that would actually work C
existant you look so ridiculous right
now I
look say goodbye rather to we what what
the is
that oh
telling you it's totally legal these
doctors they'll prescribe medical
marijuana to anyone man what do I tell
them I need it for it doesn't matter
they want to give you prescription
that's how they get paid just make
something
up hey Mr Washington welcome Hey doctor
all right I'm going to ask you a couple
questions and then what
AIDS AIDS as as in uh as in I got it
need lots of weed to get rid of
it okay AIDS um wow all right uh are you
are you sure you're not suffering from
anything else like you know back pain
nope anxiety cool is a cucumber how
about insomnia sleep like a
baby with AIDS okay Mr WatchON let's
just slow your roll for a second here if
you had AIDS then I would have to verify
it by seeing test results whereas if you
have back pain or anxiety or anything
else that I can't test for then I can
give you this prescription for cannabis
right now oh understand oh I see I get
my bad good good good okay so leprosy no
no because if you had leprosy I'd have
to quarantine you what do you no okay I
see your fingers falling off that's no
don't do that though that's not going to
work scurvy nope rickets what no
consumption no Mr Washington something
from this Century schizophrenia you
don't have
schizophrenia no keep it simple
please what the hell is that I don't
know what that is that's a fish hook in
my lip just picked something off this
list I can't reach it why not
paralyzed does your face hurt Mr
Washington yeah then this should help I
wake up next to this guy and as usual I
don't even know his
name I'm trying to get dressed quickly
and get out of there before he wakes up
but I can't find my underwear
I look everywhere but I just can't find
them and then it hits me I had left them
at another guy's apartment earlier that
night and that's when I knew I had a
[Applause]
problem thanks for sharing
Sky well I notic a lot of new faces this
evening and I'm so glad you all came and
I want you to know that this is a safe
place to
share so if you want to tell us your
story there'll be no
judgment sure I'll
go hi y'all name's Wendell and I am in
fact a sexual addict hi wend wend and
what brings you here
Wendell well you know my life sexually
speaking is crazy and I just want to
find one single solitary
person to spend the rest of my life with
just one just
one so do you feel like your addiction
is too much to handle right now duh I
mean it's been crazy
y'all with me the nastier the
better I'm a dirty dog try everything
all the
fixings
tantric much like
Sting all the bells and whistles you
name it I've dced
it and when would you say you hit rock
bottom wend when it got slippery outside
my shower on the floor outside my shower
oh I hit rock bottom
sexually probably last night last night
do you think that you could tell us what
happened wend yeah let's see uh it's
just like any other night I had ordered
a large pie pepperoni pineapple cheesy
crust cheesy bread on the
side I cut two 30 minute later pizza
parlor sent over a delicious lady
delivery
person Body Tan face
tan that's my
weakness so I invited her
inside opened up the box it was
hot devoured the First Slice licked as
split crust first second slice didn't
stand a chance ate the tip of that [__]
first washed it down with a
pop then I got nasty with the cheesy
bread my heart started pounding harder
than usual Cur lunk C slunk moved on to
the third slice what what what about the
girl what girl oh the girl yeah she was
there
too invited her into my budoir AKA the
stabbing
cabin we disrobed one another I touched
her on her genitalia she touched me on a
manalia and that's when I hit
it sexually of course Upstairs
Downstairs all around the town stairs as
you do and uh by then it was just
another night I mean oil everywhere
and sauce all over
me sauce oh yeah that's my word
for
ejaculate any who I'm so uh distraught
because I I feel vulnerable and I don't
know I just feel like
anyone could take advantage of me right
now any
one okay let's see what the blondes have
to say
first well thank you wendum thank you
for sharing it's actually our time
[Applause]
today this is not just another streaming
app what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you joking me bro this is
daily late and late Lake this is real
roasted and raw this is great standup
great movies and the great corn Holio
are you threatening me no this is one
pump two pumps and three pumps hi hi
this is live sports breaking news and a
mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now
[Music]
streaming it's Friday night Make some
noise
put your hands in the
[Music]
air if you cool like a pimp put your
hands off if you cool like a pimp put
your hands off cuz you're an actual pimp
put your hands off if you own a bunch of
women put your hands
up if you going to hit it all night put
your hands up if you going to hit put
your hands up if you maintain an
erection for 12 hours put your hands
up without the benefit of iagra put your
hands
up if you a real life player put your
hands up if you abuse women's trust put
your hands up if you treat her like
objects put your hands up
if you a real life Gangsta put your
hands up if you a real life gangster put
your hands up if you kill other people
put your hands
up if you're the biggest boss here put
your hands
up if you run an actual drug ring put
your hands up
if you just realize that you're full of
put your hands
[Applause]
[Music]
up it's your
landlord hey
Devon hey how you doing brother how you
doing yeah just uh stopping by just want
to check up on everything you
know okay
you in here you little
mother
nope closet look
good door is strong so y'all selling in
yeah we've been living here a year and a
half so we have so how these covers are
working out for
you nobody in here besides your stuff
which looks good thank
you completely unrelated have y'all seen
a 4 foot1 dude with a purple beard up in
here no no no no one's in here probably
because we locked the
door oh he got the body like a
rat he can just squeeze through the
vents yeah so you think somebody's
hiding in my apartment no I told you
it's just a social call I mean why would
Gerald be in here anyway Gerald there is
a man with a purple beard beard named
Gerald in my apartment hell no why did
you see him about 4' n got a purple
beard yeah
[Music]
baby
oh hey baby girl you ain't
Jal oh by the bye have you seen a 4 foot
five purple beard baby Devon what's
going
on okay you know what I'm going to level
with y'all there is a 43 with a purple
beard named Gerald somewhere in this
building why does he keep getting
smaller every time you mention him
seriously cuz I didn't want no alarm
y'all he he is disturbingly small really
he a good guy he smoke Rock though I
mean he'll do anything to get money for
crack anything
okay I mean anything I get it he will
murder you well we certainly hope you
find him oh I'm going to find him don't
worry about that cuz I'm going to look
low and then I'm going look
H Jerald you tiny little [__] sorry for
the inconvenience y'all J when I get my
hands on you you going to be
too we met B boy Joseph in Atlanta GA hi
Joseph what's
up start the
[Music]
music has he
started yeah I'm pretty sure this is
it
[Music]
thank
you yeah thank you I ain't done yet
though thank you Joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no I'm
sorry no all right thank you Joseph
thank
you cuz you know I I ain't got no formal
training or nothing like that I learned
on the streets that was very parent as
it turns out Joseph so thank you for
coming you know that my my mama's ons
and my daddy and jail it's not not
really relevant yeah born in a coffee
can under a bridge that's terrible
Joseph that's that's awful but it's not
going to my sister shot my brother while
my cousin beat my uncle okay now it's a
it's a little bit much Joseph thank you
very much but put myself to school by
renting my body out as a heroin suit
case all right I see what's going on
Joseph please we we do have other
dancers here today who are waiting their
turn very politely no Joseph let her
come on stage let her come no Joseph if
I won this competition I could put a
roof over my house cuz I got a house
ain't got no roof for real though Joseph
just one little thing though don't do it
Joseph it was a loud Bridge don't finish
that S I got hearing damage in this ear
Joseph and also in this here the bridge
have trucks go over it because the
bridge keep it 15 ton hold it put it in
your mouth and get off my stage rate
rated six Joe that's a big truck Seth
okay Joseph please and who is this oh
who is this right here this is my
12-year-old daughter who I raised all by
myself without the help of anybody else
in the entire world she is my
inspiration Joseph it doesn't matter
there's nothing you can do or say that's
going to make us change our minds today
that right there that right there that's
her daughter she blind come
[Applause]
on so I raise them both by myself
without nobody else's help come get your
ticket to
Vegas good job can you believe it I'm
getting goosies over
here what does it take to save a child
in
Africa to save them from the
violence to save them from becoming a
Child
Soldier what if I told you that all it
took was just one beard for the price of
one costume beard you can save a child
from becoming another statistic another
warlord's
Pond be
safe that's
right just one
beard and for a little more you can get
him
[Music]
aain we here for that
g
[Music]
[Applause]
these are all old people we are wasting
our
time
[Music]
wait
go
[Music]
go call
today we'll put a be
AF
child Mr cook you're almost up are you
ready good I'm good okay really going to
need you to stick to the script on this
one I'm the CEO of Apple Willis I'm not
going to do anything stupid please stop
comparing me to Steve Jobs no nobody's
comparing you to Steve Jobs okay I just
want you to focus on the products and
please stick to the script okay you're
on in three they're going to forget they
ever heard the name Steve
Jobs what up Apple
people
yeah yeah know the first thing that I'm
going to do is t o TS throw out the
scripts
now I'm supposed to come out here and
tell you about some bull new iPhone pad
pod dick [__] you've seen it
boring yes that's exactly
it now let's just say this table right
here let's say it's Bill Gates huh
well that's what I'm talking about and
let's say that this is our competitor's
new smartphone
how about that now
what I am and I am a major donkey dick
W right and let's say that this right
here this is one of our competitor's new
eBook reader huh what about that what
uh-oh
Tut looks like
[Applause]
[Music]
Wayne yeah yeah
woo
yeah all
right yes who wants to see some of that
classified Next Level huh did Steve ever
show you that classified no he didn't
you can't do that they haven't been
tested yet this device will allow you to
teleport anywhere on the planet check
this out I am
the
Future Let's see Steve Jobs do
that hold up hold up listen up listen up
on that's right y'all cuz you know what
we only get one two yeah let's leave it
all on the field today hell yeah we
going to give them something they can
remember yeah let's do
this yeah yeah yeah we
Unstoppable this is what we work for
y'all it's time to handle our
business we never want Up In
Here We The Best of the Best of the Best
of the Best
don't never let nobody tell you
different you is not an
option we all show that we the best in
everyone this is our time this is our
moment we can't let nobody take this
away from
us
we a team y'all we got to do this
[Applause]
together I a never had no family like
this
y'all Y my
family y'all my brothers forever you
know I got your back
y'all I know y'all got
mine we're taking this all the way to
the Super Bowl y'all this is all years
this is all
[Music]
dtin
let's keep doing like we've been do all
[Music]
see
[Applause]
we do what we was trained to
do can nobody
St we can do anything we set our minds
[Music]
to
play this
game like it's the last game of your
[Music]
life okay still and settle down settle
down that includes you Mr Rodriguez do
you want to take the milk carton off of
your
head thank you so much we have a special
guest
today he's from this
neighborhood and he's a former gang
member and he's coming here this morning
to talk to you about Life Choices so
please give a warm Central High School
welcome to Donnie Herrera
I used to be just like
you just like you you you you used to
clown
around make fun of the
principal put milk on my head just like
you
Rodriguez
and
then I got hit with
AIDS
consequences got into some real Trouble
boy stole from my mom and
dad stole from my own sister and then
one
day a piano fell on my head what
consequences feel lucky Mr step there
gave me 88 concussions one for each key
you think I'm learning but
no see I'm just like you I got back out
there started making some real crimes
home
boy oh yeah oh yeah and
then I got trampled by a herd of buffalo
what
consequences okay Donnie um I think
we've had enough done with my
story I was like you I decided to be
cool to hang out with some of the tough
kids you know who I'm talking about they
were hanging on the streets late at
night more than cigarette smokers homes
and
then one day I got shot out of a
catapult that's it okay into the mouth
of a dragon students everything you've
heard here today is a lie I don't lie
anymore you're all
excused
me look at me I shouldn't even be here
thank
youo I apologize so I got really deep in
crimes I did a driveby at my own
daughter's
kin yeah shut up everybody dead killed
yeah yeah then I got sucked into a
wormhole consequences that's it okay
everybody go I was in another dimension
tried to introduce my own parents to
each other almost failed arm was
disappearing I invented Johnny Be Good
at my parents prom and at the last
moment they kissed and it came back the
faster we get away from him the better
nobody believe me where's my crack where
my
crack consquences
all right so we have to remember
H5 okay um oh I got it high five oh I
see oh that's good I see what you're
trying to do they're trying to figure
out a pneumonic device uh okay high
fives came out in the 70s that's when
they were invented that's a seven
there's two of us so if you subtract two
from Seven that's five okay great so you
got it so um and then um there's five
major food groups why are you going on
oh no you're going to love this just
this is fun for me cuz it's a puzzle no
no puzzle okay five major food groups
there meat vegetables grain Dairy and
fruits my favorite fruit is pineapple
but you know that we got it already
pineapple comes from Hawaii okay and o o
my favorite current show is Hawaii 5
Hawaii 5 okay so that's it done we're
done Hawaii and Scott Scott Khan is the
star ha50 we're really talking about
Scott his father is James KH who's one
of the five major
stars's of the one of the five major
huge Stars H right of Godfather movies
so it's Pino
Brando and
um Dian Keon yes D Keon and it's easy to
remember her name because her name is
the same last name as Buster Keon and
Michael ke both Comedians and when you
laugh you say ha stop stop stop stop
stop stop you see what you're doing
you're over complicating the whole thing
we already had it you just you just you
just making it more difficult just like
you do everything I left my phone in in
the car which is wait hold up a Dap no
no it was it was handshake no I got it I
got it I got it ha Buster Keaton and
Michael Keaton same last name as Diane
Keaton is one of the five huge stars on
The Godfather movies it's Keaton Brando
Duval Pacino and James Khan who's the
father of Scott KH who's the star of
Hawaii 5 Hawaii pineapple pineapple my
favorite fruit five major food groups
there's two of us 5 plus 2 is seven
that's the 70s win high five
high five high five I had it D it turns
out it wasn't a ghost at all it was my
little sister hiding in the basement she
was making the noises the whole
time oh shoot I forgot his juice boxes
oh I will be right back you'll be all
right with Zach I think so okay
so
Zachary you know I'm going to be
marrying your mother and uh I'm going to
be moving in soon and I
just I'm just so excited to spend more
time with
you you know I
know that you had a hard time with your
father and that is thanked you and you
know I just want you to
know that's not going to happen with
me okay and I promise I will never spank
you oh okay
that's okay
um I know why you did
that but I will never spank you because
I know that you still oh
that's
yeah I don't know that there's anything
I did to deserve that okayy
this you okay I'm going to be real with
you you can't go hitting people all
right oh oh oh I ain't coming back for
that fourth one
all right so we done we got that out of
our system cuz I know that
this this isn't
you oh I told you you
want oh oh come on
D
you fast oh what oh that's
unbelievable I'm the good guy I'm I'm
the good guy
man
look I'm never going to spank
you I'm not going to be like your
father I'm going to be your
friend you need to respect me you
understand you
little
I will respect you
Charles if you play your role now listen
up I'm a bad bad boy
Charles I don't need a
friend so go ahead marry my mommy move
in her as hard as you want just leave me
the
alone you do that 11 years from now I'll
be out of the house and we won't have
any
problems you
don't and I will break
you okay he
[Applause]
Charles how are we doing I love
[Music]
him well well
well Jack welcome make yourself
comfortable you're going to be here for
quite some time he'll never get away
with this
Dage that is all Dean
leave
us now where were we you're wasting your
time drage the military codes were
destroyed is that
so I think you're bluffing
Jack and I am about to
call
you're block you see Jack I am a player
in this
game
but I'm also the dealer I hold all of
the
[Music]
cards you see Jack if I were to go all
in you would not be able to cover the
beds
what are you
doing I was thinking like maybe I could
be like your torturing assistant or
something I could be in the room with
you and like be that guy that stands in
the background all intimidating like and
that way fine fine over there and keep
your trap shut yeah that's what I that's
what that's what I was
thinking well you two down with your
little ladies chat oh shouldn't have
said
that you know Jack it's very appropo
that D would say that because I feel
like we should have a chat and when I
say we I mean just you and
me
are you a chess player Jack
sure so then you're aware that each
piece serves a different
function you
see whereas you are merely a pawn you
see Jack I am a
queen I am allowed to move around the
board with impunity
what this with the l y man I was
thinking like maybe during your chest
speech you could suck on this lollipop
cuz then that shows him like you so
comfortable with torture you just do
something stupid like sucking on a
lollipop you see what I'm
saying I need you to go over there right
now I need you to be still
okay or no there is absolutely no or
involved go over there
okay you shouldn't call yourself a queen
though cuz where I'm from that means
something different than
shh
Jack I've been waiting for this
moment for a very very long time I
wanted to make an
introduction to your new best friend
I'll never talk oh this will make you
talk
Jak and you plus you don't even need to
stab him at first you can just like
caress his cheek with the blade
something just real like crazy yeah I
got it I got it you good that's what I
was planning on doing I'm sorry where
did we find you shaan's cousin who is
Shaquan Shuan no no I'm asking you who
he is he got kicked into some lava so
that's when I came in okay that's
wonderful I need you to go over there
and I you to be stuck still like a
statue yeah yeah now like immediately
keep moving in that direction no yeah
I'm
good
Jack the military codes are not even the
primary reason why you are here I wanted
you all to myself he's standing back
there like an actual statue isn't he
yeah it's
weird God damn
it thean you don't have to stand like an
actual statue not literally I didn't
mean it literally oh all right I thought
that sounded stupid when you said that
originally I like yeah it would be
stupid for a person to do something like
that shoot cuz I didn't know I was like
what that do
make
Jack today you will experience the most
Exquisite pain I may or may want get yo
we got pictures of his girlfriend uhhuh
that's it that's pretty much torture
over right there you can just show him
pictures of his girlfriend and he'll do
whatever you say there it is oh you know
what even better we got a cage it's got
a hole at the bottom so you can put that
over his head you and this other hole
you put like a rat or a scorpion up in
there that's what is there for the Quan
all right that is that he's there for in
the first place all of the implements
that you're seeing on the table there
are there for a particular
reason what about that oh you know
what the quad would you like to be
involved that's what I was thinking
since the
beginning I was
thinking maybe you should just tell them
like the military
codes
was I speeding
officer you don't look like you're from
around here no
sir you've been doing any drugs tonight
no sir nope
no
why you pop that trunk step out of
vehicle for me
please
really no drugs huh
nope well well
well what have we here no no no no no no
no no no no you planted that in my car
oh did I
or did I plant this uh I I guess against
the car right now spread them uh huh's
whoa whoa what do we have here huh what
these your colors homie that's that's
not M uh no I don't or are these your
colors or perhaps these are your colors
or are these look at all these colors
man you sure got a lot of colors look at
all of these
colors
are you a real cop freeze what is
that well well well it looks like an
illegal
firearm
or is
it
oh I'm I don't I don't know what this is
I'm sorry pick a card it's not even a
good fan any card you can just stick
there okay you took that card yeah now
can you remember that card yes can you
commit that card to memory this is
unbelievable have you done so have you
done so please insert the card back into
the deck randomly it's in a different
place than where you took it
originally there we are there we are now
ridiculous I take the deck like so I
give it to
scil and
abroy
okay is this your call no are you sure I
want your badge
number
how did you do
that
and that is for
you after all that you're still giving
me a ticket is it a ticket or is it a
two for one coupon for my show at the
magic house Thursday night at 11:00 p.m.
your
call I'll take the
ticket
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids okay
excuse me boarding group one I'm in
boarding group one excuse me I'm in
boarding group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first class passengers first
class passengers only
please next our business class
passengers may now
board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite
members okay now all passengers with
children anyone with small children you
may Bard
now okay we would like to continue
boarding with uniformed military
personnel what why get this is thank you
for your service thank you so much for
your service God bless you thank you for
your service
thank you for your service all right
people in
wheelchairs any priests nuns rabbis
imams what why do they get special
treatment asalam alaikum I've
never that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with
babies any old religious people with
military babies what's a
military
thank you for your
service Jason
schwarzman anyone with a blue suitcase
you may now board finally no not you sir
not me this is a blue suitcase that's a
blue computer bag so you're not you're
not going to let me on
then
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it God damn it anyone who doesn't
seem
cranky drunk people you will now be
boarding any drunk
people drunk people
Bo all right it's no it's my bag
sir
just hello oh hey
Christian
yeah totally well you have your
favorites and I have my
favorites
okay call you later CIA
Chow boarding group
[Music]
one up your hand
J I got him I got schwarzman here
everyone Jason schwarzman
[Music]
F we got Jason schwarzman let's wrap it
up
people boarding group one over here get
a boarding group one one
two there goes the girl who owns my
heart I knew she was the one right from
the Star our love is here to stay each
and every day we know that we will
never wow great work everybody Troy I
love that little mtown outro thing super
Soulful cool thanks L yeah just uh came
to me so I went with it wow it's crazy
hey is this uh where the Acappella group
meets oh hey Mark hey Lyall what's going
on buddy Mark get over here guys this is
my buddy Mark he just transferred from
Minnesota I thought he could uh sit in
on a few practices I don't know maybe
join the group maybe all right guys
let's do always been my girl again from
the top and Mark show us your stuff you
got it man all right guys ready one
two my
heart I knew she was the one right from
the
start our love is here say each and
every day we know that we will never
part
[Music]
you got to be kidding me mar was out of
this world gosh okay well hey it just it
just came to me so I just went with it
great well keep going with it guys have
a safe weekend all right see you on
Monday nice to meet you guys man that
was awesome it's need the best cool guys
great practice Troy good effort all
right yeah check you later guys guys see
you later
alligators think you
doing I'm doing my
thing you
doing this my seven white
boys
you need to back the
up
that I'm about to get mine do you have
any idea how long it took for me to
infiltrate this
grow 25
minutes you think I'm going to roll over
with some faletto
ass you know
what white boys is going to do what
white boys is going to do and if they
want to run with a high ass singing
falet
on then that's on them oh that's on them
then oh that's on them okay so it's like
that oh it's stole like that well watch
your back okay watch your back you
my and improvise oh it's so cold out
it's going to be dark soon oh my God
yeah we should build a fire yeah um oh I
can't oh fire
fire oh no it's a black
cat hey man what a cat got to be
black
free man I guess I got to put my dick
away
[Applause]
[Music]
a
let me
throw this
is what's the matter rich in the next
episode Steve Urkel turns Carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious buddy it's
hilarious come on I'm an actor Jean this
was supposed to be about me and my
family I know but you know after that
after that first death spot with Steve
Urkel I mean America found love them man
we had to make him a regular and you
know Hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we got to play ball
bubble don't you dare bubble of me Jean
now last week Steve used his
transformation machine to turn Carl into
a car and drive him around the mono
Grand Prix come on how many times are we
going to use this transformation machine
this was supposed to be a blue coll
Cosby Show now you turn it into goddamn
Quantum Leap who writes this I I
couldn't tell you even if I wanted to
okay may we got like 21 writers up there
okay you know what I'm saying Reginald
but you and I both know but they don't
decide what happens in the show okay we
both know who decides what happens in
the show two weeks ago Steve erco used
to invisibility Ray on Carl and I wasn't
even in the goddamn episode it was just
my voice yes I know I know R I'm sorry I
apologize will never happen again then
Steve used his voice changing Ray to
turn Carl into a high pitched nerdy
Voice who do you think provided the
voice for that don't get too feisty on
me now re let's not go down that path
okay oh oh we're going down that path
Jean in a couple of weeks Harriet Eddie
Laura grandma Aunt Rachel Little Richie
and the other little kid are going to
get teleported to another dimension and
then Steve injects Carl with his own DNA
so Carl turns into another Steve Urkel
that's two Steve urkles and no family on
a show called family matters how the
does that work listen listen re I don't
want to tell emania is Unstoppable okay
he's a phenomenon there's nothing we can
do about it okay it's up
to him no no no no no I'm an actor I'm a
actor I a real actor I did Richard theii
I was in true West with Sherman helsley
I was in Die Hard damn it Steve Ur you
will suck Steve 's if he want you to you
will suck his you understand he is our
bread and butter you mother I am high on
cocaine I'm a jeene I done more cocaine
than you way mother I'm going to tell
you what you are RL Johnson you're a
pawn in that nerd's game you are a pawn
do you think I have any power over what
that monster does any power at
all I am the SE
vice president of development for the
americ
jeane
Jean Jean what's become of you
Jean
I I'm
nothing Gan I don't know what you mean
by that je but you're scaring me no no
don't don't don't do anything crazy Jean
everyone does too much coke sometimes
but just what are you going to do with
the gun Jean what are you going to do no
no no no no no no no no we can talk this
through okay the king is
dead long live the
king did I do
[Music]
that Jalil Jal
there is no jalile only
Steve it's always been Steve give me K
mother forgetting something Carl don't
you come near me stay away from me here
could have all been so simple Carl just
say your lines and take the money your
monster
what are you doing I I I can't control
am I doing this no no no no no no no no
ST I'll do anything you will do what I
want on Family
Matters
yes of course
[Music]
Steve see you on set
Carl
get out of my house
[Applause]
Steve
oh hi that wasn't expecting to see you
all undulating up here I I just uh put
my Jack on the bed when I first came to
the party but uh I didn't realize that
the party made its way up here but I'll
get that now I will if you uh Carol I
don't know if you're in there somewhere
but uh wherever you are thank you for
the invitation I really enjoy myself
I'll see you at work tomorrow okay Hey
sir I think I see my jacket I think I I
think your arm is in the sleeve actually
I'll grab that's not my jacket and
that's not your arm it's not your arm
white people are crazy white people are
crazy just looking for a jacket sir okay
yeah very nice mustache I've never seen
one above the nose that's interesting
that's not your nose okay sorry to uh
disturb you sir just looking for a
jacket just a ordinary man looking for a
jacket you want to say something to me
sir are you oh no thank you very much
sir it tasted a little bit like salted
but but that's okay it's Tweed the
jacket I'm talking about and it's got
leather patches on it just oh maybe this
is it thank you found it and nope that's
not it but congrat ulations ma'am you
are doing great with what God gave you
nope don't look at me in the eyes ma'am
I don't want you to steal my soul hi
ladies and nice to meet you and sir yes
I do see you too okay yes white people
are crazy oh no I'm I'm okay I really am
I'm uh already seeing a a group of
people and we're taking it slowly we are
taking it slowly it's a church maybe
some of y'all would be interested in
looking into that not mine but one
somewhere if that's a okay thank you
ma'am for there it is I found it found
the jacket it's right here I'm going to
pull it and I believe it might be lodged
somewhere within you I'm just guessing
because that is just a little bit of
resistance all right there we go and you
know what that is going to be yours keep
it thank you cover yourself up Carol if
you're in there I'll see you at the
office tomorrow just bring the bowl you
can finish the egg salad my God why
people go to see old boy how's Kenya
well I love Kenya absolutely adore the
place you know it's so important to
protect them you know oh the few
untouched tribes left indeed yes and
while we're on the subject I've got
something of a confession to make oh
dear while I was down there I caught the
attention of a young Messi woman you
didn't she took me for an exotic
sophisticated Superman of sorts and
developed something of a liking to me
well isn't that always the way yes it is
and it's quite awful Gerald she came
down to my Hut wearing nothing but a
fertility headdress and carrying a
husband stick and oh I had to
participate in the custom well you'd be
morally irresponsible if you did not
participate in the custom you could
destroy the entire social structure oh I
felt so terrible about of course you did
Gerald I felt terrible seven times but
you know Gerald I too have a confession
do tell remember several years ago when
I went to the Amazon yeah yes well I
accidentally packed a lighter in my SEL
oh my yes well one day I absentmindedly
lit the Flint and the entire Village
took me for a god oh no yes every
Sundown as I was being fated by all the
young women of the village which is the
local custom I felt completely
embarrassed by the entire
aair imagine in some vivid detail but
you can't deny the local custom you
absolutely cannot deny the local custom
can't deny loal you cannot deny the
local custums one thing you must do is
adhere to the local custumes must hear
the local Customs
loal people must the local Customs local
Customs must local C it's the least one
can do it all reminds me of the time I
was in Papa New Guinea and I introduced
the local tribe to the French term
manaja after that evening a couple of
the local men called me Papa oh dear
whoops
Daisy whoopsy Daisy indeed it's getting
harder and harder to protect the local
tribes from the influence of the outside
civilization I know exactly what you
mean oh boy exactly and I must confess
that the last time I was deep in the
bution Australia yes I ended up deep in
Bush and Australia booah well where are
you off to now old boy I'm off to
Tanzania Tanzania make sure that you go
deing an eclipse because then everyone
will want to have sex with
you
regrettably
men as we launched the Counterattack
against the Union Army we must remember
that even though we may die a glorious
death on the battlefield we do so to
preserve a way of life the southern way
of life a way of life so pure and
beautiful that no man nor government can
take this away from
us the
right the right to preserve
our own
[Music]
s we
are well hello there m sorry we late
sure didn't mean to sneake up on you sir
look fellas we're trying to have a nice
little Civil War reenactment here we
don't want any trouble so are we sir we
we we try to have a real nice
reenactment we certainly don't want to
cause any trouble either do we say you
always TI
trouble only come to those who gone done
looking for it so don't stop your
speeching on our
County as Jefferson D okay I know what
you're doing I get it what are we doing
sir I don't know what you're talking
about do you know what he talking about
Sam why we just hear the slave on about
any oh which way you want us to how many
times you I have to tell people just
because we're dressed like conf soldiers
doesn't mean we're pro slavery we're
just here to preserve the pure and
beautiful slice of Southern history yeah
pure and beautiful like slice oh lord
lord lord we sorry oh we so Sor please
don't give us the whip okay nobody's
going to whip anybody ju just stop it
yeah just stop it all right fellas just
just ignore them all right now we're
here to preserve our way of life the
South has the right to own
the South has a way of
life the union cannot stop
[Music]
us the union Yankee bastards cannot stop
us from stop it stop it that's enough
you want to be part of this reenactment
fine you're part of it go go go fetch us
some Munitions and everything else don't
just stand there like a bunch of
lazy that good enough for you that is
all I needed to hear gentlemen give us
your cash and anything that is an actual
col Do's item you racist mother okay
don't have all day man okay thank you
thank you wallets wallets wallets wallet
that's a very nice piece these are heavy
C thanks you for
coming first thr the business I'm sure
y'all heard the twizz got pulled out the
river this morning ain't no secret he
and carille were up in the hood together
listen up Carell about to say some
words
okay you know what don't none of you
look at them tears and think that sh is
funny because it takes a big man to cry
in front of his
crew go ahead
car y'all know twig was my
boy back in the day
we used to pretend the sofa cushions was
a fort
M and we used to pretend that the floor
with M
lava okay you know what
though ain't nothing funny about
that of course this man is crying cuz he
and twigs with kids together okay you
mean they best friends
forever
go ahead
carille we used to play
[Music]
carebear twig and I would spend the good
part of an afternoon trying to figure
out with carebear we
was oh I wish one of y'all
M would just start laughing cuz y'all
know you think this is funny Carell over
here blubbering and talking about Care
Bears but you know
what but
you throw some manly tears okay thr some
manly ass tears right there that you
looking
at go ahead
Carell
[Laughter]
I'm sorry man that was a weird ass
sneeze I just did right there godamn it
can the brother get some Claritin up in
here go ahead
Carell wigs always fancied himself
[Music]
sherbear M I always I always thought
thought of myself as more of a fun shine
bear okay okay all you need to respect
that right there okay y'all need to
listen to
Fun I'm sorry man you a funshine bear
man I'm sorry that that is some funny
all right let's go sell some
crack welcome to the 2015 East West bow
Pro Edition of all the All-Star games
and professional sports this one is sure
to be the most extravagant that's right
these players were selected by the fans
too and when it comes to flare these
characters are the Crim
DM
CR deaem Vanderbilt University cos Gro
shamway Clemson ha Clint dicks
University of Alabama doah Hugh Marshall
legon dpri West Virginia University Le
do University of Central Florida quiser
gono senior Central Connecticut State
University gry peep Georgia
Southern the brenshaw Ferguson
University of Virginia strong
FL University South Carolina St Tavian
rooc click gramling State Cornelius tank
Kine Florida State University vonius
Thicket sued Duke madun
shazbot CH University swordless M toown
Jacksonville State
University
there is a lot of talent in this game
Eric let me tell you something when you
look at Players like maradon shazbot
haha Clinton Dicks and Strunk pluggit
you're looking at players who made an
impact this year I mean is ha Clinton
Dicks even real this guy was amazing so
solid all season long for the Green Bay
Packers and when you throw in guys like
Lagoon depri thwart M toown and the
bickershaw Ferguson this is surely going
to be a squad for the ages I agree now
let's meet the players from the
West Prince of Muka University of
Nebraska Jr junior Juniors Junior Texas
Christian University
F University of
Oregon fzy Whitaker the University of
Texas Myriad
profiterol
Utah Busters
Browns Illinois State
cupcake man
un washing is Kitchen Ken State
University Take It to the
Limit College of the canas snoff men's
plots East Los Angeles College Frosty
Rucker University of Southern
California Northwestern University
triple paru Ball State log jammer to
baggage clean North Texas
University a Aon Rodgers
Cal let's get this party started ladies
and gentlemen this is Paramount plus
this is Strokes of Genius beautiful
games and One Shining Moment this is
Defenders investigators and seven
strangers pick to live in a house this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and
younger this is everything you've been
looking for that's going to leave a mark
life for breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now
[Music]
streaming there's got got to be another
human being out
there
[Music]
somewhere it's been
173 days since the
undoing today I'm may be the last man
alive however if there is another I will
find
them the loneliness is more than I
[Music]
can there we
go
[Music]
soon
[Applause]
my just like y know nothing about
that hey baby how you
doing
yeah day
[Music]
baby whoa hey dude hey I I'll come over
there dude hey I'll come to you
[Music]
man there's got to be another human
being out
there
somewhere but Bab moving out please this
is the worst possible time please don't
do this
babe garbage huh can I'll take your
garbage yeah
sure you know I find the more garbage in
the
Can the better it feels to dump it all
out
I suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the voice
place so we can start
over here to fix the copy yes sure sure
hey how did you sometimes things ain't
really broken it's the way we treat them
it needs to be
fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is who are you
Steve well if it isn't Mr stand there
[Music]
Carl
you need to find your own troubled white
boy I was here
[Music]
first topic
hands sweep this this
[Music]
damn TR the
field there can be only one
[Music]
[Applause]
magical
[Music]
good Lord are you all
right
well I guess sometimes things have to
come apart before we can put them back
together again oh you're a magical negro
too who you call a negro
[__] ladies and Gentlemen please turn
off your cell phones and enjoy our
production of lunch with
greatness my my my what a beautiful day
in Montgomery
Alabama I swear the sun is so hot I
nearly melted indeed Dr King but I
suspect we didn't meet meet here to talk
about the
weather indeed brother Malcolm unless of
course we articulate that the sun in
this country shines brighter on some
than it does on
others yes but when the sun does shine
on us it is growing the seeds of
[Music]
revolution
I see your point brother Malcolm but do
not those same seeds need to be watered
with
love I suppose that is the subject of
some discussion Dr
King and I am all for discussion brother
Malcolm unless of course the words
devolve into proclamations of
hate well or is that not why we are here
today Dr King to
discuss yes brother Malcolm and I am
confident that as we discuss we are
going to discuss it and discuss it until
I
say
that our people have never resorted to
violence before the white man gave them
no choice but to pay him back in the
only currency he
[Applause]
understands brother
Malcolm is that what you really have to
say at this point in our lunch indeed Dr
King because we didn't land on Plymouth
Rock Plymouth Rock landed on us
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah I've heard
you say that before I don't know why
we're talking about rocks when in fact
it is the Flesh and the bone and the the
dreams I I have a dream that someday our
children will be judged by the content
of their character not by the color of
their
skin yep yep yep same for me same for me
in fact I believe that one day a black
man will become the president of the
United States of
America hopefully for 8
years Obama
[Applause]
22 oh of course 8 years of course eight
years that's a given right that's a
given you know I mean but in order to
get there isn't he going to need the
help of our strong beautiful black
women got to respect the sisters got to
respect the
sisters got to respect the
sisters as Wesley snip said in pass 57
always better on
black
Drew come
forward yes chef this is a chicken kiche
with crini mushrooms baby spinach and
feta
[Music]
cheese
unbelievable Ruder I have a huge problem
with this
dish it's that you haven't made it for
me
sooner thank you
Chef because if you had Drew then I
would know how good you are at cooking
food that's
bad I'm sorry chef and when I say bad I
mean Michael Jackson
Bad thank you Chef you know how he look
really really bad at the end of his
life Chef I'm sorry I don't know if you
like the dish or not you don't know I
like the dish or not well let's put it
this way Pat your knives get out you're
off the
show sorry
Chef
because you should be working in the
finest restaurant in the
world thank you shf just not any world
that I live
in sorry shf because frankly Drew I'm
jealous of you thank you chef and your
ability to not give a about what you
could look this is not fit for human
consumption no this should be eaten by a
higher life form with a more complex
palet but also an altruistic drive to
save Humanity from dishes like this
joking not you deserve to
die so you won't have to endure a life
in which you will never exceed what you
have achieved here today
[Music]
thank you
sh in
conclusion there you go excuse me oh
excuse me sir are you sitting in
26g yes have I done something wrong no
no no no we just wanted to ask if you
would mind switching seats so that a
mother and a child could sit together
but I'm back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting
here which is an economy plus um It's
actually an upgrade upgrade you say
mhm economy plus yes sir
oh don't mind if we do great great uh
carry on carry on yourself Alex thank
you
economy Plus for the Discerning
passenger we're not in Kansas
anymore Toto ladies and gentlemen this
is your captain speaking we should be
leaving Topeka in the next 10 minutes I
stand corrected looks like we're going
to have a smooth flight trust me I know
the captain and he's one smooth
[Music]
guy
[Laughter]
of course he knows the
captain he is the captain
Oh Oh move over Colin mockery there's a
new face in the biz his name is
Captain you have to be in the comy plus
to get it I guess
ah extra foot
room one inch at
least
M Sky shop
magine oh dog ears for my
convenience Lord of the Rings cups
Lord of the Rings
tables holy shotu
massage economy plus it hurts a little
but but I like
[Laughter]
it Rose
[Music]
butt
and I thought I had an
[Music]
upgrade hey
man you got to let me out of here oh
[Music]
okay
you tricked me I can honestly say I
wasn't trying to trick
you you weren't all I said was you got
to let me out of here there's no
trick so so I I do have to let you out
of
here yes
okay
[Music]
on boy
eyes orders to let him go I don't know
why he's in here in the first place I
[Applause]
don't well you really got me in trouble
sorry yeah you must think I'm stupid
well I'm not stupid I'm smart so you you
know how you can prove that you're
really smart oh yeah let me guess you
want me to let you out of here again
well you know what you think you you can
trick me into letting you out again well
you
can't cuz this is my
choice get the heck out of here all
right all
right reverse psychology
I am sorry about that guys that was me
guys my bad my
bad real nice now they said they're
going to dock my pay and if I let you
out of here again I'm going to be
severely punished I you know I'm
actually surprised they haven't already
thrown you in here with me no prison is
for bad guys you're you're a bad guy and
I'm a good guy yeah but you can see how
from my perspective I'm a good
guy wait you're a good guy oh my
gosh it doesn't seem like you understand
what your job
is oh oh okay I see what you're doing
you're trying to you're trying to
manipulate me with reverse psychology
well it's not going to
work it's not even worth going out there
again look they just going to get me and
bring me back in here just like they
always
[Music]
do unless what no I forget it I don't
want to take advantage of him anymore
look look hey look no listen I'm not
going to fall for it whatever it is so
you may as well just tell
me I was just going to say that like if
you were to help me uhhuh get past the
guards and get all the way out okay I I
really I have to tell you you need to
think about this long and hard MH weigh
your options and consider the
ramifications of those options like KY
will
let's go I'm busting you out of here
don't yell man might as well Ring the
Alarm man idea
yeah oh hi Tom what let me see you guys
yeah oh boy I did it again that
night I was a prison a guard I was a
prison guard I wasn't allowed to talk to
the prisoners that was the thing they
said to me if you talk to those
prisoners you're going to get trouble
you're going to get trouble now that I'm
in here I
[Music]
wow you really came out of nowhere what
no no I was stopped at that stop
sign
yeah listen uh let's just exchange
information and have our insurance
companies take care of it right yeah I'm
going to get my
info yes pleas
please hey no what what what are you
doing what are you doing huh why did you
start the engine what engine the engine
of your car did I
yes I was just trying to get the uh
information for you from the glove box
do you need to start your car to open
your glove compartment uh yeah
okay you know what how about I just uh I
get your insurance information now right
sure hey no no hey hey hey stop stop
stop stop where the hell are you going
uh nowhere give me the information right
now okay right now do you understand
okay okay all right sorry I I
misunderstood I don't see how all right
here it is no no I no you're your
insurance in information I just did this
is a Walgreens receipt oh oh here it
is licensed to
fart here it
is what is that that now now you're just
miming you know what give me your
insurance information right now or I'm
calling the cops okay okay dude I'm
sorry I'm sorry that's just that's my
personality I was messing with you I I
apologize I thought you were going to
take off and and flee the scene yeah no
I'm not well then how am I going to get
my car fixed I we just hit an accident
it's obviously not the time or the place
so I'm I'm sorry here you go here it is
I mean can you imagine though yeah that
you were going to take off yeah I can't
imagine that it's giving me chills up my
[__]
spine
anyway here's the real insurance card
and
uh let me know what you think official
laminated license to fart what the hey
hey I am a
sociopath hey all I know is it's good
having another brother moving into the
neighborhood hey man it's good to have
you over and I think that you will dig
this all
right heyy huh nice guitar collection oh
thanks man hey you want to hear
something yeah sure all right all right
let's get this
to well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red W and
[Music]
true dreaming of the girl with the red
hair and freckles in her eyes like the
skies of
blue country music I grew up in Texas
you know so all right keep her safe from
the homies in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking The Reaper and
acting like
clown
keep that pretty wide dress from getting
dirty and brown cuz that's the American
way
oh pretty racist
song racist against
who black people black people but I'm
black well keeping the redheaded girl
away from the homies on the wrong side
of town homies come on brother there's
all kinds of homies you know you white
homie Asian
homies no homies are black no I think
you're making them black man I mean that
I think that's your stuff you hear the
Twang and then you assume that it's
racist but that's that's just what
country music is like here look you're
gonna like this one you like this one
all
right some folks wear their hats way off
to the side with their pants down low
and a gun tucked inside take their beer
by the 40 and their chicken deep fried I
think we all know who we're talking
about the only dark I like is when I
turn off the lights the only Hood I love
is py and white t trust you if I can't
see your face at night I think we all
know who we're talking wait wait hey
stop that that's racist what's what what
is racist about it the only Hood I love
is pointy and white yeah man that's
talking about the clan man the K clux
Clan are you outside out of your mind
that's traditional country music imagery
man like a a pickup truck or sleeping
under the stars or your dog got killed
or your wife left you same thing I would
have been fine with any of those things
what is the difference between those
things and what is in the song they're
not racial hey you know what can I just
say something man I'm just gonna be
frank you're getting a little like Al
Sharpton like farahan on me right now
man my God are you serious dude dude
please hey give me you know can I do one
more let me just do one more dog I
absolutely promise you that this song is
not racist and it's impossible for you
to misinterpret it as
such okay it seems like you're about to
sing the most racist song so far I'm
not
hi get me a ring family tree okay I'm
out come on man
hey over here trying to sing about a
tire swing
WR off an entire genre of
music the joing and the drums are a
banging let's get the boys together and
have ourselves a hanging oh damn now I
see
it now I see
[Music]
it
well tonight we going to party till the
party don't stop and the part don't stop
because it keeps on going nonstop going
to party all night going to keep this
party going cuz the party won't stop
it's been two straight days and the
party still going 2 3 4 5 6 s days till
it's Friday again and the part keeps
going party all night cuz it's said all
night
FR
[Music]
9 t Rings iPad Facebook Party Time SK
jeans Friday night dance dance dance
tonight we going out and we ain't coming
back cuz the party won't stop and we'll
go all night Friday night every night
the part going down down down down down
down down down down yor City LA Chicago
Houston Philly San Diego Phoenix Austin
for Bost Memphis Denver Port
Vegas Tampa new L
[Music]
durity weing back cuz the party won't
stop and we'll go all night Friday night
every night the part's going down down
down
down New York City LA Chicago Houston
Philly San Diego Phoenix Austin for wor
Boston Memphis Denver Portland Vegas
tucs Fresno a Tampa Pittsburgh New linol
Durham Salem City city C City
C going the then we'll just keep
partying all day long girl dancing and
[Music]
headon
so tonight
[Music]
going hey Uncle Ted oh jez sorry uncle
Ted man oh Kei I got you didn't I yeah
you got me man you got me pretty good oh
so what's going on today oh just the
usual Young Buck just another day at the
laundry while people come in the Dy
laundry we chatted up about some of the
topics of the
day that's just another day hanging at
the
mat wonder what's going on in the barers
shop today so it looks like they having
fun over
there
forget all that Kei come on we got our
own assortment of colorful characters
right here in the mat come on hey there
you need any more quarters
nope okay okay hilarious oh hey there
miss Demetrius you need some more
[Music]
quarters oh she didn't hear me that's
part of the problem Uncle Ted you know
all that noise up in here from the
machines running and it's kind of
hot loud and hot sound like my old
[Music]
lady Ben Williams is in there now he's
Lando ceran he runs Cloud
[Music]
City damn it Keith
what I tell you we got it going on right
here at the M
baby Uncle Ted I got to tell you
[Music]
something I got my own washer and dryer
months ago I just keep hanging out here
cuz I didn't want you to feel
bad oh you didn't want me to feel bad
huh got your washer dryer all right oh
you're big timing me now okay I see how
it is hey well your shirt ain't clean
your pants ain't
clean you can't get a good wash on one
of them home wash your Dy
Tad I'm going I no no no wait wait wait
wa wait wait wait wait let's have some
fun let's have some fun we you could get
in one of the laundry carts and I could
push you around
no I'm out of
here don't wa wait hold on there then
keep
keep and if that don't work then you do
a little tap dance and then you go I'm
your
man hey welcome to the barber shop young
man you're Billy D Williams yeah yeah
how you doing I'm good thank you could
you do me a favor could you let go of my
hand
okay oh thanks man all right how you
doing
man
[Music]
baby
[__] man I felt sorry for that dude but
you know what you gonna do I had to lay
that
down what that lay you down hey brother
I don't know what fight you was at this
got a couple licks in sure but I was
like
B man I put the [__] on the chain
[Applause]
wax wa
abouty about py the wa [__] on the
chain
[Music]
wax is that a
thing well yeah that yeah a that's a
that's a thing yeah yeah there
something okay yeah I put the [__] on
the chain wax [__] on the chain wax I
put the [__] on
the [__] coming in this is the chain
wax I'm putting on hold up I just um
Google [__] on the chain wax no results
man um why are you googling no I'm just
saying [__] on the chain
wax not an
expression yeah it is it is yes thank
you something Leo yeah what what what
does it mean then what does it
mean I'll tell you what it means it
means
that
is that you put the [__] on
[Applause]
the like y'all know what it is okay have
either the two of you have you ever said
the words [__] on the chain wax in any
context
us he talking you man you ain't talking
to
me hey man it's not our fault that you
ain't never put that [__]
[Applause]
no one can put the [__] on the chain
wax cuz [__] on the chain wax ain't a
thing you trying to start a thing aren't
you
what I mean what are you talking about
trying to start a thing a thing like off
the hook or I'm GNA put you on blast you
trying to get it in the eer so everybody
out there saying [__] on the chain wax
man why you doing this why you looking
up I'm saying and and fact checking my
ass you keep saying some that doesn't
exist and you got Thing One and Thing
Two corroborating your story like it
does and you why you lying that it's
[__]
[Music]
B why do you care so
much whether I made
up [__] the chain wax or
not I lost my
[Music]
job my girl left
me and all I all I wanted to
do was have a little bit of
fun with my friends
today so why why do you have why do you
have to belittle me like
that
[Music]
it's just that
I I'm just trying to say what you trying
to
say I'm trying to say that I want to put
the [__] on
[Applause]
the he put the
[__]
woo this is not just another streaming
app what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you joking me bro this is
daily late and late late this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great standup great movies and the
great corn Holio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps hi hi hi this is live sports
breaking news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
[Music]
would you look at the time you should
just stay here at night I've had too
much wine you can leave at first light
it isn't that far mayy just stay where
you are back to my place you can't
escape from
my I really had a very nice let just
that need to just say good I love to see
youe unlock this door it's lock from the
outside
tonight look I really have to go no you
really have to stay hey no means no that
is what they all say you're hurting my
arm I won't cause you any harm let go of
me we can make this harder just easy a
woman always comes prep I'm really
scared I said this is not what I want
why you have to be such a I know
selfdefense I dare you to try it I don't
want to fight [__] you are mine
[Music]
tonight please just please go away you
wanted me to stay well well I I just
changed my mind I think I'll just stay
in unwind how did this all switch now
you
are
my please be kind tonight now you're
mine
[Music]
to
oh
damn check that
out what is is that I didn't know they
made him like
that I don't even understand what I'm
seeing I would love to see what's under
there I am really really curious about
that yeah dog yeah I mean I have no idea
well you know we uh we obviously have
some idea you
know I
don't well you know it's a you know it's
a coochie
baby yeah or
something uh no no no man it's it's
definitely her lady
Parts oh or maybe it's just more
skin no it's a vagina yeah or maybe it's
a little face under
there uh no no it's it's definitely
going to be a vagina why but because
she's a girl and girls have vaginas man
what is that what is a vagina it's a
woman's reproductive or again what are
you being serious right
now thank you that is all I
[Applause]
require there's aliens there's an alien
down
[Music]
there
and Now ladies and gentlemen the man
you've been waiting for Mr Michael
Winslow go get him
Winslow Bring the Noise Bring the Noise
another soldout night for the Kings of
mouth noise got to tell you though we
wouldn't have this audience without
Winslow lucky for you huh those Police
Academy fans look at all the t-shirts
six sequels can you believe it every
sound effect this guy makes is like a
little tiny Mona Lisa popping out of his
mouth have you ever heard him do the
walking through leaves in the fall while
he
[Applause]
[Music]
d
what
boy boy
[Music]
e
[Laughter]
Bo
beep beep
[Music]
beep woo woo
wo
[Music]
con yes I'm
here promise you'll never forget about
me
yes of course
promise me you'll take care of our
little
girl love
her
yes with all my
heart promise me you'll stay strong for
her
yes yes I
promise and promise me you'll never
sleep with another
woman
I hear
you promise me you'll take care of Mr
big fluffy tail
yes yes yes yes that cat will be the
most loved cat in the world and that you
won't look at
porn
huh is that yes chick chick chick Chi
chity chity chity
check no pornography bust Brown says
what is that a
yes
yo better believe I her was you s girl
you love me right yes I love you yes and
we're soulmates right
yes so you will never ever ever think of
someone else while masturbating right
message received I don't understand is
that a yes you're com is that a promise
your request has been filed say you
promise forget
about huh I need to hear you say it I no
say I pr I promise you promise
you you promise
say
it okay I promise no air quotes
promises are things that love say
it I promise I promise what are you
promising I promise what you said iine
forget it yes I
mean
okay will you at least promise to go see
my mom every day so zero pornography
done I like that
nurse fix my
wife don't touch me right now not not
all about you okay but do I look in the
camera no oh at you all right like on
television all
right oh
now knock it off all the stupid ass grab
ass and touchy feeling bull godamn I
told you they was
rotten I am uh ponus Jackson uh
principal here at cloro uh Vince cloro
High uh this uh station is just a
formality there's a bunch of Stu that we
confiscated just this week St you don't
have to show them that here's a wand
with a silencer on
why but I ask again why one out of five
girls in this school is pregnant with a
demon baby what out of five okay ain't
no theing the babies are evil but the
mothers they're good kids as we said
cloros uh there's never a portal that
cannot be opened with Ingenuity and
respect how you going to be using an
invisible cloak when I can see you
tagging the damn wall dime bag of pixie
dust Contraband see here's the thing the
kids know that the only way to fly
wizard pepper unbelievable mhm get your
ass out my office I will turn you into a
spider they're good kids Hogwarts and
cloos Clos and Hogwarts go hand in hand
the best top two visiting schools there
are but you know uh out of these two
schools we each have a strength we do SC
a little bit lower on a standardized
tests than Hogwarts but there is a
cultural bias we may not have a huge
endowment like they get over at Hogwarts
and yes some of the teachers have to buy
their own no eyes or bat wings one kid
got transformed into a cat they can't
even afford a changing back this young
man's name is Jamar normally you're not
allowed to touch the students like this
when they're in human form but uh when
they're cat we just have at it
Sports everybody loves sports it's true
the hallways are a Bluster with the
conversation of our quid half the team
is back here riding mops we got two
little [__] on Swiffer
list when all is said and done uh the
average cloro student uh said this
mother sometimes the kids think it's
cute to turn themselves into a rat sneak
into my office play a little joke on me
who is that Tyrone is that is that no
this you sold me out son now you going
to end up with a bullet in your head for
it you can't play me
[__] I'm the [__] that
plays [__]
[__]
cut all right everybody let's get reset
we are going
again Nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah to well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an American tough well I'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
BBC commitment so you can play with us
cheers mate cheers Antoine listen I'm
just not buying that you're someone that
was born and raised in the streets of
Brooklyn that's weird cuz uh I actually
was born and raised on the streets of
Brooklyn I was in the gang and
everything most of this stuff actually
happened to me wow okay well that's
that's that's great for us because I
want you to use it okay it's good first
take let's just uh let's get going let's
go let's get going thank you
J scene five take
two and action you sold me out son now
you going to end up with a bullet in
your head for
it you can't play me
[__] I'm the [__] that
plays [__]
[__]
cut
cut okay uh Nigel that was great
brilliant just the way you move
especially when you talk I just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes it's fabulous cheers it's
fabulous Antoine your performance um
it's just not quite there yet okay I I
really need to see you make more of a
transformation okay like like Nigel
here
that dude's British yeah Antoine if I
might jump in with a bit of advice I
don't think I need that no no no no look
hear him out maybe you might want to try
thinking of something in the material
that's similar to something that's
happened in your real life for for me
for instance I I like to think of when
me mom wanted me to attend Prep School
in leads to become a barrister but I
wanted to study the theater at Oxford
thank God and so that was a conundrum
really for me I'm going stop you right
right there cuz it's it's just confusing
me right like I don't need that cuz I am
from the streets I was in a gang they
told me to kill my
cousin this might be a bit spot on no
yeah that's a bit spot on do you have
any stories that involve your
mom what's a
mom oh de scene five take three okay and
anine remember you're a gangster okay
betrayal the
streets okay Nigel your perfect Antoine
transform and action you sold me out
son now you going to get a blood up in
your head for
it you can't play me
[__] I'm the [__] that
plays [__]
[__] he's boring to watch
cut that does not sound
good and I do not feel like you have
found the emotional core of this
character man [__] this nobody is more
real than me okay I come from the
streets and nobody's going to tell me
what the streets is like nobody you
understand that's a great speech I just
wish that I believed it you want to give
it a shot sure I'll have a go ma [__]
this I'm as real as a guest yes these
[__] streets is for real I'm up in
there man are I'm [__] from the from
the [__] from the Earth from these
streets something to that that no but
I'm so with I'm with you when you say
that even when you're saying the wrong
words I just wish you could do
that you
what oh
goodness okay that hurts but I don't
feel that it comes from the right
emotional place for the character all
right here give it a shot give me watch
watch oh that's that's great I feel that
in here and in here very gracious in my
heart try that
again I just I don't I don't believe you
I so you got to keep the top is full
okay got it I'm on top of that you going
to fit in just fine here hey something
that might be your picture on the wall
oh employee of the year when does she
work what I was just wondering when she
works girl it's
neat
[Music]
oh
congrats now here's the best part about
working at a yoga shop is you get all
the free fro you want mhm you can't
believe how delicious it is and also fat
free thank thank God because my
boyfriend he just got back from his tour
in Afghanistan and he's coming here to
pick me up he should be here in a minute
I haven't seen him in a
year a whole year you say mhm how
some I'm good now if you need an extra
shirt or anything they're going to be in
there because these seem to shrink
uh-huh oh you know what girl I can't get
n of this stuff I mean you should have
some it's free no I'm okay I'm I'll have
some later come on girl that
free hi I just got back from Afghanistan
I'm here looking for my girlfriend
laa
[Music]
baby baby what what is
me no it's not what is
me apparently she doesn't work anymore
thanks
what oh my God he's leaving me this
morning is he leaving me this why would
he leave me what what possible reason
people leaving me but he leaving
me maybe maybe he got that PSD PSD Oh
you mean the the ptsds the ptsds you
mean the postraumatic stress
disorder it's got to be that got to be
that oh my God my baby got the
PTSD my baby got to PTSD that can be the
only
reason oh my baby my four four baby got
the
pdsd oh my
[Music]
baby it is so good to see you Keith yeah
we usually have to wait for a special
occasion well actually I have a little
surprise I got engaged
oh
son
woohoo yes
wow congratulations little
bro
engaged kind of a big deal more for me I
guess that's what that
means yes well um she got a name uh
Stephanie marriage is a wonderful
Journey 50% and the
divorce sorry bro them's just the
facts I will uh I will keep that in mind
thank
you you got a photo oh yeah AKA does she
exist there you
go oh she is
beautiful let me get eyes on this
everybody else already
had great
lighting airbrush uh no she kind of
looks like that one model uh on the
prices right uh
yes uh that's her The Price is Right
Clive that's your show shut up mom no
it's
not oh yeah Stephanie M people always
under bid on their showcases not the
best
presenter where's the wedding oh uh in
Hawaii oh
y awesome woohoo meliki
MAA she ever been married before uh no
so she says ex-boyfriend she got one of
course sloppy seconds at least right Dad
Keith she sounds wonderful thank you Mom
shut up
mom Silence from you okay you're cut off
from
talking you know what Clive I really
don't appreciate the way that you're
talking to
Mom yes yes the prodigal
hath returned you know what you want to
go let's go cuz I've been here for the
last 15 years taking care Mom and Dad
well you've been troping all over the
world and why so you can come back here
and criticize me for how I treat them no
I actually came here to ask you if you
would do me the honor of being my best
man I know that we have uh had our
differences but you're my older
[Music]
brother we we'll pay for your room and
and we're also going to rent you a car
and and we'll pay to fly you out
[Music]
there first
class well we can't afford first class
well you you're dead to
me why shut up mom I'm eating in my
room well that uh that went better than
expected I think so yeah let's get this
party started ladies and gentlemen this
is Paramount plus this is Strokes of
Genius beautiful games and One Shining
Moments this is Defenders investigators
and seven strangers picked to live in a
house this is Young SpongeBob young
Sheldon and younger this is everything
you've been looking for that's going to
leave a mark live sports breaking news
and a mountain of entertainment all
right this is Paramount plus now
streaming nobody likes you you girl well
you're a different color than me and
that's bad oh yeah well you dress like a
now hold on a second wa Mr T never make
fun of a way a man dresses way a man
dresses is his
business remember that whether it's
overalls chains or feather earrings
however they dress is not to be joked
about I pity the fool that judges
another man's
clothing I'm sorry I judge your clothing
it's
[Music]
okay
hey Scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van I don't know if that's a good
idea Timmy what are you afraid of is it
because you have a stupid name like
Scout hey whoa Mr T again never make fun
of a person's name your mama gave you
that name or you made it up for business
purposes either way it's personal I'll
pity the fool to make fun of another
man's name Mr T is a cool name it's a
cool name Mr T
[Music]
hey Scout want to do some drugs aren't
drugs bad I don't
know if you're afraid of drugs we could
drink a bunch of alcohol yum that sounds
good well guess what you're hair is
stupid never make fun of another
person's hair hey Mr T a person's hair
is the artwork that they present to the
heavens it's just like I've been
saying it isn't
fair
beare people care about their
[Music]
hair
hes for the home where I lay my head and
I cry about your mean jokes in my bed A
is for anxiety that fools provoke when
they looking at my hair and they making
jokes I is for I don't like the way I
feel when you're joking that my haircut
does not appe R is for the real mean
jokes you make and the hurtful little
pot shots that you take
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
boldness you
fools
[Music]
real teaching Center is brought to you
by
BMW the ultimate driving
[Music]
machine hello and welcome to teaching
Center I'm Boyd Maxwell with today's top
stories from the exciting world of
teaching and I'm Perry Schmidt well now
we know the long awaited Announcement by
star English teacher Ruby roof has sent
teaching fans Across the Nation into a
fr I've enjoyed my time in Ohio very
much but I'm pleased to announce that
I'm taking my talents back to New York
City thank you very much apparently PS
431 has made Ruby an offer she couldn't
refuse 80 million guaranteed over 6
years with another 40 million in
incentives based on test scores this
salary puts her right up there with
Rockridge Elementary's Katie hope and
William wo out of coate
magnet all right let's take a look at
yesterday's high school teacher draft
from Radio City Music Hall where central
Rapids High recipient of the worst test
scores last semester made the first pick
that was no surprise to
anyone with the first pick Central
Rapids High takes calculus teacher Mike
Yos from Tulsa Teachers
College and just like that you're a
millionaire Mike Yos is an unbelievable
story his father living from paycheck to
paycheck as a humble pro football player
kid was a actual math you know he's
going to buy his mom a house oh you know
this oh there's no way around that you
owe your
mom today's highlight of the day is
brought to you by the 100% Black Angus
beef thick Burger on a fresh baked bun
from Carl Jr and
Hardies now it's time for the highlight
of the
day star history teacher Ashley Ferguson
has been running up them test scores
over at Vince CL oh high okay wo
Confederate forces fired first can
anyone tell me where this battle took
place now look at this she looks left
then right looks past the students with
uh their arms up in the air spots Max
near the back sees that even though his
hand isn't up he's engaged Max it was uh
Fort Sumpter that's right oh come on see
what she did there she's bringing an
introvert into the discussion y'all
that's a teacher of the year play right
there that's right Boyd you know the
confidence gained by Max by answering
that question correctly will enhance his
performance throughout the rest of the
year No Doubt coming up after the break
Mayfield prep trades French teacher
Janine loow to Skyline High for a head
librarian and two Lunch Ladies to be
named later and we'll get the inside
scoop on the impending teacher strike
that could crippled the season next up
on teaching set
woo strength courses through me I am
velocity
I am
[Music]
power I am a leader a
Believer I am the force that
guides I am the gateway to what is
possible the path to the
future I am the future
the allnew 2015 6 series is here meet
the new
teacher okay all right good morning Tom
Jason how you doing there Dave Crystal
Tommy good morning Jake how are you
pretty good Kenny yeah yeah I you know
so early in the morning I'm sorry to be
the bearer of bad news but uh you know
how I was supposed to work late tonight
well I got to run this errand for Mr
mahina and he says that you're going to
have to cover for me so there it is I
don't even I'm sorry dropped the axe
okay so H
mhm again
yeah oh you know what just remembered Mr
mahina also almost lit my mind wants us
to uh change parking spaces what yeah me
personally I enjoy the N minute walk but
he said that we have to do it believe it
I hate it as much as you do do nothing
you can do Mr mahina said it mahina this
whole situation has been mized it just
seems a little confusing to me as to why
Mr mahina would give a [__] where we
park how's that I mean why would he care
where we park I I don't know the answer
to that question I I mean that's it's
just what he said he hey the mahina
works in mysterious ways you know what
I'm going to ask him myself cuz no
that's okay I'll do
it
uh Mr Mahin sir I I know you're busy but
can I speak to you about the parking
switch what is there to talk about Kenny
I told you and Jake to switch parking
spaces don't you know who I am I am Mr
Mah and I'm a real real person in here
now you get out of my
office wow you that it was crazy in
there I mean that
was tense
yeah you know what's really crazy though
I've been working here for about a year
and I've never even seen Mr mahina well
see now that's that's an easy one to
answer that's because he comes in before
you come in to work and he's still
working when you leave that's what makes
Mr mahina you know come on we're talking
about Mr M here right it makes perfect
sense you know I bet the hardworking
boss would love to meet a hardworking
employee you know shares the same values
so I'm gonna go ahead and just introduce
myself no
no you can't go into Mr mahina's room
are you crazy no one except me is
allowed to go in there Mr mahina is
busy okay fine you made your point clear
man thank you very much Jake I think
it's best wait no Jake wait
Jake come on
man what question Mar existance will
you will that wit turn me into a b
creature it didn't mean that people I'll
have that end of the year report to you
by
10 save the Earth from
[Music]
space
yellow Falcon what do your senses tell
you D struo is a killing
machine his armor is impervious to our
blers you got any ideas red Falcon sure
do yellow Falcon Blue Falcon you
remember our battle at Dango Bluff I'll
take the legs you take the blasters it
was Beaver Creek and I took the legs
make sure you sh up that flank Black
Falcon um are you talking to me because
I'm the green falcon no time for that
black f Falcon purple Falcon arm
missiles Roger that arming missiles
now uh battle formations we're going in
hey Roger that hold up copy that F my
Falcon is green hey hey hey we can talk
about our Falcon colors when we get back
to base Black Falcon right now we got a
mission to do fall into Falcon
formation well here's the issue is that
you're going to give me an order I'm not
going to know you're talking to me cuz
I'm not in a Black Falcon come on chill
it out black falcon yeah Black Falcon
relax first of all I don't like the way
you guys are saying Black second of all
there is no Black Falcon I'm green
falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh don't talk to me like
that no don't say Grill like that I'm
the green falcon and I oh stop being so
Black Falcon about it what the do you
mean by that black falcon brother I
understand what you're going through do
you you no I don't think you do how
would you feel if I called you red
Falcon huh whoa and purple Falcon how
would you feel if I called you yellow
Falcon huh that's a racist that was
racist yeah that's racist oh that is
racist that's racist oh see okay no
forget it Black Falcon out green falcon
green falcon damn it hey why' that green
falcon fall out of Falcon formation
Black Falcon can get on that and report
back black
falcon black falcon come in an Earth
from space
FAL
Johnny okay
Carter I can stay here all night so why
don't you and I cut the crap and you
tell me what happened on March
15th and what's in it for Carter Finley
what's in it for you is I don't send you
back to
jail the guy's name is cat branchman I
met him downtown at a club called the
clutching kitten you may have heard of
it it's down on the quarter of hang and
Fur Street cat
branchman so what's a guy like you and a
guy named
cat okay I know what you're doing Finley
you're just using what you see in my
poster I'm not detective I'm telling the
truth we'll see how much truth you tell
after a few weeks in solitary conf fine
detective you've twisted my arm that's
better
the guy's name wasn't cat
branchman it was a Chinese guy named Mr
meow he's the real gang
boss story went he hung guys from trees
and took pictures of them Finley used to
run a club downtown a front of course
called it the Paw and poster Finley ran
it with a guy named Hong
inar
okay
let's try this one more
[Music]
time
Finley who do you work
for
um coffee Mr
Coffee
Coupe coffee Coop his name was baly tall
man coffee cop now you're just talking
about me Finley I'm going to give you
one more chance
who is in charge his name was angry
man the warehouse is located in the
diploma for being a detective I want a
name Justin thank you hang tree don't
say hang godamn it do not say
hang hang nope hangman Justin cat Finley
poster do not say poster or
cat cat poster okay that's it I'm losing
my patience Winslow get this [__] out
of
[Music]
here I'm losing my
patience let's try this one more
time get been too old for
this wellplayed
detective well played
indeed hey
Carter you hang in
[Music]
there
me hey player how you doing man hey can
I make a request for sure man what are
you looking for hey man look a brother
up with some old school oh yeah all
right word okay what you looking for uh
Biggie Tupac Biggie Tupac come on man
that's too new I'm talking about that
old school man you know what I'm talking
about oh I thought I did man with like
wuang
Clan wuang Clan come on man those fools
just came out hook a brother up with
some of that old school okay what uh I
don't know what you looking for man with
NWA
NWA come on man what do I look like a
kid out there talking about the NWA F
shizel my nle crisscross applesauce
who's the boss Tony dancer adelos I
don't know it all right I'm talking
about that old school okay you know what
that's my bad old man all right we going
to take it back all right I'mma bust out
some Run DMC for you right now Run
DMC
come on man I don't know about none of
this Run DMC wouldn't want to be a aom
out of Pia grab a donkey by the toe give
him garia I don't know it all right all
I know is some old school if you can't
give it to me you can't give it to come
on man rund DMC is old
school what can you name a group you the
DJ man I ain't trying to tell you how to
do your job grandm
flash man grandm flash you look you
sound like a kid yourself talking about
my grandm flash to the oop the BB Bobby
Boop the Don't Stop The Boogie to the
bang bang boogie the upchuck why people
talking about up Chuck Sugar Hill Gang
brother how we end up in Candy Land you
know what man if you want some old
school then you come back here and find
it yourself I'm going on
break right get myself back here right
here see what's going on back here what
what we got what we got let see nope
nope NOP NOP nope no no no no no no no
nope
ah damn now we
talking
[Applause]
I bu buet bu bu what the is
happening let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
plus this is Strokes of Genius beautiful
games and One Shining Moments this is
Defenders investigators and seven
strangers picked to live in a house this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and
younger this is everything you've been
looking for that's going to leave a mark
live sports breaking news and a mountain
of entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming yo yo yo
what up what up what up welcome to
battle rap you we're going to battle rap
every day in the month of February y'all
yo I'm your host big PE
that's right to my left we got the
champion y'all introduced son yeah
what's happening this your boy Ryo de
I'm about the front hand back that's
right that's right that's right I'm we
got the Challen introduc some what's up
man I'm Dill killer in the house 100 USD
a pure me no fill right here D okay okay
okay yo Dill lost the toss so you go
first okay gentlemen battle rap all
right yeah man here we go your shook son
I'mma eat you for breakfast cuz I'm a
crook son I stole a CPP of field from
your girl breastes
yeah in the ni
man you don't even know man Hey listen
man you can't even win this 100 yard
dash but let me ask you a question what
do they call that a
[Applause]
mustache relax a little
bit take it down a little bit what the
are you doing
can you take it down a little bit
man come on what are you a
horse that's the last
one yo what's up dog you know my is Rich
I'm swimming in simoleons I mean what am
I supposed to do with this miniature
black
[Applause]
Napoleon hey man hey
get
I hey hey get
you look at look at this look at that
look at that
oh go get it man go get it that's a boy
yeah man here we go yeah look at the
chain and his F ass
timbering hey no no no no no no hey
hey I don't know what to why are you
doing me why would you no
listen come
on
you guys got to go
man you're all done man that's right man
yo we got a champion still we got a
champion
[Music]
what's me L Levi no
you list listen listen man yeah I want
you to look out on the on the lake man I
just want you to look out and imagine a
place man where you can do your thing
man where you and I can go and do our
thing but never have to Forfeit yeah you
can scream and shout and shove people
back and forth but we don't never have
to quit Okay but look out on the lake
man look out on the lake it want them
right no matter what happens man I start
rapping and my rhyme stes off the flow
and I'm turning the TI and no matter
what you do you can push and shove and
scream but we'll never get disqualified
yeah yeah yeah oh H man for good measure
while you're looking at the lake just
give me one more
[Music]
good could be worse not that bad for me
it's all about perspective it's what you
make of it can I tell you something all
things
considered I'm actually kind of
comfortable right now thank God for
shock I can be the kind of prisoner I
want to be still alive thank you right
mhm just two injured buddies yes having
a friendly convo while we're waiting to
get tortured again and you know there's
a kind of a positive in having no
options because you know we're not even
going to try to escape because we know
we'd fail yes I'll tell you another
thing don't miss the arm really first of
all Lefty okay so this thing pretty much
got in the way keep it buddy you know
you fools lathering
away your suffering has only just begun
wow that is a perfect summation of The
Human Condition once you've embraced
that you can do anything
Bingo no one has ever suffered as you
WI
you love your work and that kind of a
positive attitude quite frankly is
contagious it
is we'll see how positive you're feeling
after I cover your body in gasoline and
set you on
fire you know what it's amazing that you
would say that cuz I was just thinking
it's getting a little chilly in here
thanks so much man Dam
it what a dramatic and fascinating man I
think we owe him big time as do I really
I mean all this time away from my
computer my phone my work it's just I
feel unplugged yes yes oh
oh Circle of Life n a quena you know I
can't really feel anything anyway so you
help yourself
buddy
oh what do you got there you see this
this is what I'm going to use to cut off
your
legs
finally that's a great saw I'm a home
improvement guy and I know my saws and I
got to tell you if you're cutting off
legs that is the way to go that's the
one that is definitely the one good on
you why are you doing this to me you're
making me crazy wo whoo wo wo somebody
needs a day off we of all people should
know how hard he works mhm mhm
make stop this is
[Applause]
[Music]
torture please
Le oh I'm sorry
buddy I can't believe it
thank you so much for coming I haven't
seen you in
years
oh
yeah
oh yeah
hey
Stuart man oh I haven't seen you since
eighth grade eighth grade Miss Lacy's
class I know I
know oh you brought me flowers mhm
that's awesome that's awesome I bought
these at a store for you you have to
bring me flowers
man there you go crazy the way I went
out like that huh yeah what was that I
was like when I heard I was like what
the well well I mean Boulder what who'
have thought Boulder right I mean it's
like who gets killed by a boulder these
days well I mean I mean not me I mean
you remember I I was in Boulder Colorado
I was hiking and then I fell off that
mountain remember
you remember right Boulder Colorado yeah
I was hiking and then I no dehydrated
they couldn't find me no I was I was
saying like if you think about it
Boulder killed you well not really
Boulder I mean I wouldn't say the city
per se it was the it was the cougar that
got me and then that's what everyone was
talking about I mean I God I was out
there for like three weeks yeah jeez but
that's neither here nor there so hey did
you get that LinkedIn invitation I sent
you before I died uh you know um I I
mean I don't when I see LinkedIn I just
delete it without even checking I got
totally totally totally I get it I get
it hey so what uh what what did you want
to say to
me um what do you mean you know that's
like why people come to graveyards right
is so you can say the stuff that you you
wish you had said when someone was alive
right oh my God there's so much stuff oh
okay where do I start um take your time
man you can lay a couple on me today and
then come back yeah I mean uh I'll yeah
I can get it done here cuz that's the
whole reason I came down here and you
know yeah yeah Al my grandfather's like
two rows down there um I was going to
come to you say some things to you go to
him and sort of finish
up
oh but but you were coming to see me too
totally totally totally well fire away
man you're the only good friend I have
who's come to visit
yeah really yeah
uh-huh I just wanted to uh say that oh
if you see my
grandfather maybe you could just tell
him that like okay so you didn't come
here to visit me you came here to see
your grandfather I get it what do you
mean what are you talking
about please I'm here to see you why
right okay that's it's cool you know I
I'm just going to you know go back to
the afterlife I'm sorry I'm being
hostile it's just I'm a little
embarrassed right now I'm taking off
guard I'm just going
to no go ahead take him get him no go
ahead get him get
him
[Music]
this oh uh just that heads up though Lee
um I'm I'm probably gonna haunt you for
the rest of your life and if you have a
daughter I'm going to possess the
creepiest doll in her bedroom no just so
you know no no no no no wait
Ste Ste
St
[Applause]
[Music]
no noise
noise
[Applause]
[Music]
noise excuse
me what you doing I'm just noising your
noise
don't it's mostly about the dancers
oh yeah besides I'm kind of the guy that
says noise noise what happened nothing
happened I just noed you because of you
standing up yourself and your place in
this damn Circle no no no noise okay
noise is my thing no more noise from
you excuse me excuse me
[Music]
EXC
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
noise
noise noise noise noise
[Music]
noise
voice
[Music]
no
no no
[Music]
voice welcome to meta world news our top
story why are people always trying to
steal my
magic in other news cat litter can be
used to blind people when fighting
interesting I didn't know that well that
wraps up meta world news for this
Wednesday February biscuit fountain
drink I'm meta World Peace good
night welcome to meta world news in
sports I'd rather eat my hand than to
have my penis cut off I really have to
believe someone was going to cut it off
but if I did I can definitely eat my
hand I know because I had a dream where
I did it it was horrible I ate my whole
hand now that's what you call rhetoric
well that wraps up meta world news for
this Wednesday April hurricane slipnot
I'm meta World Peace good
[Music]
night welcome to metal world news
in fashion if you woke up and there was
a 4-in miniature human standing on your
chest would you swat them off I was
really challenged by this question I
would hope that I'd engage them in
conversation but in reality I think I'd
be scared of them and SWAT them away
which would probably kill them well that
wraps up met world news for this
Wednesday October noise canceling
octagon Tire I'm met a world peace good
night did I fulfill my contract Satan
[Music]
welcome to metalor news our top story
ninja costumes don't come in size Tri XX
which is discriminatory against enormous
assassins you know what for forget about
the teleprompter I need to speak from
the
heart well that wraps up metal world
news for this Wednesday May stable gun
hairbrush I'm met World Peace good
night
[Music]
welcome to metal world
news I
wish there was a Genie in
here well that wraps up met world news
for this Wednesday March hybrid ice rink
I'm met World Peace good night hey Jim
where's that
[Music]
Genie
welcome to meta world news our top story
the pope is thinking of moving out the
Vatican so feral cats can live there now
let's go to homemaker's corner with meta
World
piece thank you meta you need five
plastic grocery bags to make an
effective
parachute thanks meta and you will die
if you try that well that wraps up meta
world news for this Wednesday November
Morning Star cocktail napkin I'm meta
World Peace good T
[Music]
night welcome to metal world news our
top story a professional athletes should
never Post online looking for people to
liveaction role play Hunger Games with
them I'm sorry Gerard Kaye and
Zach well that wraps up metal world news
for this Wednesday August microwave wood
I'm met World Peace good
[Music]
night
welcome to metal world news in science
news it is impossible to knock yourself
out with your own fist let's not fall
behind
America well that wraps up metal world
news for this Wednesday biscuit biscuit
biscuit I'm met World Peace good
[Music]
night you win fish now I'm the one in
the
aquarium
excuse me big man big man big man excuse
me big man no but big man okay God bless
you I catch you on the up flip thank you
big man thank you big
man hey brother hey uh can I ask you a
question real quick though brother man
oh see that's good cuz I was about to
ask you a question right so here's the
deal man crazy thing my car run out of
gas about a mile up the road just away I
was just wonder if I get a little bit of
money you know just get a couple of
gallons That's crazy cuz you know what
this my car had also broke down right up
the road I got my daughter here she five
she's sleeping in the car I got to get
back to her real quick so if you could
help me out I was going to ask you if
you can help me you know saying let me
just give you my wallet out here and
show you my IDE to let you know that I
am straight up legit real I ain't trying
to trying to do nothing to nobody on the
issue of legitimacy I do have an
identification that's an employe ID from
borderers bookstore see right here I got
my B Total Fitness ID right here shows
you that I stay fit and conscientious
and whatnot you also know of these other
IDs I have in my hand have the same name
on it which makes you know that it is
indeed me right I two have multiple ID
crescendoing in this yogurt lamb punch C
okay yeah I see see that right there
that is I'm up my ninth purchase
apparently and you can't F yogurt for
that yeah all right so normally I would
not ask another person for assistance
but our our our family is in a fiduciary
crisis right now my wife is languishing
in the hospital she a construction
worker and what happened is she got
struck in the face by a power line fried
a whole head up burnt both her eyeballs
out she's getting eyeball replacement
surgery as we speak I also have a
spousal injury crisis on my midst as
well my wife was in the astronaut
program making her a full-fledged
astronaut impress she had gotten Moon
dust in her lungs inhal you never good
it's never good we don't want that so
maybe we could find an ATM or something
like that oh look that's one over there
go what's what's the chances of it we
should probably check that out yeah
let's just take a look right there here
we are well here we are ATM machines
that I did not know previously were here
all right two of them no less I'll tell
you what we should do though man you
give me the 20 okay I'll give you the
three that's on my person
I you after then you give me that 1 I'll
cut you a che for 100 just to cover that
you give me the change in cash okay okay
I feel that why am I playing I'm just
going to give you my ATM card so you
know I'm Legit of course of course I'm
going to give you my ATM card so we both
have something of value from the other
person all
right and your code is it is 1 234 and
yours sir 1 2 3 5 I thank
you
at that that is a Ralph's Rewards Card
okay that is a credit card placeholder
you would find in a translucent sleeve
and a brand new
wallet excuse me big man big man right
quick right quick can I ask you a
question biggest man question right
quick all right where you headed
youngster yeah I'm uh headed to the Cobo
building on Jefferson all right yeah
Cobo Hall Jefferson Avenue
mhm so uh what you in Detroit for uh I
got to do a presentation all right okay
yeah presentation okay yeah what are you
presenting uh actually it's about how
market research can be interpreted
without of the Box Solutions oh all
right so you goingon to get this all
outside the box all
right most people think that all
customers are a single demographic oh
okay you trying to get all them
demographics up in here all right all
right yeah
online Trends are less linear oh okay
online Trends linear
mhm also thinking about doing the
presentation naked just no clothes on oh
yeah yeah naked presentation no clothes
on that's good afterward I might just
piss on the floor in front of everyone
oh yeah okay all right pissing right
there up in front of everybody all right
sound good then I might just shoot
everybody in the place you know
with the gun I'm hiding in my ass yeah
yeah gun way up in that ass that's the
way to do it I'll cut my victim's faces
off wear them as masks yeah mask go on
the face uhhuh yeah okay N Shine H
Hitler y okay hi Hitler to you
too all right here we
are oh by the way when you kill those
people with your ass gun make sure to
use a serated blade to cut the faces
out I'll feed is
a this place is so
nice is supposed to be one of the best
uh French places in town M I did not
realize that you were so
cultured you're sweet uh my French is
pretty good so so uh I can order for
both of us you well well
well welcome
to I am your waiter for this evening my
name
is but you may call
me look at you if you have any questions
about anything at all I'm more than
happy to assist
you I got it
m well our first special tonight
is is a loop
served with a
PL that is served
on and
also
and yum our soup today is a with just a
dash of and served with
melted soup yeah our SE today we have a
very
nice from the valy in vant it is served
with the side
of man it's just I'm a little bit
overwhelmed yes oh okay I'm so glad you
said that I was about to say the same
thing so you would recommend getting
the with the um I'm sorry the and a
heavy sauce oh no no no it's more like
a what do you think I'm I'm going to
defer to him on this one because he
knows his stuff way better than I do
miss you
what um yeah we're uh we'll have
the
S uh
the I
what TR the
FL it's been nice knowing you have a
lovely
dinner
W this is not just just another
streaming app what this is so much
comedy it's not even funny are you
joking me bro this is daily late and
late late this is real roasted and raw
give it to me now this is great standup
great movies and the great corn Holio
are you threatening me no this is one
pump two pumps and three pumps hi hi
this is live sports breaking news and a
mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now
streaming
good
morning uh Clive double down
rins I'm Daniel Tate I am your parole
officer and I just want to help you how
the hell you supposed to help me man
what the you know about the streets what
with your diplomas on the wall settle
down I know that you might not be able
to relate to me but I think I know
somebody who you can't relate
to little homie what up what up it's my
favorite
CL what up dude n dog listen hey man I
ain't trying to talk to no puppet man
it's not a puppet it's little homie I
would like for you to talk to him Clive
see I used to work in the juvenile
correction systems and I found this
method very effective I ain't no
juvenile man okay he's right the does he
look like a kid do you come on he's a
grown ass man see what look it's very
important for your parole that you talk
to little
homie up little
homie desper my [__] Grumps yeah what you
getting into these days man what it is
what it is you got a job
yet I'm trying man but uh no one will
hire me yeah hey all that noise
man between you and me man ain't nobody
trying to hire with a record but hey man
what you need to be doing is get back
into some Crim
man what what what what what what's
going on man are you talking to me yeah
well you should be talking to little
homie right now yeah [__] talk to me
look at me when I'm talking to you okay
okay okay
fine
[Music]
damn so you smoking
weed no man no no little homie uh I'm
I'm I'm done with
drugs [__] I got some uhoh uhoh uhoh
look at this P Grumps smoke this week no
no no no no no man I'm I'm done man you
hear me I'm I'm done with drugs I ain't
doing all that that I don't know little
homie seems pretty serious about that
here look I'm confused man what do you
want me to do here well I want you to
clean up your act but you're not talking
to me right now you're talking to little
homie now smoke that I smoke this [__]
right
here oh
God he's out messing around I think I
think you better do what he says
wa little homie man just relax man relax
little homie take it easy I'm I'm going
to smoke it
down wait wait no no no no no no no you
can't fool me you trying to trick me man
no no I'm done with the
weed
oh
cat
dumbass now your fingerprints is on the
weapon you in this with me now
right okay little homie yeah
H well oh
oh you failed the
test I have no choice but to revoke your
par
what oh man ain't this about a [__] on
your feet baby boy get him out of here
come
on I can't believe that negr actually
thought I killed
you miss Clarissa I'm going to tell you
girl in that dress you looking about as
sweet as a feel full of honey circle
after a spring rain
shower how do you do it girl that ass
though what was that what was what what
you just said to her oh I was just
following your lead no you wasn't you
was being all heavy-handed with it man
you got to be
subtle subtle exactly you got to be
subtle you want to talk to them ladies I
can
B Miss Denise girl the way that dress is
Flowing you look like a mountain creek
after spring th simply refreshing what
is your secret way that dress fitting on
you got them titties popping
out what amazing what e yo secret what
are you do what are you doing I was just
doing what you was doing no you wasn't I
even said what is your secret that's
what btim that part was did you hear me
saying anything about anybody's
titties no you know what how about we
just say no words all together no words
all together mhm question yeah how will
I talk you're not going to talk okay all
[Music]
right ladies I'm sorry y'all hurt my eye
y'all just like SM like the sun and just
as bright in them beautiful
[Music]
dressing
vagina what the hell was that oh I did
say a word at the end there didn't I did
you see the part with all this was going
on and shaking the tail feathers and
whatnot I didn't see it I got the worst
view in the
house that's what chased them away man
all right you know what stay away from
me all
right
Miss
L you like a long stemmed Rose the way
you looking and
smelling what is your
recipe damn boy I bet you got a big old
dick and ball I love
[Music]
you
got to be careful here this place is
crawling with
them what was that what cover
me guys hey guys hey guys oh thank God
and and we started a community of
survivors y'all come live with
[Music]
us wait how did you
know come on Redneck wants us to move
into his
community us let's
go
guys over here oh thank God there are
others would you let me date your
daughter of
course oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my God please don't hurt me uh uh my
best friend's black and I love Jay-Z and
uh my favorite movie is Think Like a
Man she's good come with us okay stay
close okay what's your name Emily of of
course it
is don't shoot don't
shoot what do you think about the
police I love the third
album I I I don't have any money no
money a
a oh my God oh my God thank God you guys
showed up I got to get out of here it's
a silver Lexus just pull it right up
front and don't scuff the paint all
right I just had it
buffed
was he an alien too
[Applause]
yep
brothers and
sisters
tonight the newest member of our family
will Feast for the first
time
ailia bring the new
blood
[Music]
ah brother
tyell welcome to the first night of your
new and what are we wearing
here I'm I'm just wearing what I got bit
in
mhm okay do you have anything black or
like pants with laces up the side of the
leg be good just so you can still see
the
skin Oh no that's not my style so I
ain't got none of that in my closet or
nothing like
that okay anyway we will tonight all
[Music]
[Applause]
Feast come on man
man excuse me I'm just saying y over
here licking and and hissing and whatnot
if we going to eat then let's eat
damn yes of course we will all
[Music]
feed spread the
meat
did any of that actually get in your
mouth cuz I mean now sh no one of y'all
is hungry all the
time see uh no no no no see look why
y'all got to hiss when you flashing your
fangs you know you can make your teeth
come out with Y doing all that nonsense
see and can you two get a room seriously
y'all live in the damn Mansion there
gotta be some other place you could do
that [__] I mean are you two even
lesbians I just don't understand why
everything got to be all sexual and
licky girl seriously man you got to get
your hands up off me before I [__] you
up [__] is nasty creepy as [__] been
touching my nipple for 15 minutes all
this [__] y'all is doing up in here this
is just like straight up gratuitous I
got bit on purpose so I can live for
ever see future cars yeah Cyrus these
pants are uncomfortable and I actually
have a boyfriend and this song has been
playing for like 2 years and it
sucks this just
seems
desperate okay desperate really Tristan
it's
Christian really his name ain't even
trting so do you all feel this way yeah
yeah kind of
yeah
wow it's like you can't even get good
friends no you're not even
okay and you're leaving now that's I
mean you know what though seriously like
you could fix this place up it'd be dope
though for real our car is going to be
able to fly or is everything going to be
on a magnetic track I mean that's what I
want to know it's no big deal this otive
tastes like pennies oh I'm sorry but
baby hey come on now nipple play for
private time we talked about living is
just a dream and when we wake
up this is such [__] you guys this
is all about Susie Diaz it's Susie Diaz
this party Susie Diaz is running the
show I'm just going to show up if she
needs me to bring beer or something I'm
more than happy to
do oh dude oh my god a woman just
fainted I'm going to have to call you
back ma'am
ma'am
[Music]
um 911 what is your emergency yes yeah
I'm I'm I'm on the corner of of of fif
and Metropolitan and I just came up
across this woman and she just she just
passed out uh on the sidewalk here okay
and is she responsive sir
[Music]
um okay sir is she
responsive
sir sir um no sir if you can hear me
she's not responsive she's beautiful
[Music]
that is not relevant to this emergency
sir an ambulance is on its way in the
meantime I need you to check her pulse
sir check her pulse right check her
pulse
okay does she have a pulse sir she does
but her skin is so soft s she doesn't
have a ton of makeup but she's the kind
of girl that just doesn't need it you
can see that she put a lot of thought
into her outfit but not she's trying too
hard she's perfect sir may I remind you
that you have not spoken a word to this
woman I need you to see if she's
breathing if she yeah okay
hold sir I need you to stay on track
okay okay she not breathing the look my
life is not breathing you got to save my
baby do you know how to give mouth to M
resuscitation yes I do okay I need you
to administer that now okay
[Music]
okay
no no I can't I can't I can't do it I
can't I can't do it it's it's just it's
disrespectful I I have to be respectful
for her sir this is the only time it's
okay to put your mouth on an unconscious
woman do it I just didn't picture it
happening this way there's butterflies
in my stomach and I'm
just I don't want to mess this up it's
so rare to find sir if you can hear me
an ambulance is on its way I'm sorry I'm
sorry I I I uh oh gosh my head I'm so
like sir Stay With Me this is what it
feels like to be in love St me sir what
it must be like when you when you find
the wall sir
[Music]
are now 111 what is your emergency
there's an attractive confident welltoo
black man he just passed out right here
on the street okay ma'am listen very
carefully I'm going to need you to marry
him okay should I give him like mouth to
mouth
first yeah girl get you some
Sho thank you sir all
right all right how's every everybody
how's everybody
doing all right and you guys can all
hear me okay all right I know this guy
can right here boy this guy's ears are
so big he's laughing at jokes from the
yuck yuck Club all the way to the other
side of
town all righty and you sir you you're
doing okay right and you're getting
enough to eat is that even
possible thank you sir F folks I'm sorry
I'm going to get everybody tonight I'm
going to nobody is safe I'm getting
everybody except for you sir I'm going
to leave you alone just like your date
did tonight hello
all right okay who is next who is
next hey ma'am I get it you have breasts
okay jeez look at this chick over here
her cleavage is giving the Grand Canyon
an inferiority
[Laughter]
complex you skipped me who's who's
talking right now d
yeah hey man look at that look at that
pink shirt you got on there wow where'd
you get that queer t-shirts.com
it's in support of breast cancer
awareness I am gay
though okay go for it I can take it h oh
yeah yeah no hey yeah don't you worry
about that man gloves are coming off
okay
right there right there what's with the
three drinks man alcoholic
much this is my pain medication [__]
course it is it's your pain medication
cuz uh he is in
pain right now make fun of the
burns make make fun of the what what did
you say because here's the problem sir
is it's really dark in here here and
sorry are you burned cuz I can't make it
out thanks so much ma'am for
Illuminating him thank you that's uh I
appreciate that oh those Burns make fun
of the robot voice sir I don't know come
on I can take it okay well no you know
what I feel like the wheelchair look sir
there is nothing funny about you being
in a wheelchair and we can all oh but
there is something funny about me being
fat all right no all right fine fine
I've got it I've got it I'm doing it I'm
doing it I just didn't want to go after
this guy because I didn't want him to
kill me in my
dreams like like Freddy
Krueger oh come on cuz no you do you how
Freddy Krueger's face is burned off
that's
[Music]
not
you
[__] he said he could take it that's
what he said I thought I could but I
can't how's this on me how do we even
know if he's crying right
now come on well I don't know that sound
it just sounds like an electronic sound
are
we he said he could take
it best comic book adaptation to film
hands down no argument see you later
girls all right oh yeah um I know I'm in
the minority here but I don't really
like the Christopher Nolan Batman movies
I don't I really just feel like they're
overrated
okay well that's um that that's just an
opinion you see that's why I prefaced it
by saying I know I'm in the
minority you know what no no not really
it's not awkward at least not until you
said awkward now it's awkward because of
what you
said anyway anyway what anyway what
really because when you say anyway then
you have to follow it up with an actual
contribution to the conversation we're
having yikes no look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me there's
no yikes and the reason why there's no
yikes is because there's nothing scary
about this situation okay it's a very
low stake situation all right no not all
right come here no don't look at him
don't look at either of those guys look
at me all right all right what cuz after
you say all right you have to follow
that up with
something don't do
it don't look at them do not look at
them no no do not look at them do not
look at them don't tell us how you
really feel you know what I'll tell you
how I really feel listen I really feel
like you're an [__] who has nothing
interesting to say so what ow no don't
no no don't look it up come here turn it
right here tell me an opinion that you
have about something just one opinion
that you have about anything at all just
share an opinion anything share an
opinion share an opinion share an
opinion share an opinion right now just
on the top of your head share an opinion
anything just one opinion that's all I'm
asking share one opinion right now share
sh I I don't have an opinion and that's
why I just like everything that everyone
else likes in pop culture a
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't look at
me don't look at
me
[Music]
okay I once met a l so fine she was
drunk on barley wine I'd been to Sea for
months or three I knew I could make her
mine and the last was past consent so it
was off with her we went and we threw
her in bed and rest her head and we left
cuz that's what gentlemen
do
woman drink or two woring about what you
will do we say oh but we don't
say is
[Music]
disrespectful there once was a G from
leads who I heard was good on her knees
so I docked my ship for an overnight
trip to take care of of all my needs she
was FES Tales to tell and my mask began
to swell so I laid her down and raised
her gown and performed conolingus for an
hour or
[Applause]
so
Des down there we say oh ho but we
don't
[Music]
disrespectful I once had a woman so fair
whose womb contained my air with a Sun
by my side the Seas we'd ride the child
she would bear but my girl she was no
fool she was working her way through
school so I did support when she chose
to abort because it's her body in there
for her
choice we
don't we're talking about gold we don't
look at chest L the treasure holds with
a hand and the FEA and a on her hip we
don't say she when we're talking about a
sh we don't say fish and we don't say
[__]
Lang there was a lady with a golden eye
and the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
prayed to stay alive she awoke the very
next day and in her grave she lay but
the scariest part of the story from the
start is I bet you assume the doctor was
a man
I am
so our
[Music]
doors
of we say oh but we don't say that's
always
[Music]
disrespectful there was a slot with TT
to here and an
ass
[Music]
cuz it's your h oh but we don't say
[Applause]
[Music]
ho
hey hey I I just got a text from Charles
y'all he got on the wrong bus he's on
the other side of town other side of
town but our concert is in an hour yeah
I I know but but he wants us to warm up
and rehearse praise to the Lord Charles
said that in text okay okay well if
that's what Charles said yeah that's
okay we got this we can do this do this
come on
[Music]
yall up to the we give praise up to the
Lord we sing up to the Lord give thanks
up to the Lord we lift up to the Lord we
give praise up to the Lord we sing
merily up to
the to the I
think you're going higher youre pretty
sure this is my note in fact I'm
positive this is my note because this is
my note pretty sure this is my note
could have SW this was your note that
has never been my note where we can't
have the same note so one of us is wrong
why don't you worry about your not
I take care of my own but it's a really
bad note you are not Charles I never
said that I was Charles well you acting
like you think you Charles look I know
that I'm not Charles you can't say that
again well you're your notes and it's
messing with the rest of our notes speak
for yourself na I'm holding my notes I
wasn't trying to single you out said
everyone was off that no not everything
is about
you kiss my black
ass oh dear
lord where
[Music]
is Come on talk to me in the middle
of
Vince I uh I have that quarterly
analysis that you asked
for I had a quarter of these nuts on
your
chin
right it's just that I wanted to review
some of these numbers with you it it it
seems like our earnings are low against
our original
projections these nuts were low against
your
chin
you know Vince if you ever need to talk
to me about something I'm more than
happy to listen these nuts will be more
than happy to rest against your
chin hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kind of
funny at first these nuts were kind of
funny against your
chin Vince I'm worried about
you
I was worried about these nuts on your
chin F
seriously these nuts were seriously on
your
chin Mr Graham I just got a call from St
Mary's Hospital and your parents were in
a serious car
accident I'm so sorry but your mother is
dead and your father is on life support
these nuts are supporting life on your
chin no
way sorry
Amber Vince you got to stop it your
mother just passed away these nuts
passed away and you did no they didn't
they didn't
Vince listen you got to leave here right
now and go be with your dad this could
be the last time that you get to see him
this could be the last time I get to see
my nuts on your God damn it Vincent
you're fck father might be
dying these nuts might be dying on your
[Music]
chin God damn it f snap the [__] out of
it your mother is
[Music]
dead right you're right you okay I'm
okay you're all right you're back I
don't know what came over me that's
right it was so
good was just it worked in every
situation
I know I know and it's always it's just
so funny well it wasn't it wasn't that
funny it was
funny it really wasn't that funny
Vince really
funny I would not go so far as to say it
was really funny Vince funny but it
wasn't
though it
was it
wasn't agree to disagree it's funny okay
it's f one more time I just got to go
record to sing it wasn't really that
funny want go see my dad that was funny
wasn't that
[Music]
funny
dad Stay With Me
dad I love
you and I
love these nuts on your
chin n of your chin
[Music]
he J dinkle Ed yeah L
Carron check out
Leos I wonder what he's dreaming about
he is probably dreaming about what we is
going to do to the team from the
West I
Wonder
[Music]
to variousness T King for short I'm a
bad man and an awful sport smooch wace
you can call me Ty Royal rapping up
rushes like aluminum foils Theo I'm very
scary if I got the ball you best be lar
Patron Duke Mar I love the ball so much
I want to marry it cuz the Easter
schools going to Le the PO on the west
oh
yeah where football's concerned we going
to show you that we are the best we are
the
best I'm ibraim Mo s and my rhs are
clean like my name was Dr s po third
they call me the pro I can inter balls
with my ear shower handle that's my name
power candle sounds the same with Jack
Mar s Lamar black and waxon play sax
Demarcus plays
[Music]
guitar the
West okay don't you
know foot we going to show you that we
are the best indeed we are the
best it must have been all a
dream
or was
[Music]
it oh it's
on what's up y'all it's Jeffers spin I'm
the big left tackle going to help us win
X at ousness I'll use my Force to give
the East distress H goodness platter is
where running through theathers and
pading my stats y'all know me I'm
washing beard catch so many balls it's a
little weird cuz you know we're going to
win against the East what we we going to
get the most points and they going to
get the least trying to call the voices
running through my head back it up is I
hit the QB and make a noise like can't
block me and all of that jazz cuz y'all
don't want none of this
osati the player TJ AJ day Formerly
Known le as Mouse cop and Don I'm the
touchdown man that's grundle but y'all
ain't ready for my man Dam
Smith yo yo Smith comma Daniel kick Le
don't hold a candle cheers up I'm a
Chate crotch goddamn baby
[__] the [__] want to get with me got
sweet and D rolling num some team kou
hitting field goals blunted been drunk
when I ped been like aund times that I
already done it oh see these haters
thought I was playing staying away from
my faces with all the bull they saying
but just remember talking when you
tossing those gauntlets I'm Dan Smith
and the West is getting rowdy like
[Applause]
[Music]
Monsters what if we told y'all that once
a month half the human RAC is in pain
and the the other half don't want to
hear [__] about
it B Mar I'm T Tombstone welcome to
menstruation
orientation oh no you don't now we know
you don't want to hear about it but they
don't want to have it so sit your ass
down and listen for once in your life
today we going to talk to all you men
about what happens to your women when
they are on their periods and why it's
important to be sensitive to that [__]
don't say chillax relax calm down and
don't say ass fat grumpy or cranky they
ain't cranky they got blood coming out
of their vaginas y that's some biblical
plague [__] y'all that would be like
once a month if you had Locust flying
out of your dick for a week your ass
wouldn't be cranky your ass will be like
oh
[__] what
Happ so be nice to your [__] when
they bleed in if you ain't getting them
[__] get the [__] out their way they got
crbs they got headaches they got weight
gam and every time they pee it's like
the shining in the toilet be supportive
the empathetic but whatever you do do
not try to solve it don't even bring
that [__] up when women be hanging out
together their periods will sink up
vaginas be communicating they got their
own vagina language talking
about oh man oh
God if you find yourself around a group
of women and they all have a back ache
back away slowly what's that in your
pocket there so boots recognize this
[__] that ain't space Dynamite
that's a terod learn what your [__] has
to go through first you put this piece
in your vagina then you push this part
into the first piece then you throw this
part away do that several times a day
for a week every goddamn month it's the
worst thing ever all the time and it's
much worse for them than it is for you
to hear about it and periods is
important that's how the body gets rid
of the old eggs so it can cook up them
new ones so listen to what's going on
with your female emotionally and get
your [__] some chocolate don't call her
a [__] but get your B some
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate chocolate CH Chate
ch ch ch ch Chate Chate ch ch Chate ch
let's get this party started ladies and
gentlemen this is Paramount plus W this
is Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moment this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers pick
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and younger this
is everything you've been looking for
that's going to leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment right this is Paramount
plus now
streaming